ALLEN ARCHULETA ATKINS WELL.
BRADFORD CABALLERO DODD TORONTO
GALGIANI GLAZER GONZALEZ
HERTZBERG HILL HUESO HURTADO
JACKSON LEYVA MCGUIRE MITCHELL
MORNING. NIELSEN PAM PORTANTINO.
ROUGH RUBIO SKINNER STERN
AMBERG BY CASKEY WIENER. WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO OUR MEMBERS
WHO ARE PARTICIPATING REMOTELY.
FACE YOU KNOW. THAT'S OKAY
GORGEOUS WHERE'S PRESIDENT.
CHIANG HERE SENDING. CENTER CAN
CAN YOU PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
CHANGE PRESENT. DALLY. SENATE
BILL YOU'RE ON MUTE. DALY
PRESENT PERFECT. GROSS
INTERGRADES PRESENT. MELENDEZ
BLENDERS PRESENT. WE HAVE TO GO
BACK AND SEE HER SENATOR
MELINDA'S IF YOU COULD TAKE
YOURSELF ARM OFF OF THE BLANKS
THROUGH THERE YOU ARE GO AHEAD
I DIDN'T DO ANYTHING MELINDA'S
PRESENT PERFECT THANK YOU.
MORLOCK. REPORTING AND
RESIDENTS WERE LIKE PRESIDENT.
THEY MORLOCK IF YOU CAN SAY IT
AGAIN CENTER MORE WATER NOW ON
THE SCREEN. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT MORLOCK PRESIDENT.
GRAYSON THANK YOU SIR. MORALE.
WILK. WILK PRESIDENT WELL. GOOD.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT MEMBERS I
WANT TO THANK EVERYONE WHO IS
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY AND HERE
ON THE FLOOR FOR YOUR PATIENCE
I THINK WE ARE DOING A
PHENOMENAL JOB IN OUR NEW
NORMAL AND OUR NEW REALITY WITH
THAT MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS ON
THE RAIL AND IN THE GALLERY
PLEASE RISE WILL BE LED IN
PRAYER THIS MORNING BY SENATOR
BILL AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING WILL BE LED IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE
FLAG BUT SENATOR MONNING.
SENATOR BILL. MADAM PRESIDENT-
I'VE BEEN GUIDED BY. A PRAYER
SINCE I WAS FOURTEEN YEARS OLD
AND IT WAS TAUGHT TO ME BY- THE
JUDGE WORDS. AND IT'S THE PER
SE NATION IS SOME SAFETY. AND
IT'S ABOUT DECISION MAKING AND
DISCERNMENT WHICH WE ARE ABOUT
TO. REALLY HAVE AN INTENSIVE
EFFORT IN THE LAST COUPLE DAYS
SO I THOUGHT I'D GIVE THIS
PRAYER. TAKE LORD. AND RECEIVE
ALL MY LIBERTY. MY MEMORY. MY
UNDERSTANDING MY ENTIRE WILL.
ALL THAT I HAVE IN POSSESS YOU
HAVE GIVEN. ALL TO ME. TO YOU I
RETURN IT. ALL THE JURORS
DISPOSE OF IT. IN HOLY
ACCORDING TO YOUR WILL. GIVE ME
YOUR LOVE YOUR GRACE FOR THIS
IS SUFFICIENT FOR ME. THANK YOU.
MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME IN THE
PLEDGE TO OUR FLAG I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE. YEAH. GOOD MORNING
MEMBERS HAPPY SATURDAY THERE
ARE NO PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ MESSAGES FROM
THE ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED
READ REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL
BE DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED WE ARE NOW MOVING TO
MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
CAN PURSUANT TO THE SENATE RULE
TWENTY NINE TEN D. THE
FOLLOWING BILLS ARE REFERRED TO
THE RULES COMMITTEE I AM TWENTY
SIX SB FOURTEEN FIFTY NINE.
PURSUANT TO SENATE RULE TWENTY
NINE TEN SEE THE FOLLOWING
BILLS ARE REFERRED TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE ITEM ONE AB. THREE
ZERO EIGHT EIGHT. MEMBERS WE
ARE GOING TO MOVE TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE
WE'RE GOING TO START WITH THE
READING OF THE SECOND FILE
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE L.
881-788-2004 SEVEN THIRTEEN.
EIGHT NINETY THREE TWENTY SIX.
SIX THIRTY NINE EIGHT FORTY ONE
AND ASSEMBLY BILL THREE THIRTY
ONE. THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY
THE SECOND READING FILE HAS
BEEN READ WE'RE NOW GOING TO
MOVE TO GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS
WE'RE GOING TO START WITH FILE
ITEM NUMBER TEN. MATT APPROACH
HIM BEGIN WHENEVER YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT FILE ITEM TEN IS THE
CONFIRMATION OF GABRIEL SEND OF
ALL TO THE FAIR EMPLOYMENT AND
HOUSING COUNCIL THE COUNCIL
DEVELOPS REGULATIONS TO
IMPLEMENT CALIFORNIA CIVIL
RIGHTS LAWS MR SANDOVAL IS AN
ATTORNEY AND HAS SERVED AS A
SENIOR ADVISER IN THE WHITE
HOUSE. AND A SENIOR COUNSEL IN
THE OFFICE OF CIVIL RIGHTS AT
THE U. S. DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION HE WAS APPROVED IN
THE SENATE RULES COMMITTEE ON
AUGUST FIFTH I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. MEMBERS ON
THE FLOOR IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
NONE MEMBERS PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY IS THERE ANY DEBATE.
SEEING NO HANDS RAISED MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN ARCHULETA I ATKINS I FELT
I BRADFORD HI CABALLERO. DODD I
TO RAZA I GALGIANI HI GLAZER.
GONZALEZ HI HERTZBERG I HILL I
WAS SO. HURTADO HI JACKSON I
LEYVA I MCGUIRE I MITCHELL. I
MONEY. I NIELSEN. PAN FIVE
PORTANTINO FIVE ROTH. I RUBIO.
SKINNER STERN. NUMBER HI MY
CASKEY HI WIENER. I WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO OUR MEMBERS WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. BATES
BATES FILE ITEM NUMBER NINE
GABRIEL SANDOVAL OPPOSE. BABIES
NO. ONE MOMENT PLEASE SENATOR
BATES I BELIEVE THAT WAS FILE
ITEM TEN IS THAT WHAT YOU SAID.
I WAS ON THE RUN PCS IS GABRIEL
SANDOVAL. NO THANK YOU I SAID
BATES NO FOR JUST. SUBMERGES
FILE TEN NO PORGES NO CHIANG.
HANGING FILE ITEM TEN AT
STAINED. DALLY GALLATE FILE
ITEM TEN NO DALLY NO GROWTH.
FILE ITEM TEN NO. GROVE NO
MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ FILE ITEM
TEN NOW MULLIN. MELENDEZ NO
MORE LOCK. FILE TEN NO. THERE
ARE MORE LIKE ONE MOMENT WE DID
NOT SEE YOU ON THE SCREEN
THROUGH NO FAULT OF YOUR OWN.
THERE YOU ARE IF YOU CAN TAKE
YOURSELF OFF MUTE AND STATE
THAT AGAIN THAT BE GREAT.
ANDREAS MEMBERS OF MY SCREEN
JUST DISAPPEARED YES. WELL I
DIDN'T IN NO MORE LUCK NOW
MORALE. NO MORE ROOM SO CENTER
MORALE WHICH- ITEM ARE YOU
REFERRING TO I NEED YOU TO
STATE THAT FOR ME PLEASE AS TO
THE APPOINTEE. GABRIEL SANDOVAL
BECAUSE IT MIGHT. FRIENDS HERE
ARE HER CODEINE ITEM NUMBER TEN
AND SAYS I AND NUMBER NINE ON
MY- BUT IT'S TO BUY. REGARDING
GABRIEL'S SAM OF ALL THANK YOU
SIR THANK YOU MORRELL NO. WILK.
FOR A MEETING SANDOVAL ABSE.
THANK YOU SENATOR MOVES A CALL.
CENTER GROVE FOR WHAT PURPOSE.
I'M NOT INTERESTED AND I
APPRECIATE YOU CALLING ON ME I
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE A REQUEST
THAT YOU RECALL ALL THE REMOTE
MEMBERS AND HAVE THEM STATE
FILE ITEM TEN GABRIEL SANDOVAL
GOVERNOR AND GUBERNATORIAL
APPOINTMENT TO THEIR EMPLOYMENT
AND HOUSING NOT JUST SIMPLY
FILE ITEM TEN SO IF YOU COULD
RECALL OUR MEMBERS I WOULD
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT. ONE
MOMENT SENATOR.
SENATORS IN THE
ROOM AND THOSE THAT ARE
PARTICIPATINGREMOTELY WE ARE
GOING TO ACCOMMODATE SENATOR
GROVES REQUEST AND WE'RE GOING
TO CALL AGAIN THE REMOTE
MEMBERS ON FILE ITEM TEN
GABRIEL SANDOVAL AS APPOINTED
BY THE GOVERNOR TO THE FAIR
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING COUNCIL
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
REMOTE VOTING MEMBERS. FIX HI
LEFT FILE ITEM TWO IN THE
VENDOR OF APPOINTMENT GABRIEL
SAW THEM ALL FOR THEIR
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING COUNCIL
NO. EIGHT NO BORJAS. OVERTURES
FILED TEN NO. SENATE SENATOR
BORDERS I BELIEVE THAT- YOUR
LEADER ASKED YOU TO STAY OR
JUST A MILE TEN GABRIEL
SANDOVAL POINTY TO FOR
APPOINTMENT HOUSING COUNCIL NOW
THANK YOU FOR JUST NO CHIANG.
BUT I'M NUMBER TEN GAVE US AN
OF ALL MEMBER PLANNING AND
HOUSING COUNCIL ABSTAINED.
DALLYING BALLY FILE ITEM TEN
GABRIEL SANDOVAL NUMBER OF FAIR
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING COUNCIL
NO. SENATOR CHIANG AYE PART IS
WE HAVE TO GO BACK TO BECAUSE
WE GOT ALL OF IT EXCEPT HE DID
NOT STATE YOUR NAME. J. FILE
ITEM TEN GABRIEL SANDOVAL
MEMBER FAIR EMPLOYMENT AND
HOUSING COUNCIL AND STATE
PERFECT. DALLY. YOU'RE GOOD
SENATOR DAILY TALLY NO GROWTH.
GRILLS FILE ITEM TEN GABRIEL
SANDOVAL TO THEIR EMPLOYMENT
AND HOUSING COUNCIL NO. GROVE
NO MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ ON
GABRIEL SANDOVAL MEMBER THE
FAIR EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING
COUNCIL NOW. MELENDEZ NO MORE
LOCK. BARLACH I ITEM IN GABRIEL
SANDOVAL MEMBER FAIR EMPLOYMENT
AND HOUSING COUNCIL NO. MORLOCK
NO MARONE. THIS SENATOR MORRELL
ON ITEM NUMBER TEN ON THE
APPOINTMENT OF GABRIEL SANDOVAL
TO THE MEMBER FAIR EMPLOYMENT
HOUSING COUNCIL NOW. THANK YOU.
MORALE NO MILK WILK. THE CENTER
WILL BE WERE ON MUTE PLEASE
UNMUTE YOURSELF. YES I DO YOU
CAN YOU HEAR ME NOW. WE CAN.
OKAY GOOD- CENTER WILK FILE
ITEM JAN. DURING THE
APPOINTMENT GABRIEL SANDOVAL AS
A MEMBER OF THE FAIR EMPLOYMENT
AND HOUSING COUNCIL AT ST THANK
YOU CENTER WILK. RUBIO I. THINK
IT'S AN RUBIO OF CENTER GROVE
YOUR HAND IS STILL LET DID YOU
HAVE A ADDITIONAL QUESTION. NO
MA'AM I APOLOGIZE I'M NOT
REMOVE IT IMMEDIATELY NOT A
PROBLEM SENATOR MOVES THE FILE
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM ELEVEN SENATOR
ATKINS. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT FILE ITEM NUMBER
ELEVEN IS THE CONFIRMATION OF
DOCTOR MEREDITH WILLIAMS AS THE
DIRECTOR OF THE DEPARTMENT OF
TOXIC SUBSTANCES CONTROL. DR
WILLIAMS PREVIOUSLY SERVED AS
ACTING DIRECTOR AT THE
DEPARTMENT AND AS DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF SAFER PRODUCTS AND
WORKPLACE PROGRAM SINCE TWENTY
THIRTEEN. SHE EARNED A DOCTOR
OF PHILOSOPHY DEGREE IN PHYSICS
FROM NORTH CAROLINA STATE
UNIVERSITY. SHE WAS APPROVED ON
A UNANIMOUS VOTE IN THE SENATE
RULES COMMITTEE ON AUGUST
TWELFTH RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU MADAM
PRO TEM MEMBERS DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE GOING TO OUR MEMBERS ON
THE FLOOR FIRST SENATOR WHITE
HOUSE SKI. MEN PRESENT I RACES
SUPPORT OF DR WILLIAMS IT'S
HARD TO IMAGINE A MORE
THANKLESS JOB IN GOVERNMENT IN
CALIFORNIA THAN BEING THE
DIRECTOR OF DGSE- THIS IS
TAKING ON THIS ISSUE HE'S BEEN
IN THE POST SINCE TWENTY
NINETEEN HE KNOWS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE IS WORKING ON.
REVISIONS THAT WERE PART OF THE
INDEPENDENT REVIEW REVIEW PANEL
WHICH SHE'S BEEN. YOU KNOW
TRYING TO GIVE MORE CONFIDENCE
INTO THE AGENCY AS WELL AS A
TWO THIRDS VOTE TO INCREASE THE
FEES THIS IS SOMETHING THAT'S
ON. BOTH THE SENATE AND THE
HOUSE SOMETHING WILL BE TAKEN
UP NEXT YEAR BUT WE'VE GOT TO
GIVE THE TOOLS TO- THE DIRECTOR
WHETHER SHE'S DEALING WITH THE
FIFTEEN HUNDRED. YOU KNOW FIRST
SITES TENDER TOSCA THAT HAVE
NOT BEEN CLEANED UP AND HAVE
NOT EVEN BEEN IDENTIFIED OR THE
HAZARDOUS WASTE MANAGEMENT
PLANS SO I STRONGLY URGE. THE
CONNECT CONTINUATION BETWEEN
THE EXECUTIVE THE LEGISLATURE
IN FIXING UP THIS DEPARTMENT.
THANK YOU SENATOR WHITE HOUSE
E. SEEING NO FURTHER OF MIKE'S
UP FOR MEMBERS ON THE FLOOR
WE'RE GOING TO GO TO OUR
MEMBERS WHO ARE PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY. I DO NOT. SEE ANY
HANDS RAISED. MAN SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS I FELL
FIVE BRADFORD AYE CABALLERO.
DODD HI DURAZO HI GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER. GONZALEZ FIVE HERTZBERG
I HILL I LISTEN HI HER TADO I
JACKSON. I LEYVA. I MCGUIRE I
MITCHELL. I MONNING. I NIELSEN.
PAN FIVE PORTANTINO. I ROTH. HI
RUBIO I SKINNER STERN NUMBER I
WHITE HOUSE SKI FIVE WIENER HI.
PLEASEPROCEED TO OUR MEMBERS
WERE PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
SENATOR MORLOCK THIS IS FOR YOU
DIRECTLY WE'RE HAVING A PROBLEM
WITH YOUR FEED SO WE'RE NOT
GOING TO COME TO YOU RIGHT NOW
BUT WE WILL COME BACK TO YOU.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
REMOTE MEMBERS. BATES.
CENTERBRIDGE ROMEO. CHECK OUT
SORRY THANK YOU. FILE NUMBER
ELEVEN MEREDITH WILLIAMS
DIRECTOR DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC
SUBSTANCES CONTROL HI SENATOR
BATES HI. BASED FIVE PORGES
WE'RE JUST FOLLOW EVAN WILLIAMS
POINTY DEPARTMENT TALKS
SUBSTANCE CONTROL ONLINE FOR
AGES I CHIANG. FILE ITEM ELEVEN
MEREDITH WILLIAMS I'M SORRY
CHANGE FILE ITEM ELEVEN
MEREDITH WILLIAMS DIRECTOR
DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC SUBSTANCES
HI CHIANG I DALY. GALLEY FILE
ITEM LEVIN MEREDITH WILLIAMS
DIRECTOR DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC
SUBSTANCES HI DALLY FIVE GROWTH.
HE MET A PRESIDENT TO FILE ITEM
ELEVEN MEREDITH WILLIAMS
DEPARTMENTS TOXIC SUBSTANCES
CONTROL HI. GROVE FIVE MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ VIOLIN LEVIN MEREDITH
WILLIAMS DIRECTOR DEPARTMENT-
TOXIC SUBSTANCES CONTROL BY LAW
BY. BROWN YES THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT- ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN
ON MEREDITH WILLIAMS DIRECTOR
DEPARTMENT OF PROXY SUBSTANCE
HI. NAME CENTER MORAL SENATOR
MARIA. THANK YOU MORALE HI WILK.
WILK FILE ITEM ELEVEN DR
MEREDITH WILLIAMS AS DIRECTOR
DEPARTMENT TOXIC IN SUCH AS
CONTROL HI. WILK HI THANK YOU
CENTER MORE LIKE WE WILL GET
BACK TO YOU WILL HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE ON THIS
MEASURE FOR NOW WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE A CALL AND MOVE ON TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE MEN
APPROACHED HIM. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT FILE ITEM NUMBER
TWELVE IS THE CONFIRMATION OF
ANDREW JACK AMINI AS A MEMBER
OF THE HASTINGS COLLEGE. OF THE
LAW BOARD OF DIRECTORS. MISTER
JACK COMMITTEE HAS BEEN
MANAGING PARTNER AT HANSON
BRIDGETT LLP SINCE TWO THOUSAND
TWO. EARNED HIS JURIS DOCTOR
DEGREE AT HASTINGS COLLEGE OF
LAW HE WAS APPROVED IN THE
SENATE RULES COMMITTEE ON
AUGUST TWELFTH. RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU MADAM PRO TEM MEMBERS ON
THE FLOOR ANY QUESTIONS OR
DEBATE SENATOR WIENER. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE IN
SUPPORT. THE NOMINEE- I. KNOW
HIM THROUGH THE SEVERANCE. I
KNOW MISTER JACK COMMUNITY- TO
THE SAN FRANCISCO LEGAL
COMMUNITY HE IS A- LEADER IN
OUR COMMUNITY- INCREDIBLY WELL
QUALIFIED- TO BE ON. THE BOARD
FOR HASTINGS WHICH IS SUCH AN
IMPORTANT LEGAL INSTITUTION IN
THE BEARING CALIFORNIA AND I US
FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
CENTER WIENER SEEING. CENTER
NIELSEN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SEEING NO FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE FLOOR WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE TO OUR MEMBERS FOR
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY. I DO
NOT SEE ANY HANDS RAISED. OKAY
MA'AM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN. I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS I FELL I BRADFORD I
CABALLERO I DODD. I TO RAZA. I
GALGIANI I GLAZER GONZALEZ I
HERTZBERG HI HILL AYE HUESO. I
HER TADO. HI JACKSON. I LEYVA I
MCGUIRE I MITCHELL I MONEY. I
NIELSEN I CAN HI PORTANTINO. HI
ROTH. I RUBIO HI SKINNER. STERN
NUMBER FIVE Y. CASKEY HI WIENER
HI. THANK YOU MA'AM SECRETARY
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO OUR
MEMBERS WHO ARE VOTING REMOTELY
AND YOU'RE DOING A GREAT JOB.
THANK YOU OUR MEMBERS WHO ARE
PROVISIONS PAID REMOTELY YOU
ARE DOING A GREAT JOB NAME
MAJOR POSITION AND CENTER
MORLOCK WE ARE GOING TO COME TO
YOU THIS TIME BECAUSE WE THINK
WE'VE GOT THAT FEED WORKING.
BUT WE'LL START WITH MADAM
SECRETARY. BASICS BATES FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE HUNDRED
YOUNG COMMUNITY MEMBER HASTINGS
COLLEGE OF THE LAW BOARD OF
DIRECTORS ABSTAINED. GORGEOUS
ORDERS FILE TWELVE- MISTER-
GIOCA MEANIN- HASTINGS BOARD
OF DIRECTORS AYE BARGES AYE
CHIANG. ALL AT THE CHIANG FILE
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE JET
COMMUNITY THIS IS CALLED BLOCK
STATE. DALLY. DALLY FILE ITEM
WELL IN YOUR JACKET ME MEMBER
HASTINGS COLLEGE. GROVE FILE
ITEM TWELVE ANDREW JACKSON
MEANIE- AT HASTINGS COLLEGE
SIXTEEN. MELENDEZ MELENDEZ FILE
ITEM TWELVE INJURED JACKING
MANY APPOINTMENTS TO THE
HOUSTON COLLEGE ARAMBULA BOARD
OF DIRECTORS NO. MELENDEZ NO
MORE LOCK. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT GLAD TO BE BACK
IN PARTICIPATING- FIRST- ITEM
ELEVEN WILLIAMS DIRECTOR OF THE
CENTER MARKS SANTA MONICA NEED
YOU JUST TO VOTE ON THE MEASURE
BEFORE US WHICH IS FILE ITEM
TWELVE WE WILL COME BACK WHEN
WE LIVE CALLS. ON THAT MEASURE
SO YOU'LL BE ABLE TO VOTE THEN.
COOLEY UNDERSTOOD THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT MY APOLOGIES
FOR TRYING TO BE EFFICIENT- I
DON'T. I DON'T SWELLS AND DREW
GEODE MANY MEMBER CASE THINGS
COLLEGE OF THE LAW BOARD OF
DIRECTORS I WOULD LIKE TO
EXCHANGE. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT THANK YOU MURROW. YES
I THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
SENATOR MORALE ON ITEM NUMBER
TWO TWELVE ON ANDREW JACKAL
MEANIE- FOR THE MEMBER OF THE
HASTINGS COLLEGE OF THE LAW
BOARD OF DIRECTORS KNOW. MORALE
NO WILK. HE WILK FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE POINT OF ENTRY
GIACOMINI TO THE HASTINGS
COLLEGE A LOT OF BOARD OF
DIRECTORS ABSTAINED. THANK YOU
MEMBERS ALL RIGHT WE HAVE GONE
THROUGH THE APPOINTMENTS WE ARE
NOW MOVING TO. ASSEMBLY THIRD
READING. SORRY SENATOR MOVES A
CALL NOW WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO ASSEMBLY THIRD READING WE'RE
GOING TO START WITH FILE ITEM
THIRTY ONE. SENATOR MCGUIRE.
THURMOND WHERE WOULD LIKE TO
PRESENT FILE ITEM THIRTY ONE.
VERY GOOD WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO
FILE ITEM THIRTY TWO SENATOR
PAN MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL IT TWENTY SEVENTY
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER TING AN
ACT RELATING TO HEALING ARTS
CENTER PM THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT- PLEASED TO PRESENT
EIGHTY TWO OH SEVEN SEVEN BY
SOME MEMBER TEAM WHICH WILL
ALLOW PHARMACISTS TO SELL
SYRINGES WITHOUT A PRESCRIPTION
TO HELP PREVENT THE SPREAD OF
HIV AND HEPATITIS C. THIS BILL
SPECIFICALLY EXTENDS THE SUNSET
FOR JUST ANOTHER FIVE YEARS
UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY SIX- MORE
TWO HUNDRED STUDIES AROUND THE
WORLD HAVE CONSISTENTLY SHOWN
THAT APPROVING SYRINGE. ACCESS
REDUCES THE RATE A SYRINGE
SHARING AND DISEASE
TRANSMISSION WITHOUT INCREASING
THE RATE OF DRUG USE DRUG
INJECTION OR CRIME THIS STUDY
HAS FOUND OTHERWISE IN FACT
RESEARCH BY OUR CALIFORNIA FOR
PUBLIC HEALTH IS INCLUDED NO
EVIDENCE OF INCREASED DRUG USE
OR CRIME IN THE STATE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATED WITH THE
AUTHORIZED. USE OF SYRINGES
WITHOUT A PRESCRIPTION I WOULD
NOTE THAT THIS- THIS THE
SITUATION'S BEEN IN PLACE FOR A
WHILE AT ACTUALLY IN. THE
STATE- AND SO JUST EXTENDING
THIS ANOTHER FIVE YEARS IS
GOING TO HELP CONTINUE TO BE
SURE WE PREVENT THE SPREAD OF
HIV AND HEPATITIS C. STRONGLY
SUPPORTED- BY PUBLIC HEALTH
EVIDENCE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
KNIGHTHOODS THANK YOU SENATOR
PAN MEMBERS ON THE FLOOR.
DISCUSSION AND OR DEBATE.
SEEING IN HERE NONE. WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO OUR MEMBERS WHO
ARE PARTICIPATING REMOTELY AND
I SEE SENATOR GROVES HAND UP
SENATOR GROVE. HE CAME OUT OF
PRESIDENT I RISE IN OPPOSITION
IN THIS BILL I MEAN TO ENABLE
PEOPLE TO HAVE- SYRINGES OR
HYPODERMIC NEEDLES. AND A
NEEDLE TO HAVE THEM FREELY
WITHOUT A PRESCRIPTION IT'S
JUST NOT GOOD COMMON SENSE WHAT
WE NEED TO DO IS MAKE SURE THAT
WE- HELP PEOPLE GET OFF OF THAT
ADDICTIONS THAT THEY HAVE SO
THAT THEY CAN LEAVE. LIVE
VIBRANT AND FULL LIVES- I DO
DISAGREE WITH THE AUTHOR THAT
SAYS THAT THERE IS STATISTICAL
DATA OUT THERE THAT SAYS. THAT
NO PROVIDING THESE HYBRID
DURING NEEDLES ARE THESE
NEEDLES I REDUCES CRIME- I DO
TO AYE. DADDY IN THE
INFORMATION THAT I HAVE SAYS
THAT IS NOT TRUE SO I DO I DO
DISAGREE WITH THAT AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO VOTE.
THANK YOU CENTER GROVE. I SEE
NO OTHER HANDS UP ON OUR REMOTE
VOTING. MEMBERS BUT I DO SEE
SENATOR WIENER SENATOR WIENER.
THANK YOU- AS A- REPRESENTED AS
A SENATOR REPRESENTING- THE
CITY DOES PRIME MORE DEEPLY
IMPACTED BY HIV THAN ANY CITY
IN THE WORLD- I DO- TO THE NEED
TO RESPOND TO THE- COMMENTS BY
THE SENATOR FROM BAKERSFIELD
RESPECTFULLY- FOR PEOPLE WHO
ARE ADDICTED AND ACTING THEY'RE
GOING TO INJECT NO MATTER WHAT
WE DO AND SO WE GOT THEM INTO A
RECOVERY PROGRAM WHICH WE- WORK
VERY HARD TO DO. AND THE
QUESTION IS ARE THEY GOING TO
INTERACT WITH A CLEAN NEEDLE OR
INTERACT WITH A USED NEEDLE
WHERE THEY CAN GET HIV
HEPATITIS OR ANY OTHER MATTER.
OF INFECTION THE QUESTION IS
NOT WHETHER WE'RE GOING TO
BERATE THEM AND JUST TELL THEM
TO STOP INJECTING WE HAVE TO DO
THE HARD WORK TO GET THEM IN
THE RECOVERY- BUT IF WE HAVE A
CHOICE WHICH IS WHAT THE
CHOICES BEFORE US TODAY CLEAN
NEEDLE OR DIRTY NEEDLE I GO
WITH A CLEAN YOU KNOW FROM THE
PHARMACIST ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR WIENER
SEEING NO FURTHER DISCUSSION ON
THE FLOOR OR REMOTELY CENTER
PAN YOU MAY CLOSE THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT I JUST WANNA BE
SURE THAT- WHAT HE SAID WAS
UNDERSTOOD CLEARLY- FIRST OF
ALL THIS IS ABOUT REDUCTION IN
THE SPREAD OF HIV AND HEPATITIS
C. BOTH WHICH ARE CONTAGIOUS
DISEASES OF SOMEONE TAXES THAT
THEY CAN GIVE IT TO OTHER
PEOPLE. SECOND MIGHT STILL WANT
TO BE CLEAR THAT THE EVIDENCE
SHOWS THERE'S NO INCREASE IN
CRIME SO I APPRECIATE THE
POINTING OUT ABOUT CRIME AND
DECREASING BUT WHAT DOES DOIS
IT DECREASES THE SPREAD OF
INFECTION WITHOUT INCREASING
CRIME RATES WITH THAT I THINK
THAT'S A GOOD COMMON SENSE
THING TO DO I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR PAN. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN I
ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS I FELT.
BRADFORD FIVE CABRERA I DON'T
DODD. HI TORONTO. I GALGIANI HI
GLAZER GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG I
HILL HI WITH SO HI HER TADO. NO
JACKSON. I LEYVA I MCGUIRE I
MITCHELL. I MONEY I NIELSEN. NO
HAN I PORTANTINO. I ROTH. I
RUBIO. FIVE SKINNER STERN.
AMBERG I Y. CASKEY HI WIENER. I
THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY WE'RE
NOW GOING TO MOVE TO OUR
MEMBERS PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
WE ARE ON FILE ITEM THIRTY TWO
AB TWO ZERO SEVEN SEVEN MEN
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
BATES BATES AB TWENTY SEVENTY
SEVEN NO BATES NOW FOR JUST.
WE'RE JUST EIGHTY TWO ZERO
SEVEN SEVEN NOW FORTUS NO
CHIANG. THANK AB TWENTY SEVEN
SEVEN NO CHIANG NO DALLY. DALY
AB TWO ZERO SEVEN SEVEN NO.
DALLY NO GROWTH. GROSS AB TWO
ZERO SEVEN SEVEN NO GROVE NO
MELENDEZ MELENDEZ AB TWO ZERO
SEVEN SEVEN NOW. MELENDEZ NO
MORLOCK. AB TWO ZERO SEVEN
SEVEN ABSTAINED. MORALE YES
NUMBER L. A. B. TWO ZERO SEVEN
SEVEN NO. MORALE NO WILK.
SENATE WILL CURE MUTE. WILK AB
TWENTY SEVEN SEVEN NO WILK NOW.
THE SENATOR MOVE THE CALL
MEMBERS WERE GETTING INTO A
RHYTHM HERE GREAT JOB WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO FILE ITEM
THIRTY THREE SENATOR MCGUIRE
NOT AT HIS DESK FILE ITEM
THIRTY FOUR SENATOR HERTZBERG
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY ONE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
QUIRK AN ACT RELATING TO LAND
USE. SORRY ABOUT THAT CENTER
HERTZBERG THANK YOU MA'AM
PRESIDENT JOHN. YOU KNOW WE'VE
BEEN TALKING ABOUT AND DEALING
WITH THESE ISSUES THE FIRES
WHICH HAVE BEEN NOTHING LESS
THAN EXTRAORDINARY. SO MANY
FOLKS AND- PART OF THAT IS IN
MAINTAINING COMMUNICATIONS WE
HAVE EVOLVED TO MOBILE SYSTEMS
WHERE WE USE THESE FIVE G. CELL
TOWERS AND SO WITH THE PUBLIC
SAFETY SAFETY POWER SHUT OFFS.
INTERRUPTING COMMERCIAL POWER
TO THE WIRELESS INFRASTRUCTURE
AS I SUGGEST HIS LOSS TO ACCESS
TO CRUCIAL COMMUNICATION
SERVICES IN MANY AREAS OF THE
STATE. OF THIS MEASURE WILL
ENABLE MOBILE COMMUNICATION
PROVIDERS TO INSTALL BACKUP
POWER GENERATORS AT EXISTING
CELL SITES MORE QUICKLY
ENABLING RAPID DEPLOYMENT OF
EMERGENCY STANDBY GENERATORS. I
THINK IT WOULD BE FAIR TO SAY
IS VITAL FOR PUBLIC FATE SAFETY
AND WELFARE TO HELP INSURE
COMMERCIAL A CONSUMERS MAINTAIN
ACCESS. TO THE IMPORTANT NINE
ONE ONE SERVICES WIRELESS
EMERGENCY ALERTS AND OTHER
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMUNICATIONS.
THE AUTHOR HAS WORKED
DILIGENTLY WITH RESPECT TO ALL
OF THE PARTIES IN THE BEHALF OF
DOCTORCORK I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
CENTER HERTZBERG MEMBERS ON THE
FLOOR ANY DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING THEN
WE WILL MOVE TO OUR REMOTE
VOTERS- MEMBERS I DO NOT SEE
ANY OF YOUR HANDS UP SO I'M IN
ASPEN I'M SECRETARY TO PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN. ARCHULETA
I ATKINS I FELL. BRADFORD HI
CABALLERO I DON. HI TORONTO.
GALGIANI I GLAZER GONZALEZ.
HERTZBERG AYE HILL HI HUESO. HI
HER TADO I JACKSON I LEYVA HI
WIRE. MITCHELL I MONNING. AYE
NIELSEN. I CAN FIVE PORTANTINO.
HI ROTH AYE RUBIO. FIVE SKINNER
STERN NUMBER I WHITE HOUSE SKI
HI WIENER. NO WE WILL NOW MOVE
TO OUR MEMBERS WERE VOTING
REMOTELY THE MEASURE THAT WE
ARE VOTING ON IS AB TWO FOUR
TWO ONE MADAM SECRETARY. BATES
EIGHT AB TWO FOUR TWO ONE ALL
RIGHT. EIGHT FIVE FOUR JUST.
WE'RE JUST AB TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY ONE ON BARGES HI CHIANG.
HEY AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY ONE
HI KAREN HI DALLI DALLI AB.
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY ONE HI DALY
I GROWTH. AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
ONE I GROW BY. MELENDEZ
MELENDEZ AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
ONE HI MELENDEZ HI MORLOCK. OR
OR AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY ONE I.
MORLOCK HIGH MORALE AB TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY ONE MORALE HI
MORRELL HI. WILK. I'M SORRY
IT'S MAKING ME DOUBLE DOUBLE
CLICK FOR WHATEVER REASON WILK
AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY ONE I
WILK HI SENATOR MOVES A CULT
MEMBERS ARE MOVING TO FILE ITEM
THIRTY FIVE SENATOR- BURKE
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY NINETY TWO
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER RODRIGUEZ AND
ACTUALLY BEING TO EMERGENCY
AMBULANCE EMPLOYEES CENTER
AMBER. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS- AND PRESENT
I RISE TO PRESENT AB TWENTY
NINETY TWO ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ.
CALIFORNIA NEEDED NEARLY 80% OF
EMTS AND PARAMEDICS EMPLOYED BY
THE PRIVATE SECTOR ALL OF THEM
WORK IN A FIELD WITH HIGH RATES
OF MORTALITY INJURY AND TRAUMA.
THESE FIRST RESPONDERS
FREQUENTLY EXPERIENCE VIOLENCE
ASSAULTS WERE RESPONDING TO
EMERGENCY CALLS AT A HIGHER
RATE THAN MOST OTHER
OCCUPATIONS. AB TWENTY NINETY
TWO WILL REQUIRE PRIVATE
AMBULANCE EMPLOYERS. TO
ESTABLISH A SUBSIDIZED
PURCHASING PROGRAM THAT WILL
ALLOW THEIR EMPLOYERS TO
VOLUNTARILY PLEASE SPIKE THAT
THEIR EMPLOYEES TO VOLUNTARILY.
PURCHASE PROTECTIVE GEAR WITH
EMPLOYER. FUNDED STATE AND
UNDER THIS BILL PRIVATE
AMBULANCE WORKERS WILL HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO OBTAIN AND WEAR
PROTECTIVE GEAR. THE WHEN- WHEN
THEY RESPOND TO INCIDENTS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR- VOTE
THANK YOU CENTER NUMBER MEMBERS
HERE ON THE FLOOR ANY QUESTIONS
OR DISCUSSION ANY DEBATE.
SEEING THEN WE WILL MOVE TO OUR
MEMBERS WERE PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY I DO NOT SEE ANY HANDS
UP. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN FIVE ARCHULETA
I ATKINS HI WELL. BRADFORD HI
CABRERA. I THOUGHT. I DURAZO HI
CAL JOHNNY FIVE GLAZER GONZALEZ
I HERTZBERG HI PHIL. I HUESO.
HI HER TADO FIVE JACKSON I
LEYVA I MCGUIRE. MITCHELL FIVE
MONEY HI NIELSEN. I CAN FIVE
PORTANTINO. I ROTH HI RUBIO. I
SKINNER STERN NUMBER I REQUEST
THE I WIENER HI THANK YOU WILL
NOW MOVE TO OUR MEMBERS
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY THIS IS
FILE ITEM TWO ZERO NINE TWO
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. BATES
BATES AB TWENTY NINETY TWO NO
BATES NOW. PORGES WE'RE JUST
EIGHTY TWO ZERO NINE TWO
ABSTAINED. CHIANG SAYING AB
TWENTY NINETY TWO HI HANG I
DALY DOLLY AB. TWO NINE ZERO
TWO. NOPE TWO ZERO NINE TWO
NOPE YES. DALLY NOW. GROSS AB
TWO ZERO NINE TWO NO GROVE NO
MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ AB TWO ZERO
NINE TWO NO MELENDEZ NO.
MORLOCK. AB TWO ZERO NINE TWO
NO. MORLOCK NO MORALE. MORRELL
AB TWO ZERO NINE TWO NO MORALE
NO. WILK WILK AB TWENTY NINETY
TWO HI WILK HI SENATOR MUSICAL
MEMBERS REMOVING THE FILE ITEM
THIRTY SIX SENATOR HERTZBERG
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF A IF I
CAN MAKE THIS AN EMOTION JOYS
LUCIEN DIED AT THE REQUEST OF
THE AUTHOR I'D LIKE TO MOVE
THIS FILE ITEM THIRTY SIX AB
THIRTY ONE THIRTY FOUR AS AGAIN
AS THE REQUEST OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RACE TO THE ACTIVE
FILES. THE DESK WILL NOTE THANK
YOU CENTER HERTZBERG. CENTER
NIELSEN FOR WHAT PURPOSE YOU
RISE. TO BE RECORDED AS A NOTE
SO I WANTED TO SWITCH FROM I
DON'T KNOW ON THE LAST BILL.
SENATOR NIELSEN WHEN WE GO BACK
AND WE LIFT THE CALLS YOU'LL
HAVE THAT OPPORTUNITY THANK YOU.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM THIRTY SEVEN SENATOR
SKINNER. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN
TWENTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
WICKS AN ACT RELATING TO LAND
USE CENTER SKINNER. THANK YOU A-
MADAM PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS.
I WANT TO PRESENT AB SEVEN
TWENTY FIVE WHICH IS BEEN
THROUGH A LONG PROCESS OF
NEGOTIATIONS AND- GOOD INPUT
FROM STAKEHOLDERS SO THAT MANY
OF MUCH OF THE OPPOSITION THAT
HAD BEEN PRESENT IS NOW GONE-
WHAT AB SEVEN TWENTY FIVE DOES.
IS HOUSE METROPOLITAN
JURISDICTIONS ALLOCATE 25% OF
THEIR ABOVE MODERATE IN THEIR
MODERATE INCOME HOUSING TO
MULTI FAMILY PRODUCTION HE
GIVES ZONING FLEXIBILITY TO
LOCALS AND IS A THOUGHTFUL
IMPROVEMENT TO OUR HOUSING
ELEMENT LAW. AB SEVEN TWENTY
FIVE IS NOW ALSO CONSISTENT
WITH- THE SENATE BILL SB ELEVEN
TWENTY WHICH PASSED THIS HOUSE
WITH THIRTY NINE HI THIS. BY
CREATING MORE MULTI FAMILY
OPTIONS FOR RESIDENTS WE ARE
ADDRESSING INEQUITY IN HIGH
COST COMMUNITIES. AND WITH THAT
I ASKED ZERO VOTE THANK YOU
SENATOR SKINNER. DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE ON THE FLOOR SENATOR
MITCHELL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MADAM PRESIDENT CAN I ASK THE
QUESTION OF THE- FLOOR MANAGER
PLEASE WE TAKE A QUESTION
CENTER SKINNER YES I WILL
PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND DISCOURAGE MY
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE AUTHOR
WORKED CLOSELY WITH THE CITY
VALLEY TO CRAFT LANGUAGE. THAT
MAINTAINS LOCAL FLEXIBILITY CAN
YOU SPEAK TO THE FLEXIBILITY.
ONE SECOND MY GLASSES KEEP
FALLING OFF OF MY FACE SAID THE-
WHAT MAKES IT VERY HARD TO
REACH. LET ME. FIND THE
EXPLICIT ISSUES AROUND
FLEXIBILITY. MARI NOTES DO NOT
INDICATE EXACTLY HOW IT
ADDRESSED THAT BUT I KNOW THAT
THE CITY OF LA HAS REMOVED
THEIR OPPOSITION BECAUSE OF THE
WORK THAT THE AUTHOR DID WITH
THEM REGARDING THE EXACT ISSUE
YOU ASKED ABOUT OKAY THANK YOU
AND ARE THESE MULTI FAMILY
UNITS REQUIRED TO BE BUILT IN
SPECIFIC OR AREAS OR CAN THEY
BE BUILT WHERE EVER IS THE BEST
FOR THE COMMUNITY. THEY ARE.
WELL FIRST OFF YES IT IS WHERE
THE COMMUNITY DEEMS BEST
HOWEVER THE BILL ONLY AFFECTS
WHAT IS CONSIDERED METROPOLITAN
JURISDICTIONS SO IT IS NOT- ED
IS NOT. A CHANGE IN THE HOUSING
ELEMENT FOR EVERY SINGLE- FOR
EVERYWHERE ACROSS THE STATE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR
MITCHELL ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE FLOOR SEEING
AND HEARING NONE LOOKING TO OUR
REMOTE VOTERS I DO NOT SEE ANY
HAND RAISED. CENTER SKINNER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. HI ASK
FOR YOUR HELP THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. ARCHULETA I ATKINS I
FELT. BRADFORD. I HAVE A I
DON'T. I DONT. HI THERE I
WASN'T FIVE GALGIANI I GLAZER
GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG. HILL AYE
HUESO I HER TADO I JACKSON.
LEYVA I REQUIRE. MITCHELL FIVE
MINING FIVE NIELSEN NO HAN FIVE
PORTANTINO. ROTH I RUBIO. I
SKINNER I STERN I'M BURKE HI MY
COUNTY I WIENER. HI WE'VE BEEN
TO OUR MEMBERS WERE VOTING
REMOTELY WE ARE VOTING ON FILE
ITEM- BECAUSE HE'S MORE VOTING
ON MAJOR SEVEN TWO FIVE AM
SECRETARY. SIX EIGHT SIX
HUNDRED EIGHTY SEVEN TWO FIVE
NO BATES NO BORJAS. OR JUST
EIGHTY SEVEN TWO FIVE NOW FOR
JUST NOW CHIANG. TAKING AB
SEVEN TWO FIVE NO CHIANG NO
DALLY. ALI AB SEVENTY FIVE NO
DALLY NO GROWTH. AB SEVENTY
FIVE NO GROVE NO MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ AB SEVENTY FIVE NOW
MELENDEZ NO MORE LOCK OR UNLOCK
AB SEVEN TWO FIVE NO MORE LOCK
NO MORALE. AB. SEVENTY FIVE NO
MORALE NO WILK. WILK AB SEVEN
TWO FIVE NO WILK NOW SENATOR
MOVES A CALL MEMBERS WE ARE
MOVING TO FILE ITEM THIRTY
EIGHT SENATOR MITCHELL. MAN
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL SEVEN THIRTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BONTA AN ACT
RELATING TO INCARCERATED
PERSONS SENATOR MITCHELL. HE
VERY MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES AB SEVEN THREE TO
IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH CARE FOR
INCARCERATED PREGNANT
CALIFORNIANS IN COUNTY JAILS
AND STATE PRISONS A NUMBER OF
IMPORTANT SUPPORT FOR PREGNANT
INCARCERATED WOMEN ARE REQUIRED
IN OUR STATE PRISONS THE A
STATE REGULATIONS BUT THE
SUPPORTS ARE NOT REQUIRED IN
OUR COUNTY JAILS. AB SEVENTY
TWO WOULD CODIFY INTO LAW
REGULATIONS FOR STATE PRISONS
AND EXTEND EXISTING PROTECTIONS
THAT APPLY IN CALIFORNIA STATE
PRISONS TO COUNTY JAIL UNDER A
B. SEVEN THREE TWO EXISTING
COMMONSENSE COUNTY JAILS WOULD
REQUIRE. ONE OBSTETRICS EXAMS
IN PRENATAL CARE VISITS WITH A
SIGN PREGNANT INCARCERATED
WOMEN TO LOWER BUNKS AND LOWER
TIER HOUSING. WOULD ALLOW
PREGNANT INCARCERATED WOMEN TO
HAVE SUPPORT PERSON PRESENT
DURING CHILDBIRTH IT WOULD GIVE
PREGNANT INCARCERATED WOMEN
ACCESS TO COMMUNITY PROGRAMS
THAT WOULD PROVIDE A PREGNANT
INCARCERATED WOMEN WITH
POSTPARTUM EXAMINATIONS.
CALIFORNIA SHOULD PROVIDE
DIGNIFIED AND COMPASSIONATE
HEALTH CARE AND SUPPORT
INCARCERATED PREGNANT WOMEN
WHETHER IN STATE PRISON FOR
COUNTY JAIL AB SEVEN THREE TWO
WOULD ENSURE THIS HAPPENS I
ASKED FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU SENATOR MITCHELL MEMBERS ON
THE FLOOR DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE. SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MEMBER PARTICIPATING REMOTELY I
SEE NO HANDS RAISED. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS I
FELL. BRADFORD HI CABRERA I
DODD. I THE RYZEN HI GALGIANI
AYE GLAZER. GONZALEZ I
HERTZBERG. HELLO AYE HUESO. HI
HER TADO. I JACKSON I LEYVA I
MCGUIRE. I MITCHELL. I MONEY I
NIELSEN. PAN FIVE PORTANTINO HI
RALPH. I RUBIO FIVE SKINNER. HI
STERN NUMBER FIVE LAKE COUNTY I
WIENER I WOULD BE TO OUR
MEMBERS VOTING REMOTELY WE ARE
ON MEASURES SEVEN THREE TWO
MADAM SECRETARY. BATES BATES AB
SEVEN THREE TWO HI BATES NINE
GORGEOUS. OR JUST EIGHTY SEVEN
THREE TWO AM STAYING. CHIANG
HEY AB SEVEN THREE TWO FIVE
CHIANG I DALY. DALY AB SEVEN
THREE TWO OF STATE. GROWTH AG
GROWTH AB SEVEN THREE TWO
ABSTAINED. MELENDEZ MELENDEZ AB
SEVEN THREE TWO I'D MELINDA'S
AYE MORLOCK. BERLOCQ AB SEVEN
THREE TWO HI MORLOCK HIGH
MORALE. AB SEVEN THREE TWO NO
MORALE NO WILK WILK EIGHTY
SEVEN THIRTY TWO HI WILK HI
SENATOR MUSICAL MEMBERS MOVING
TO FILE ITEM THIRTY NINE
SENATOR HUESO MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL NINE
SEVENTY NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
HOLDEN AN ACT RELATING TO
CORPORATIONS. SENATOR HUESO.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
SENATORS I RISE TO PRESENT AB
NINE SEVEN NINE ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN AND
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS CRISTINA
GARCIA DAVID CHIU AB NINE SEVEN
NINE HAS BEEN PART OF A LARGER
EFFORT TO ENSURE BETTER PEOPLE
OF COLOR HAVE EQUITABLE ACCESS
TO UPPER UPWARD MOBILITY. IN
CALIFORNIA. WHEN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HOLDEN ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GARCIA AND I WERE CHAIRS OF THE
BLACK CAUCUS THE WOMEN'S CAUCUS
IN THE LATINO CAUCUS WE WORK
TOGETHER TO ADDRESS RACIAL AND
GENDER GENDER DISPARITIES AT
TECH COMPANIES IN SILICON
VALLEY. THAT WAS IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN DO A FEW COMPANIES
HAVE ACTED UPON THEIR
COMMITMENTS TO DIVERSITY SIR
SIR SEVERE ON REPRESENTATION OF
WOMEN AND MINORITIES IN THE
TECH INDUSTRY HAVE CONTINUED TO
THIS DAY. UNFORTUNATELY THIS
PROBLEM IS NOT UNIQUE TO TECH
COMPANIES WOMEN AND MINORITIES
ARE UNDER REPRESENTED ACROSS
WHAT COLOR INDUSTRIES
ESPECIALLY AT THE MANAGERIAL
AND EXECUTIVE LEVELS IN
RESPONSE TO THE PERS PERVASIVE
UNDER UNDER REPRESENTATION OF
MINORITIES. AND THE FOLLOWING
AND FOLLOWING THE SUCCESS OF
SENATOR JACKSON'S S. B. EIGHT
TWO SIX ASSEMBLY BILL NINE
SEVEN MINE NINE WOULD REQUIRE A
MINIMUM OF ONE DIRECTOR FROM AN
UNREPRESENTED COMMUNITY ON ALL
BOARDS OF PUBLICLY TRADED
CORPORATIONS HEADQUARTERED IN
CALIFORNIA BY THE END OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. THIS BILL WOULD
ALSO REQUIRE A MINIMUM OF TWO
DIRECTORS FROM UNDERREPRESENTED
COMMUNITIES FOR BOARDS THAT HAD
FIVE TO EIGHT DIRECTORS. AND
THREE DIRECTORS FOR BOARD
BOARDS WITH MORE THAN. NINE
DIRECTORS BY THE END OF TWENTY
TWENTY TWO. THE US DEPARTMENT
OF LABOR BUREAU OF STATISTICS
AS REPORTED THAT IN 201890% OF
CHIEF EXECUTIVES IN THE UNITED
STATES WERE WHITE. WHILE
CALIFORNIA PRIDES ITSELF ON
BUTTON BEING MINORITY. WELL
BEING A MINORITY MAJORITY STATE
CORPORATIONS DO NOT REFLECT THE
VAST CULTURAL WEALTH IN THE
STATE FOR EXAMPLE OF THE TOP
TEN CALIFORNIA BANKS ONLY 30%
OF THE DIRECTORS ARE PEOPLE OF
COLOR. THIS STATISTIC PALES IN
COMPARISON TO THE 67% OF
CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION THERE
ARE PEOPLE OF COLOR RESEARCH BY
THE LATINO CORPORATE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION FOUND THAT AS OF
JULY FIRST 202087% OF
CALIFORNIA SIX HUNDRED SIXTY
TWO PUBLIC COMPANIES DO NOT
HAVE A LATINO ON BOARD. AS YOU
ALL KNOW LATINOS MAKE UP THIRTY
NINE POINT FOUR OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. BUT THEY ARE
SEVERELY UNDERREPRESENTED IN
THE BOARDROOM. CALIFORNIA IS
BETTER THAN THIS WE ARE THE
MOST DIVERSE STATE IN THE
NATION IN OUR CORPORATIONS NEED
TO EMULATE OUR DIVERSITY WE CAN
ALSO LOOK TO SILICON VALLEY FOR
EXAMPLES OF UNDER
REPRESENTATION ON AVERAGE BLACK
AND LATINO TECH COMPANIES MAKE
UP LESS THAN TEN PERCENT. OF
WORKERS AT PREMIER COMPANIES
SUCH AS GOOGLE APPLE MICROSOFT
FACEBOOK AND LINKEDIN THIS
PERCENTAGES DISPROPORTIONATE TO
THE ROUGHLY 20% OF COMPUTER
SCIENCE GRADUATE THAT ARE BLACK
OR LATINO. ASIANS AND PACIFIC
ISLANDERS MAKE UP A GREATER
PERCENTAGE OF THE WHITE COLLAR
WORKFORCE PER AT THE LEAST
LIKELY TO BE PROMOTED TO MOVE
UP THE LADDER IN LIGHT OF
RECENT SOCIAL AND RACIAL
JUSTICE PROTESTS CORPORATIONS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY HAVE CONDUCT
REVIEWS OF THEIR WORKFORCE AND
HAVE MADE PROMISES TO INCREASE
DIVERSITY. MANY TCH GIANTS
BEGAN IN TWENTY FOURTEEN YET
THE PERCENTAGE OF PEOPLE OF
COLOR BEING HIRED AND PROMISED
HAS NOT CHANGED A RECENT REPORT
BY MCKINSEY AND COMPANY SHOWS
THAT COMPANIES WITH A DIVERSE
WORKFORCE AND I DIVERSE
CORPORATE BOARD PERFORMED
BETTER THAN BOARDS WITHOUT
DIVERSITY. YET THE FACE OF THE
WHITE COLOR ON EMPLOYEE REMAINS
UNCHANGED BY CHANGING THE
CORPORATE BOARD TO CHANGE THE
COMPANY'S CULTURE A DIVERSE
BOARD CONTRIBUTES TO THAT
COMPANY. AND IT'S VALUES FOR
DIVERSITY AND CAN READILY ADAPT
TO THE CHANGING NEEDS OF ITS
WORKFORCE AND CUSTOMER BASE BY.
S. A. B. NINE SEVEN NINE WAS
AMENDED IN SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS TO ADD MYSELF AS
A CO AUTHOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHOOSE A JOINT AUTHORS ADDING
ADDITIONAL FINDINGS TO ADDRESS
POTENTIAL CONSTITUENTS
CONSTITUTIONAL CONCERNS A
TECHNICAL AMENDMENT TO REMOVE.
THE DEADLINE FOR RECOMMENDATION
OF THE SECRETARY OF STATE AND
ADDING LGBTQ TO THE DEFINITION
OF UNDER PREPPERS AND IT
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR VOTE
TODAY THANK YOU SENATOR HUESO
MEMBERS ON THE FLOOR DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE SENATOR PAN. THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I TO RISE A
SUPPORT TO EIGHTY NINE SEVEN
NINE AS A- THE VICE CHAIR OF
THE HR LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS- AND
ALSO CHAIR OF OUR SELECT
COMMITTEE AND API AFFAIRS. I DO
WANT TO POINT OUT THAT- EVEN IN
THE API COMMITTEE AND I WOULD
POINT OUT THAT IT'S ONLY
CERTAIN SUBGROUPS OF THE API
COMMUNITY THAT. SOME PEOPLE
POINT OUT OF THROUGH THE MODEL
MINORITY MYTH THAT WORSE YOU
KNOW AT LEAST SOMEWHAT WELL
REPRESENTED AND THE FOR SOME
PROFESSIONS AND THAT LIKE
ENGINEERING OR MEDICINE AND SO
FORTH. BUT IN FACT THE API- THE
SELECT ME ON API FARES OF THIS
VERY SENATE TO HELP THE HEARING
TO TALK ABOUT THE GLASS CEILING
FOR API SO WHEN USE LOOK AT
THE- ENTRY LEVEL RANKS AGAIN
ONLY FOR SOME API SUBGROUPS OR
MANY OTHER. API SEVENTIES
PARTICULARLY ARE NATIVE
HAWAIIAN PACIFIC ISLANDERS
OTHER- ASIAN SUBGROUPS THAT
ACTUALLY DO ALSO CHALLENGES
EVEN ON THE COLLEGE LEVEL OR
THE ENTRY JOB LEVEL WHAT YOU
SEE IS BY TIME YOU GET TO
SENIOR MANAGEMENT. CEOS AND
BOARDS- THAT BASICALLY WE ARE
WOEFULLY UNDER REPRESENTED AS
AS A GROUP AND THAT CERTAINLY
OF COURSE IS ALSO AN ISSUE FOR-
ALSO THE- BLACK AMERICANS AND
FOR LATINOS AS AS WELL SO THIS
IS AN IMPORTANT. BILL TO TRY TO
BRING GREATER EQUITY TO BE SURE
THE POLICY MAKING- PARTS OF OUR
CORPORATIONS THAT'S WHAT THE
BOARDS ARE AND THEY HOLD THE
CEOS ACCOUNTABLE THEY ALSO
ESTABLISHED POLICY. THAT WE
HAVE THE REPRESENTATION THERE
SO THAT- THE CORPORATIONS WHICH
CONTROL A VAST AMOUNT OF OUR
FINANCIAL RESOURCES- IN IN NOT
ONLY IN OUR STATE BUT ACROSS
THE COUNTRY ARE MORE RESPONSIVE
TO THE TRUE DIVERSITY OF OUR
STATE AND OUR COMMUNITIES. I
DON'T DENY THAT THANK YOU THANK
YOU CENTER PAN MEMBERS ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE FLOOR SEEING NONE GOING TO
OUR REMOTE VOTING MEMBERS
SEEING NO HANDS. HOPE CENTER
GROVE. PLEASE PROCEED. I THINK
YOU MADAM FOR. AM I UP THE OF
THIS. SHINSHU BE. AND I'M I
LOOK AT EVEN MIGHT ABOARD I WAS
JUST LOOKING AT MY BOARD AND WE
HAVE SIX NUMBERS ON MY BOARD OF
MY PRIVATE COMPANY AND- YOU
KNOW STE TWO OF THEM ARE THREE
OF THEM ARE WOMEN AND- TWO ARE
HISPANICS. AND LATINOS AND SO-
THEY'VE RETARDED JUST LIKE THE
OTHER PEOPLE ON THE BOARD TO BE
IN THAT POSITION AND SO. I
THINK THAT- JUST LIKE IT WAS-
MICE THAT MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SACRAMENTO MENTION THAT- YOU
KNOW A LOT OF THESE PORTS
CONTROL A LOT OF RESOURCES FOR
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
CONTROLS A LOT OF RESOURCES TO.
AND SO I JUST THINK THAT IN
PRIVATE BUSINESS- BOARD SHOULD
BE ELECTED- AND PEOPLE SHOULD
BE PUT ON BOARDS THAT ARE OUR
BEST REPRESENT THE BUSINESS.
AND THAT COULD BE ANYBODY SKIN
COLOR IT'S JUST A QUALIFICATION
IT'S A REQUIREMENT SO I WOULD
URGE A NO VOTE. THANK YOU
CENTER GROVE COMING BACK. TO
THE SENATE FLOOR SENATOR
MITCHELL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I'M NOT A PRESIDENT OF A
QUESTION OF THE FLOOR MANAGER
PLEASE. CENTER WAS WE TAKE A
QUESTION ABSOLUTELY PLEASE
PROCEED. SENATE HUESO IS THERE
ANY LANGUAGE IN THE BILL THAT
WOULD SUGGEST. RACE GENDER
SEXUAL ORIENTATION SHOULD TROP-
PROFESSIONAL EXPERTISE ON WHAT-
FICTIONAL VALUE ONE WOULD BRING
TO THE BOARD NONE AT ALL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR MITCHELL
SENATOR WIENER. I THANK YOU ARE
YOU KNOW I THINK THERE IS A
MANTRA THAT IF YOU. TAKE
PROACTIVE STEPS TO INCREASE
DIVERSITY YOU'RE SOMEHOW MOVING
AWAY FROM MERIT OR
QUALIFICATIONS AND THAT IS
SIMPLY UNTRUE THE REALITY IS
THAT FOREVER AS LONG AS THEIR
BIG CORPORATIONS- WE HAVE SEEN
A PROFOUND LACK OF
REPRESENTATION ON CORPORATE
BOARDS BY WOMEN BY PEOPLE OF
COLOR AND BY LGBTQ. PEOPLE NOT
BECAUSE THERE ARE AN ENORMOUS
NUMBER OF QUALIFIED DIRECTORS
IN THESE COMMUNITIES BUT
BECAUSE OUR SOCIETY HAS BEEN
STRUCTURED DATA. THAT THOSE
COMMUNITIES ARE DOES NOT
REPRESENTED AND IT BECOMES A
SORT OF AN OLD BOYS NETWORK
WITH ALL RESPECT I AND SO
TAKING PROACTIVE STEPS TO SAY
WE HAD A NICE MASSIVE POOL
ABSOLUTELY MASSIVE POOL. ARE
EMINENTLY QUALIFIED. PEOPLE
CALL OF EMINENTLY. LGBTQ PEOPLE
AND YOU NEED TO BE INTENTIONAL
AND PROACTIVE TO IDENTIFY WHO
THESE PEOPLE ARE BECAUSE
THEY'RE OUT THERE AND THERE'S
NO SHORTAGE. AND TO HAVE MORE
DIVERSE SPORTS WE HAVE TO TAKE
PROACTIVE STEPS. TO REMEDY THE
STRUCTURAL RACISM AND
HOMOPHOBIA AND TRANSPHOBIA THAT
HAS INFECTED THE SOCIETY AND
THIS WORLD FOREVER AND THIS
BILL WILL HELP US DO THAT AND
AYE URGENT AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR WIENER CENTER BRADFORD.
THANK YOU I TO RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE AND AS THE
VICE YOU'RE LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS ARE WE SUPPORT THIS
MEASURE. AND IT'S NO SECRET AS
MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES OF OURS
STATED THAT MANY OF THE MOST
QUALIFIED PEOPLE ARE NEVER
GIVEN A CHANCE AND THEY'RE
USING PEOPLE OF COLOR USING
WOMEN WHO ARE IGNORE. THAT
INDIVIDUAL WHO SPENT TWENTY
YEARS IN CORPORATE AMERICA. I
KNOW MANY OF TIMES THEY WOULD
ALWAYS SAY WE CAN'T FIND WE CAN
FINE WHEN THEY'RE PLENTY
QUALIFIED LATINOS AFRICAN
AMERICANS ASIANS OUT THERE BUT
THEY CHOOSE NOT TO LOOK FORM.
AND AS STATED THIS IS USING THE
OLD BOYS NETWORK FIELD WITH
NEPOTISM AND CRONYISM OF MANY
CORPORATIONS BECAUSE AS I
LEARNING CORPORATION PEOPLE
HIRED IN A POINT BILLS PEOPLE
WHO REMIND THE MOST OF
THEMSELVES OF THEIR- PRIMARILY
WHITE MALE DOMINATED GOT TO
THEY'RE GONNA HIRE THAT'S
EITHER GOING TO POINT AND NOT
TO THE BOARDS MADE UP.
DIVERSITY SHOULD BE AND
CORPORATIONS DNA AND NOT JUST
CHECKING A BOX AND I THINK THIS
IS A STRONG MEASURE TO MAKE
SURE THAT. DIVERSITY IS PART OF
THESE CORPORATIONS BY
DIVERSIFYING THE BOARDS ARE
STRUNG OUT FOR A VOTE. THANK
YOU CENTER BRADFORD. CENTER TO
RAZA. IT'S COMING. GO AHEAD.
PUSH ONE MORE TIME. WELL THERE
WE GO I WASN'T CLOSE ATTENTION
AND YES I KNOW YOU WERE DOING
GOOD PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU
THANK YOU I RISE AS A WOMAN I
RISE AS A LATINA I RISE UP ON
THE ISSUE OF HAVING A HEALTHY
SOCIETY THAT INTEGRATES
EVERYONE FROM OUR COMMUNITIES
THAT EVERYBODY HAS THE
OPPORTUNITY AND I GET QUITE
OFFENDED. WHEN SOMEBODY THINKS
THAT BECAUSE THERE'S A
RECRUITMENT EFFORT A PROACTIVE
EFFORT TO INTEGRATE INTO EVERY
ASPECT OF OUR SOCIETY THAT
SOMEHOW THAT MEANS WE'RE
LOWERING THE STANDARDS SO I
RISE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
SENATOR ALSO. SEEING NO FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR AND SEEING NO HANDS REYES
REMOTELY SENATE HUESO YOU MAY
CLOSE THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
THANK YOU MEMBERS FOR THAT
DISCUSSION. YOU KNOW I RECENTLY
SAW A REPORT THAT REFERENCE A
STUDY THAT WAS DONE. THAT
MEASURED AND TRACKED. THAT
MEASURED AND TRACKED THE
OPERATIVE OWNERSHIP OF FARMERS
AND AMERICAN FOLLOWING THE WAR
HE SHOWED A MAP OF HOW MANY
AFRICAN AMERICANS ACTUALLY OWN
FORMS AND HOW OVER TIME BUT
OWNERSHIP INTEREST HAS DECLINED
AND THEIR FARMS HAVE SHRUNK.
AND ONE OF THE REASONS THAT
WERE CITED AS A LOT OF THESE
FARMERS COULD NEVER OVER THE
COURSE OF THOSE YEARS ACCESS
CAPITAL WELL THEY WERE
SUCCESSFUL FARMERS THE COULD
NOT MODERNIZED THEIR FARMS IN
MANY CASES THEY LOST THEIR FORM
FARMS MANY CASE THEY HAD SSL
OFF LAND TO STAY IN BUSINESS.
AND ONE OF ONE OF THE THERE WAS
A CASE IN ACTUAL THAT HAPPENED
RECENTLY IN WHICH- ONE PHARNEXT
LOCATED NEXT EXTRA NUMBER ONE
ONE OF THEM WAS AFRICAN
AMERICAN ONE ONE WAS ANGLED.
ANGLE GOT A HEFTY LOAN THAT WAS
ABLE TO HELP THEM GET A TRACTOR
IN THE- AND THE FARMER NEXT
DOOR COULD NOT GET A LOAN SO
THEY HAD TO PERFORM A LOT OF
THESE TASKS. MANUALLY AND SPEND
MORE TIME TRYING TO RUN THEIR
FARM. MINUTE TALKS ABOUT A
CONDITION THAT IS EXISTS IN OUR
COUNTRY THE CURRENT CURRENTLY
EXIST. IN THE DOESN'T ALLOW A
LEVEL PLAYING FIELD FOR PEOPLE
TO PARTICIPATE IN THIS ECONOMY.
I ALSO WANT TO SHARE AN EXAMPLE
OF A FRIEND OF MINE THAT
HAPPENS TO BE LATINO. THAT WAS
PARTNERED WITH AN ANGLE PARTNER
ON A HOUSING DEVELOPMENT. HE
WENT TO THE BANK TO ASK FOR A
LOAN. AND THEY DECLINED. WHEN
HE SENT HIS ANGLE PARTNERED
AFTER THIS IN THAT THE SME
BANK FOR THE LOAN THAT THEY
THEY GRANTED IT. AND THERE IS
NO DOUBT THAT THERE IS. A LOT
OF AS A STRUCTURAL AN INHERENT
BIAS. IN IN OUR ECONOMIC SYSTEM
IN OUR COUNTRY. AND THAT'S WHY
THIS BILL IS ABSOLUTELY
NECESSARY THIS BILL IS A GOOD
FOR BUSINESS BILL ADDING.
DIVERSITY TO BUSINESS WILL HELP
BUSINESS IN OUR STATE BECOME
MORE SUCCESSFUL I ALSO WANT TO
REMIND PEOPLE. THAT THIS BILL
IS VERY APPROPRIATE FOR THE
TIME RIGHT NOW BY WE NEED TO
APPROVE THIS IMMEDIATELY THIS
PANDEMIC HAS SHOWED US HOW
PEOPLE OF COLOR HAVE BEEN
AFFECTED DISPROPORTIONATELY BY
THE PANDEMIC. WE KNOW THAT
LATINOS AND AFRICAN AMERICANS
HAPPEN TO BE. A
DISPROPORTIONATE NUMBER OF THE
OF IN OTHER WORDS A
PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA OR OR THAT
ARE LATINOS AND AFRICAN
AMERICANS ARE ESSENTIAL WORKERS
THEY DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO
QUALITY JOBS AND HEALTH CARE.
AND BECAUSE OF THAT THERE
THEY'VE BEEN AFFECTED
DISPROPORTIONATELY BY THE
PANDEMIC THAT'S WHY THIS BILL
IS SO MUCH MORE IMPORTANT AT
THIS TIME THAT WE START. TO
MOVE FORWARD TO CREATE
OPPORTUNITY IN THE STATE TO
PEOPLE OF COLOR. IN IN A IN AN
ENVIRONMENT WHERE THEY HAD BEEN
DISPUT DISPROPORTIONATELY
DENIED THAT SAME OPPORTUNITY SO
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT. BILL IN
THIS WOULD REALLY SET
CALIFORNIA PART IS A NATION
THAT'S REALLY RECOGNIZING THE
DIVERSITY MATTERS AND THAT IT'S
GOOD FOR BUSINESS A LITTLE
IMPROVE OUR SOCIAL AND ECONOMIC
CLIMATE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CENTER HUESO MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN
ARCHULETA I ATKINS I FELT.
BRADFORD I HAVE A I DON. DURAZO
I GALGIANI I GLAZER. GONZALEZ I
HERTZBERG I HILL HI WITH SOME
HI HER TADO. HI JACKSON. I
LEYVA I REQUIRE. I MITCHELL. I
MONEY HI MORE LOCK. NIELSEN NO
PAN FIVE PORTANTINO FIVE ROTH.
I RUBIO. HI SKINNER BY STERN.
AMBERG WHITE HOUSE SKI. WIENER
HI. THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY
MOVING TO A REMOTE VOTING
MEMBERS THIS IS MAJOR. NINE
SEVEN NINE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. BATES.
BATES EIGHTY NINE SEVEN NINE
ABSTAINED. GORGEOUS FORGES AB
NINE SEVEN NINE NO CHARGES NO
CHIANG THANK AB NINE SEVEN NINE
HI CHIANG HI DELHI. DALY AB
NINE SEVEN NINE AB STATE.
GROWTH. EIGHTY NINE SEVENTY
NINE NO GROVE NO MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ AB NINE SEVEN NINE NO
MELENDEZ NO MORE LOCK. AB NINE
SEVEN NINE ABSTAINED. MORRELL
MORRELL AB NINE SEVEN NINE NOW
MORRELL NO WILK. AB NINE SEVEN
NINE NO WILK NOW SENATOR MOVES
THE CALL MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING
TO FILE ITEM FORTY ONE SENATOR
UMBERG NOT AT HIS DESK FILE
ITEM FORTY THREE SENATOR
CABALLERO. PLEASE READ MADAM
SECRETARY. ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
FORTY THREE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
ROBERT RIVAS AND AFTER LEADING
TO EMPLOYMENT AND DECLARING THE
URGENCY THERE OF TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY CENTER CABALLERO
THANK YU MADAM PRESIDENT I
RISE TO PRESENT AB TWENTY FORTY
THREE THE AGRICULTURAL
WORKPLACE HEALTH AND SAFETY ACT
ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ROBERT RIVAS THIS BILL WOULD
PROTECT THE OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY
AND HEALTH OF CALIFORNIA'S
AGRICULTURAL WORKERS DURING THE
COLD ED NINETEEN CRISIS BY RICK
REQUIRING CAL OSHA TO ENFORCE
EXISTING HEALTH. AND SAFETY
GUIDELINES AND CONDUCT A
TARGETED OUTREACH CAMPAIGN THE
CAMPAIGN WOULD CONSIST OF
PUBLIC SERVICE ANNOUNCEMENT AND
WORKPLACE SIGNS IN ENGLISH AND
SPANISH AND INFORMATION WOULD
BE DISSEMINATED USING
PICTOGRAMS TO REACH THE WORKERS
THAT DO NOT COMMUNICATE IN
EITHER LANGUAGE ADDITIONALLY%
THIS OUTRAGE CAMPAIGN WOULD
INCLUDE INFORMATION ON PAID
SICK LEAVE WORKERS COMPENSATION
AND COVERT NINETEEN RELATED
EMPLOYMENT BENEFITS LASTLY THE
BILL REQUIRES CAL OSHA TO POST
ON ITS WEBSITE INFORMATION
RELATED TO INVESTIGATIONS OF
AGRICULTURAL WORKPLACES. WE
NEED GREATER TRANSPARENCY TO
IDENTIFY AND MITIGATE AGAINST
UNSAFE WORKING CONDITIONS MANY
AG WORKERS ARE UNDOCUMENTED
OFTEN LACK ASK ACCESS TO BASIC
SERVICES AND LIVING IN CLOSE
QUARTERS THE COVERED NINETEEN
VIRUS FURTHER EXACERBATES
EXISTING CHALLENGES ADD WORKERS
ALREADY FACE AND AS WE KNOW THE
INFECTION RATE AMONG AG WORKERS.
IS STAGGERING. CURRENT PUBLIC
HEALTH AND HAS KNOWN ME AND IN
SIGHT THE MESSAGE THE WORKPLACE
SAFETY ISSUES BEFORE MORE AG
WORKERS GET SICK THE BILL HAS A
BROAD RANGE OF SUPPORT AND NO
OPPOSITION THANK YOU AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU CENTER CABALLERO
MEMBERS DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE. CENTERED RAZA. OKAY
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AS VICE
CHAIR OF THE LATINO LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS I RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY FORTY THREE IT'S A
PRIORITY BECAUSE LATINOS DO
MAKE UP A VAST MAJORITY OF THE
ESSENTIAL AGRICULTURAL
WORKFORCE IN CALIFORNIA AND
THEY HAVE HAD TO CONTINUE
WORKING THROUGHOUT THE COBIT
NINETEEN PANDEMIC DESPITE. THE
HIGH RISK OF EXPOSURE AT THEIR
WORKPLACES AS A RESULT WELL AT
THE END OF COMPRISES THIRTY
EIGHT POINT 9% THE POPULATION
THEY ACCOUNT FOR ALMOST 55% OF
THE COLBERT NINETEEN CASES IT
IS THEREFORE ABSOLUTELY
CRITICAL THAT WE ACT TO PROTECT
THE HEALTH OF THESE ESSENTIAL
WORKERS HELP LESSEN THE
POSSIBILITY OF COLBERT NINETEEN
OUTBREAKS AMONGST THEM. BY
SHARING HEALTH AND SAFETY BEST
PRACTICES AND ENSURE THE
FUNCTION ALL OF THE
FUNCTIONALITY OF OUR MUCH
NEEDED FOOD SUPPLY CHAIN THANK
YOU. THANK YOU CENTER DRAWS-
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE FLOOR SEEING NONE. SEEING
NO HANDS REYES FROM OUR REMOTE
MEMBERS I DO SEE A HAND REYES
SENATOR GROWTH. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT YOU KNOW I WHEN I SAW
THIS BILL COME OUT BECAUSE THEY
REPRESENT TO ADD THE SECOND
LARGEST AGRICULTURAL PRODUCING
COUNTY. IN THE WORLD FRANKLY
THE CENTRAL VALLEY HAS THE TOP
THREE I DID A LOT OF RESEARCH
AND- REQUIRED- ASK INQUIRED-
FROM COMPANIES THAT PROVIDE
AGRICULTURAL WORKERS ABOUT
THEIR PROCESSES IN PLACE. TO
PROTECT THE ACT BE OUR
AGRICULTURAL WORKERS AND OUR
FRONTLINE WORKERS THAT PRODUCE
STATED. AND I WAS PROVIDED WITH
PACKAGE AFTER PACKAGE AFTER
PACKAGE ENGLISH SPANISH MON.
AND COMPLYING WITH CDC
GUIDELINES- THERE WERE PICTURES
IN THESE PACKETS. ED TO HELP
PEOPLE THAT WERE MAYBE LIMITED
IN NOT ONLY ENGLISH BUT LIMITED
IN AND YOU KNOW EDUCATION.
THERE WERE- THERE IT WAS JUST A
COMPLETE I MEAN PACKET AFTER
PACKET HAD ALL THIS INFORMATION
AND IT WAS PROTECTING THESE
WORKERS. AND BUT ONE THING THAT
I DID FIND IS THAT IN OUR FOOD
PROCESSING PLANTS LIKE THE PULL
TRICKS TO PASS SEEMS PRACTICING
PLANTS THAT WERE UNDER A
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENT. IT WAS DIFFICULT FOR
THEM TO GET SAFETY INFORMATION
OUT BECAUSE THEY HAVE TO HAVE
IT AND- AGREED UPON BY EIGHT
THE COLLECTIVE BARGAINING UNIT
AND IF YOU LOOK AT THE DATA.
INTO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
MORE DEATHS OCCUR IN THOSE
TYPES OF SITUATIONS- THERE WAS
TO PACKING PLANTS THAT WERE
SHUT DOWN ONE DEFINITELY UP IN
THE CENTRAL VALLEY. AND BECAUSE
OF THE FATALITIES AT BECAUSE OF
THE PANDEMIC IN COPING NINETEEN
BUT THAT PARTICULAR PLANT WAS
UNDER A COLLECTIVE BARGAINING
AGREEMENT. SO WHILE I THINK
THAT- ALL EMPLOYERS ARE
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE DO
EVERYTHING THEY CAN TO PROTECT
THEIR WORKERS. THAT PROCESS IS
IN PLACE AS FAST AS THEY CAN-
YOU KNOW I WISH I DON'T KNOW
THAT A LOT OF BUSINESSES HAD
PANDEMIC OR CDC GUIDELINES OR-
THINGS LIKE THAT IN PLACE PRIOR
TO. THE SITUATION THAT WE GET
WE FIND OURSELVES IN THIS YEAR
BUT I CAN'T TELL YOU THAT- WITH
THE COMPANIES THAT I EAT I
CHECKED WITH. THEM PROVIDED
EXTENUATING INFORMATION AND
THEY'VE MITIGATED A LOT OF THE
EXPOSURE THAT THEY HAVE- WITH
THEIR EMPLOYEES. AND I THINK IT
PLACING UNFAIR BURDENS ON
COMPANIES AND EMPLOYEES THAT
ARE TRYING TO JUST. A PROVIDE
FOOD FOR A TABLE IS NOT THIS IS
NOT THE RIGHT TIME TO DO THAT
AND I WOULD ASK FOR A NO VOTE.
THE CENTER GROVE SENIOR FOR
THEIR HANDS UP SEEING NO
MEMBERS WITH THEIR MIKES UP
SOONER CABALLERO YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I COULD
REALLY APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS-
BY MY GOOD FRIEND FROM. THIS
CENTRAL VALLEY LET ME JUST SAY
THAT. THE OF THE CODE NINE IN.
THAT HAS BEEN THE HARDEST FOR
ME IS THAT I REPRESENT. PARTS
OF OR ALL OF SIX COUNTIES. AND
EACH COUNTY HAS A SEPARATE
OFFICER IN CHARGE OF PUBLIC
HEALTH AND SO TRYING TO KEEP UP
WITH EXACTLY WHAT THE COUNTY. A
PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICIALS IS
SAYING AND DOING WAS EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT WITH THIS BILL DOES
IS IT'S AN EDUCATION IT'S AN
INFORMATION. BILL THAT REQUIRES
CAL OSHA TO STANDARDIZE THE
INFORMATION THAT GOES OUT TO
ALL OF THE AGRICULTURAL
WORKPLACES AND STANDARDIZES THE
EDUCATION AND INFORMATION THAT
WE'VE BEEN ASKING FOR QUITE
FRANKLY- THAT BOTH FROM THE
LATINO CAUCUS AND OTHER
INDIVIDUAL MEMBERS WE'VE BEEN
ASKING FOR CAL OSHA. TO GIVE US
SOME REAL GOOD GUIDANCE ABOUT
WHAT THE SAFETY OBLIGATIONS
SHOULD BE AND HOW PEOPLE CAN
KEEP THEMSELVES SAFE I THINK
THE FACT THAT WE CONTINUE TO
SEE. THE INFECTION RATE AMONG
FARMWORKERS BE EXTREMELY HIGH
IS A CLEAR INDICATION THAT WE
NEED TO DO SOMETHING A LITTLE
BIT DIFFERENTLY AND THIS BILL
DOES THAT IT'S AN EDUCATION
ADVISEMENT AND ANNA
TRANSPARENCY BILL AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS. THANK YOU SENATOR
CABALLERO BEEN SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA I ATKINS I TELL.
BRADFORD I HAVE ITEM I DODD.
FIVE DURAZO I GALGIANI I GLAZER
GONZALEZ HI HERTZBERG HI HILL
HI WITH SO. HI HER TADO HI
JACKSON FIVE LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE
AYE MITCHELL. HI MONNING HI
NIELSEN. PAN HI PORTANTINO. I
ROTH HI RUBIO. FIVE SKINNER.
STERN NUMBER RIGHT HI MY COUNTY
I WIENER. HI THANK YOU MOVING
TO A REMOTE VOTING MEMBERS THIS
IS MAJOR. TWO ZERO FOUR THREE
PLEASE PROCEED. FACE BATES AB
TWO ZERO FOUR THREE ABSTAINED.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE CENTER GROUP
YOUR HAND UP AGAIN. I KNOW
MA'AM OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH
TERRY SORRY TERRY PLEASE
PROCEED. GORGEOUS BORJAS EIGHTY
TWO ZERO FOUR THREE ABSTAINED.
CHIANG. TANG AB TWO ZERO FOUR
THREE I. ALI AB TWO ZERO FOUR
THREE I DALLY HI ROSE. GROWTH
AB TWO ZERO FOUR THREE
ABSTAINED. MELENDEZ MELENDEZ AB
TWO ZERO FOUR THREE AYE
MELINDA'S AYE MORLOCK. AB TWO
OH FOUR THREE HI MORE LOCK FIVE
MORALE. EIGHTY TWO OH FOUR
THREE STATE. WILK. WILK AB
TWENTY FORTY THREE BY WILK I
SENATOR MOVES TO CALL MEMBERS
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE BACK TO
FILE ITEM FORTY ONE SENATOR
UMBERG MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN OH
FOUR BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER WALDRON
AN ACT RELATING TO PAROLE
CENTER AMBER I THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT MEMBERS- THIS IS A
BILL THAT IS SPONSORED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALDRON IT
CREATES THE CALIFORNIA REENTRY
INCENTIVE PROGRAM WHICH MAKES A
PAUL ROWLEY- EXCEPT AS
SPECIFIED ELIGIBLE FOR ADOPTION
IN THE PERIOD OF PAROLE IF THE
PERSON SUCCESSFULLY
PARTICIPATES IN A SUBSTANCE
ABUSE TREATMENT PROGRAM.
EVERYBODY SUPPORTS THIS BILL
IT'S A GOOD IDEA TO GINGIVAL.
THANK YOU CENTER- BURKE.
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE HERE ON
THE FLOOR. SEEING AND HEARING
NONE SEEING NO HANDS UP FROM A
REMOTE VOTING MEMBERS MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. FIVE ARCHULETA FIVE
ATKINS HIS FELL. BRADFORD AYE
CABRERA I DODD. HI TERRAZZA. HI
GALGIANI I GLAZER. GONZALEZ HI
HERTZBERG. HELLO I HUESO. BY
HER TADO HI JACKSON I LEYVA. I
MCGUIRE. MITCHELL MCGUIRE AYE
MITCHELL. I MONEY I NIELSEN.
PAN I PORTANTINO HI ROTH I
RUBIO HI SKINNER. STERN NUMBER
I Y. CASKEY I WIENER. HI THANK
YOU MADAM SECRETARY INTO A
REMOTE VOTING MEMBERS THIS IS
AB THIRTEEN ZERO FOUR MADAM
SECRETARY. BATES BATES AB
THIRTEEN ZERO FOUR HI. SIX FIVE
FORGES. OR JUST AB THIRTEEN OH
FOUR I FOR JUST FIVE CHIANG.
HEY AB THIRTEEN OH FOUR I
CHIANG MAI DALLY. DALY AB
THIRTEEN OH FOUR AYE DALLY AYE
GROWTH. AB THIRTEEN OH FOUR I.
GROVE HI MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ AB
THIRTEEN OH FOUR I MUNDAS I
MORE LOCK. AB THIRTEEN OH FOUR
HI MORLOCK HIGH MORALE. WELL AB
THIRTEEN OH FOUR ABSTAINED.
WILK WILK EIGHTY THIRTEEN OH
FOUR HI WILK HI. SENATOR MOVES
TO CALL MEMBERS REMOVING THE
FILE ITEM FORTY FOUR SENATOR
PANEL MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY ONE FOURTEEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RODRIGUEZ AND AFTER
LEADING TO HIGHER EDUCATION
EMPLOYMENT RELATIONS THANK YOU
FOR READING NOT CALLING THE
ROLE SENATOR PAN. THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT SENATORS I'M
PLEASED TO PRESENT AT TWENTY
ONE FOURTEEN BY S. A MEMBER
RODRIGUEZ- REGARDING MINIMUM
DUE PROCESS RIGHTS FOR. CERTAIN
EMPLOYEES ON THE VERY FRONT
LINES OF CARING FOR A CO THAT
PATIENTS ARE RESIDENT
PHYSICIANS. THESE ARE
PHYSICIANS WHO HAVE COMPLETED A
RIGOROUS FOUR YEARS OF
EDUCATION IN MEDICAL SCHOOL OR
DENTAL SCHOOL THEY ARE NOW
PRACTICING UNDER SUPERVISION.
AND WHILE THE PRACTICING UNDER
SUPERVISION UNFORTUNATELY- THEY
HAVE. L. DUE PROCESS RIGHTS
BECAUSE OF THAT THEY DON'T HAVE
BASIC RIGHTS- INCLUDING
REGARDING DETERMINATION
PLACEMENT OR DISCIPLINE.
THEY'RE ALSO VERY VULNERABLE
BECAUSE WITHOUT THIS PERIOD OF.
CHAIR UNDER SUPERVISION- IF
THEY IF THE PEOPLE SUPERVISING
THEM- DECIDED THEY COULD
ACTUALLY PREVENT THEM FROM EVER
PRACTICING GETTING A LICENSE IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. AND I
HOPE THAT WE CAN ALL AGREE-
THAT IS NOT FAIR. THAT IS
IMPORTANT THAT THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE PROVIDING CARE TO EITHER US
OR OUR LOVED ONES ARE ABLE TO
SPEAK OUT IF THEY BELIEVE THAT.
CARE COULD BE IMPROVED THAT
THERE WORKPLACE SAFETY COULD BE
IMPROVED AND THAT THEY WOULD
NOT BE SUBJECT TO- PENALTY
WITHOUT THE RIGHT TO. WITHOUT
DUE PROCESS RIGHTS- THIS BILL.
DOES ST AN EXCEPTION FOR THE
FACT THAT THERE'S PEOPLE
PRACTICING UNDER SUPERVISION
THAT IF THERE ARE ISSUES WITH
THEIR QUALITY PRACTICE. THAT
THAT THAT WOULD NOT BE SUBJECT
THAT THEY- WOULD BE- THEIR
SUPERVISORS- COULD CONTINUE TO
EVALUATE THEM AND ALLOW THEM TO
PROGRESSIVE THEY ARE. MEET THE
STANDARDS THEY'RE NECESSARY.
BUT WE DO NEED TO BE SURE THAT
THESE RESIDENT PHYSICIANS. WHO
ARE SPENDING YEARS. EARLY YEARS
PREPARING FOR INDEPENDENT
PRACTICE. SO THAT THEY ALSO
HAVE DUE PROCESS RIGHTS SO THEY
CAN SPEAK OUT BECAUSE THEY ARE
ON THE FRONT LINES PROVIDING
CARE AND PARTICULARLY NOW WITH
COATED SO THIS BILL SPONSORED
BY SEIU IN SUPPORT BUT MANY
OTHERS AND ESPECIALLY ASK
FORTNITE THANK YOU CENTER PAN
MEMBERS ON THE FLOOR DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE SEEING AND HEARING
NONE. REMOTE VOTING MEMBERS
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE I'VE SEEN
OUR HANDS RAISED. ADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN ARCHULETA I ATKINS FIVE
TELL. BRADFORD HI CABALLERO HI
DODD. NO THE RAZA I GALGIANI I
GLAZER. GONZALEZ HI HERTZBERG.
HELLO HUESO. I HER TADO. HI
JACKSON LEYVA HI MCGUIRE. FIVE
MITCHELL. I MONNING I NIELSEN.
NO HAN I PORTANTINO. I ROTH HI
RUBIO. SKINNER STERN. NUMBER
BYE BYE CASKEY. I WIENER HI.
HELLO FIVE. THE TERM OPENING
MEMBERS THIS IS AB TWO ONE ONE
FOUR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
BATES AB BANK'S AB TWO ONE ONE
FOUR NO. BATES NOW FOR JUST.
FORGES AB TWENTY ONE FOURTEEN
NO PORGES NO CHIANG. THANK AB
TWENTY ONE FOURTEEN NO HANG NO
DALLI DALLI AB TWO ONE ONE FOUR
NO DALY NO GROWTH. GROSS AB TWO
ONE ONE FOUR NO GROVE NO
MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ AB TWO ONE
ONE FOR NOW MELENDEZ NO MORE
LOCK. AB TWO ONE ONE FOUR NO
MORE LOCK NO MARROW. AB TWO ONE
ONE FOR MORALITY NO MORALE NO
WILK. WILK AB TWO ONE ONE FOUR
NO WILK NOW. SENATOR MOVES A
CALL MEMBERS JUST A QUICK
UPDATE LUNCH WILL BE AT NOON
WE'D LIKE YOU TO TAKE FIFTEEN
MINUTES AND TAKE YOUR LUNCH
BACK TO YOUR OFFICE WE WILL
RECONVENE AS CLOSE TO TWELVE
FIFTEEN AS POSSIBLE WE WILL
WORK UNTIL TWO PM AND THEN
ADJOURNED THE COMMITTEES THAT
WILL BE MEETING IS JUDICIARY
AND FORTY TWO OH THREE AT TWO
FIFTEEN. AM BUDGET WILL BE
MEETING HERE IN THE CHAMBER AT
FOUR THIRTY BUT LET'S TRY AND
GET THROUGH A FEW MORE MAJORS
BEFORE WE BREAK FOR LUNCH FILE
ITEM FORTY SIX SENATOR WIENER.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TO
EIGHTEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SANTIAGO AN ACT RELATING TO
ACCESS TO HEALTH SERVICES
CENTER WIENER. I THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENTS ARE COLLEAGUES
I RISE TODAY IS A PROUD CO
AUTHOR- THE SENATE BILL TWENTY
TWO EIGHTEEN BY SOME MEMBERS
SANTIAGO- WHICH WILL HELP
PROVIDE MEDICAL AND DIRECT
SUPPORT OF SERVICES TO OUR
TRANSGENDER GENDER NON
CONFORMING AND INTERSEX
COMMUNITIES ARE TGI
COMMUNITIES. ARE THERE ARE
ALARMING DISPARITIES IN HEALTH
CARE FOR TGI PEOPLE IN OUR
STATE- AND THESE DISPARITIES
HAVE BEEN. EXACERBATED BY THE
COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC AB
TWENTY TWO EIGHTEEN WILL UPON
APPROPRIATION BY THE
LEGISLATURE PROVIDE GRANTS TO
ORGANIZATIONS SERVING THE TGI
COMMUNITY AND QUALIFIED HEALTH
CARE PROVIDERS. THIS WILL HELP
CREATE PROGRAMS THAT PROVIDE
MEDICAL AND DIRECT SUPPORTER
SERVICES FOR TRANS AND GENDER
NON CONFORMING. AND INTERSEX
PEOPLE. MISTER SENATOR PER MAKE
TECHNICAL SAID HERMAN USED IN
THE BILL AND A CLARIFICATIONS
TO THE TYPES OF ORGANIZATIONS I
CAN BENEFIT FROM THE GROUNDS
OUTLINED IN THE BILL. THE BILL
HAS SUPPORT FROM NEARLY ONE
HUNDRED- LGBTQ I A PLUS
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATIONS AND
HEALTHCARE ORGANIZATIONS
INCLUDING THE AMERICAN ACADEMY
OF PEDIATRICS. AND EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
CENTER WIENER MEMBERS OF THE
FLOOR ANY DISCUSSION AND OR
DEBATE. SENATOR ALSO. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND I RISE AGAIN
BUT ALSO TO SUPPORT AB TWENTY
TWO EIGHTEEN- CALIFORNIANS
RECOGNIZE HEALTHCARE IS A BASIC
HUMAN RIGHT BUT MANY
COMMUNITIES CONTINUE TO
EXPERIENCE OBSTACLES. THAT
INCLUDES THE D. G. I.
COMMUNITIES MANY OF WHOM STILL
LACK ACCESS TO RECEIVING SAFE
NON DISCRIMINATORY AND
COMPREHENSIVE CARE. WELL THE
HUMAN RIGHTS CAMPAIGN IS
DESIGNATED EIGHTY FIVE HEALTH
CARE FACILITIES IN THE STATE AS
LGBTQ HEALTHCARE EQUALITY
LEADERS BUT WE MUST WORK TO
ENSURE THAT EVERY FACILITY
SHOULD HAVE HEALTHCARE I'M
PROVIDE CULTURALLY COMPETENT
CARE I WANT TO GIVE A SHOUT OUT
TO OUR TRANSLATE THE NO
COALITION MEDINA COALITION IN
MY DISTRICT. WE HAVE BEEN
CRITICAL IN OUR COMMUNITY AND
UP AS A SERVICE PROVIDER
FOUNDED ON THE ACTIVISM OF
TRANSGENDER IMMIGRANTS HAVE
BEEN STRONG KEY CHAMPIONS FOR
TRANSFORMING THE NATIONAL
CLIMATE FOR TJ PEOPLE ACROSS
OUR COUNTRY AND HELPING TO
CREATE A SYSTEM THAT IS TRULY
RESPONSIVE TO THE NEEDS OF THE
TGI COMMUNITIES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR DORADO
SENATOR GROVE. WE CAN SEE YOU.
YEAH CAN YOU HEAR ME WE CAN
OKAY THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
AND TODAY I RISE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION AS- OF TWENTY TWO AB
TWENTY TWO EIGHTEEN ONCE AGAIN
THE MAJORITY PARTY HAS AND
CONTINUE TO IGNORE THE PLEAS OF
PARENTS ACROSS THE STATE THE
GOVERNMENT I'M SHOULD NOT BE IN
THE BUSINESS OF INCENTIVIZING
DOCTORS TO RUSH YOUNG CHILDREN
TO MAKE A DECISION THAT'S LIFE
ALTERING AND YOUR REVERSIBLE.
BEFORE THEY EVEN REACH THE
EMOTIONAL AND PHYSICAL-
MATURITY WE SHOULD BE FOR ON TO
THE LEGITIMATE CONCERNS OF
PARENTS IN THE STATE AND SO I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO
VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER ST
MORALE. SORRY ABOUT THAT- YEAH
I STAND IN OPPOSITION AB TWENTY
TWO EIGHTEEN YOU KNOW THE
CONSENT FORM AT THE CHILDREN'S
HOSPITAL LOS ANGELES STATES THE
US. REGARDING MINORS IN THEIR
PARENTS IT SAYS IF YOUR CHILD
STARTS PUBERTY BLOCKERS IN THE
EARLIEST STAGES OF PUBERTY AND
THEN GOES ON TO GENDER
AFFIRMING HORMONES THEY WILL
NOT HAVE BIOLOGICAL CHILDREN.
YOU KNOW IT WILL. SUCH
DEPRAVITY HERE IN CALIFORNIA
THESE DAYS I'M IT'S TO DIRECT
THIS KIND OF STUFF. AND OUR
CHILDREN ARE MOST VULNERABLE-
BEFORE THEY'RE AT THE AGE WHERE
THEY HOULD BE ABLE TO MAKE
THESE. DECISIONS FOR THEMSELVES
THIS IS YOUR SOUL ROCK THIS
THIS IS BAD SO OBVIOUSLY I'M A
NO VOTE AND I DOUBT OF MY
FRIENDS ACROSS THE AISLE ARE
GONNA BE A NOBLE BUT THIS IS
WRONG. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU CENTER MORALE CENTER
GONZALEZ. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES I JUST
WANNA THANK AT THE AUTHOR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO AND MY
GOOD COLLEAGUE FROM SAN
FRANCISCO FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD AS A AYE REPRESENTATIVE
OF. A DISTRICT WHO HAS MANY
TEACHER COMMUNITY MEMBERS I'M
JUST THANKFUL THAT WE'RE
ABSOLUTELY SUPPORTING- AND A
WELLNESS PLAN FOR THEM THEY'RE
OFTEN LEFT OUT OF THE
DISCUSSIONS AS IT PERTAINS LG
DEAD GREATER LGBT COMMUNITY AND
FOR THAT I'M JUST EXTREMELY
THANKFUL NINETY. I REALLY FEEL
AS STRONGLY THAT WE NEED TO
MOVE THIS FORWARD BUT I'M ALSO
APPALLED BY A LOT OF THE
COMMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN MADE
ABOUT THE COMMUNITY AND ABOUT
WHAT THIS PLAN WOULD ACTUALLY
DO THANK YOU. HERE THEY ARE
HAND. SHE'S A CENTER CONSOLE
CENTER MORE JUST SO KNOW WE CAN
HEAR EVERYTHING YOU'RE SAYING
SO BE CAREFUL. SEEING NO HANDS
UP FROM A REMOTE VOTERS AND
SEEING NO LIGHTS UP ON THE
FLOOR SENATOR WIENER YOU MAY
CLOSE. ONE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
TRYING TO PRESIDENT YOU KNOW I
THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT TO
STEP BACK. AND TAKE A LOOK AT
OUR TRANSGENDER. GENDER
NONCONFORMING AND INTERSEX.
COMMUNITIES THESE ARE PEOPLE
WHO ARE THEY'RE PART OF OUR
SOCIETY THEY ARE OUR NEIGHBORS
THEY ARE OUR FRIENDS THEY ARE
MEMBERS. OF OUR FAMILY. THEY
ARE WORKERS WHO SERVE US WHEN
WE GO INTO A STARBUCKS OR INTO
AN OFFICE. WHERE MEMBERS OF THE
CAPITAL COMMUNITY THERE ARE
PEOPLE WHO ARE EMPLOYED IN OUR
OFFICES THEY'RE PEOPLE WHO
SERVE N ELECTED OFFICE. AND
PEOPLE FROM WHO ARE AT THE
HEIGHTS OF OUR SOCIETY AND WHO
SUCCEEDED THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
LIVING ON OUR STREETS. THIS IS
A COMMUNITY THAT HAS BEEN WITH
US FOR EVER THIS IS NOTHING NEW.
BUT WHAT IS NEW IS THAT WE ARE
FINALLY STARTING TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THE BASIC HUMANITY. BOB TRANS
GENDER NON CONFORMING AND
INTERSEX PEOPLE IN OUR SOCIETY.
THESE ARE PEOPLE IN OUR
COMMUNITIES WHO HAVE BEEN TOLD
OVER AND OVER AGAIN. THAT THEY
HAVE NO WORSE. BETTER NOT
ACTUALLY PART OF OUR COMMUNITY.
AND WHO HAVE BEEN TREATED LIKE
GARBAGE. IN THIS SOCIETY
FOREVER. THIS IS A COMMUNITY
THAT BECAUSE OF THE STIGMA.
BECAUSE THEY HAVE BEEN TREATED
WITH WITH SUCH UTTER DISDAIN
AND DISRESPECT THE TERM
UNEMPLOYMENT RATES ARE THROUGH
THE ROOF. THAT SUICIDE RATES
ARE HIGH BECAUSE SOCIETY TELLS
THEM DAY AFTER DAY THAT THEY
HAVE NO VALUE. AND THEY LACK
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE. THEY ARE
CRIMINALIZED. THEY ARE OVER
REPRESENTED IN OUR STATE PRISON
SYSTEM. BECAUSE SOCIETY TELLS
THEM FROM THE BEGINNING
EXCLUDING WHEN THEY ARE
CHILDREN THAT THERE IS
SOMETHING WRONG WITH THEM. AND
YES TRANSSEXUALS RENDON BAR
TRANS AND THEY ARE ALSO MEMBERS
OF OUR COMMUNITY AND THEY ARE
OUR CHILDREN AND WE SHOULD BE
EMBRACING THEM FOR WHO THEY ARE
AND PROVIDING THEM WITH THE
HEALTH CARE. THAT THEY NEED.
THIS BILL SIMPLY SAYS THAT
TRANS PEOPLE SHOULD HAVE ACCESS
TO HEALTH CARE. THERE IS
NOTHING RADICAL OR CRAZY ABOUT
THAT. AND IT SAYS THAT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA IS GOING TO
STEP UP TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
PUT THE ESOURCES NEEDED FOR
THIS COMMUNITY TO SUCCEED AND
TO ACCESS HEALTH CARE WE HAVE
SO MUCH HATE IN THIS COUNTRY.
I'M ONE TRANSPORT TOLD OVER AND
OVER AGAIN THAT IF YOU'RE A
TRANS WOMAN WHO WANTS TO USE. A
MATT A WOMAN'S RESTROOM THAT
THAT MUST MEAN THAT YOU'RE NOT
REALLY TRANS YOUR TO SPEAKING
OUT SO YOU CAN SCAN YOUR WAY
INTO INTO WOMEN'S RESTROOMS AS
OPPOSED TO SIMPLY BEING A WOMAN
WHO WANTS TO USE. THE RESTROOM
ARE TOLD OVER AND OVER AGAIN
YOU MUST BE A PREDATOR YOU MUST
BE FACING IF YOU'RE TRANS KID
WANTS TO PLAY SPORTS. YOU'RE
JUST TRYING TO SCAM THE SYSTEM.
NO ONE SCAMMING THE SYSTEM THIS
IS ABOUT PEOPLE WHO ARE JUST
LIVING THEIR LIVES LET'S MAKE
SURE THEY CAN ACCESS HEALTH
CARE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU WIENER
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN HI ARCHULETA AYE
ATKINS I FELL. BRADFORD I COME
BY. I DON. HI TORONTO I
GALGIANI I GLAZER GONZALEZ I
HERTZBERG HI HILL AYE HUESO. HI
HER TADO HI JACKSON I LEYVA HI
MCGUIRE. I MITCHELL I MONNING I
NIELSEN. NO HAN FIVE PORTANTINO
I ROTH. HI RUBIO. FIVE SKINNER.
STERN I'M BURKE ALL RIGHT FIVE
WHY CASTING. I WIENER I. FOR
REMOTE VOTING MEMBERS MEMBERS
THIS IS AB TWO TWO ONE EIGHT
MADAM SECRETARY. BATES BATES AB
TWO EIGHT NO BABIES NO FOR JUST.
JUST EIGHTY TWO TWO ONE EIGHT
ABSTAINED. CHIANG THANK AB TWO
TWO ONE EIGHT NOW CHIANG NO
DALLY. DALY AB TWO TWO ONE
EIGHT NO. DALLY NO GROWTH GROSS
AB TWO TWO ONE EIGHT NOW GROVE
NO MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ AB TWO
TWO ONE EIGHT NOW MELENDEZ NO
MORE LOCK. AB TWO TWO ONE EIGHT
NO MORLOCK NO MORALE WERE L. A.
B. TWO TWO ONE EIGHT NOW. L. NO
WILK. AB TWO TWO ONE EIGHT NO
WILK NOW CENTER MOVES A CALL
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO MOVE TO
FILE ITEM FORTY SEVEN SENATOR
GALGIANI MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWO
EIGHTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
EGGMAN AN ACT RELATING TO SOLID
WASTE WASTE SENATOR JOHNNY
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTY
SEVEN ADDRESSES A FEW DIFFERENT
ASPECTS OF OUR SOLID WASTE
STREAM INCLUDING NUMBER ONE
CLEANING UP AND UPDATING
REFERENCES TO DEGRADE ABILITY
STANDARDS. AND OUR TRUTH IN
ADVERTISING LAWS TO ADDING AN
INTERNATIONALLY RECOGNIZED
STANDARD FOR DEGRADABLE
AGRICULTURAL FILM THREE
EXTENDING THE TIMELINE BY SEVEN
MONTHS FOR THE STATEWIDE
COMMISSION ON RECYCLING MARKETS
AND CURBSIDE RECYCLING TO
FINALIZE RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
INCREASED PUBLIC PART
PARTICIPATION. AND FOR
EXTENDING THE DEADLINE FOR
THEME PARKS TO INSTALL COMPOST
BINS FOR ONE YEAR DUE TO
PROVIDE NINETEEN THIS BILL HAS
PASSED UNANIMOUSLY IN BOTH
HOUSES AND IS SUPPORTED BY
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUPS SOME OF
THE PLASTIC INDUSTRY AND THE
CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU AND
MORE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU CENTER
GALGIANI MEMBERS ON THE FLOOR
SINGLE MICROPHONE DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE SCENE OF- MICROPHONES
RAISED. MEMBERS PARTICIPATE
REMOTELY NO HANDS UP BETTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS I
TELL. BRADFORD HI CABALLERO I
DODD I TO RAZA. I GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER GONZALEZ I HERTZBERG I
HILL AYE HUESO. HER TADO I
JACKSON. I LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE I
MITCHELL I MONEY. I NIELSEN I
CAN I PORTANTINO. HI ROTH AYE
RUBIO. I SKINNER STERN NUMBER
FIVE Y. CASKEY I WIENER. HI
HUESO HI. MOVING TO A REMOTE
VOTING MEMBERS THIS IS AB TWO
TWO EIGHT SEVEN BENHAM
SECRETARY. BATES H. EIGHTY TWO
TWO EIGHT SEVEN HIGH. EIGHT HI
GORGEOUS JUST EIGHTY TWO TWO
EIGHT SEVEN I'D GORGEOUS HIGH
CHIANG. DURING AB TWO TWO EIGHT
SEVEN HI CHIANG MAI DALLY. DALY
AB TWO TWO EIGHT SEVEN HI SALLY
I GROWTH. AT GROWTH AB TWO TWO
EIGHT SEVEN I GROWTH HI
MELINDA'S. MELENDEZ AB TWO TWO
EIGHT SEVEN I WONDER HI MORLOCK.
AB. TWO TWO EIGHT SEVEN NINE
MORLOCK HIGH MORALE. L. A. B.
TWO TWO EIGHT SEVEN FIVE
MORRELL HI WILK. WILK AB TWO
TWO EIGHT SEVEN HI WILK HI
SENATOR MUSICAL MEMBERS WE ARE
NOW GOING TO BREAK FOR LUNCH
AND LET'S DO IT NICE AND QUICK
FIFTEEN MINUTES AS CLOSE AS
POSSIBLE AND THEN WE WILL
RECONVENE AS CLOSE TO TWO
FIFTEEN AS POSSIBLE THANK YOU.
WELL GOOD AFTERNOON SENATORS
WERE GONNA BE KICKING OFF OUR
AFTERNOON SESSION LADIES AND
JENISON IN WE'RE GOING ASSET
ALL INDIVIDUALS PLEASE TAKE
THEIR SEATS WERE GRATEFUL FOR
YOUR PATIENCE AND FOR ALL OF
YOUR HARD WORK. WE'RE GOING TO
TAKE IT UP FOR BILLS ON BEHALF
OF THE PRESIDING OFFICER WILL
BE GOING. TO BED AT OF FILE
ORDER AT THIS TIME TO THE
OFFICER TO PRESENT IS FOR BILLS.
I'M GONNA NOW GIVE US THE FOR
BILLS THAT WE'RE GONNA BE
COVERING WE'RE GONNA BE
COVERING FILE ITEM FIFTY SEVEN.
FILE ITEM EIGHTY TWO. FILE ITEM
NINETY TWO. IN FILE ITEM ONE OH
TWO. FOUR BILLS ON BEHALF OF
THE PRESIDING OFFICERS CENTER
LEYVA. CENTER LEYVA IS PREPARED
TO PRESENT OUR FIRST BILL IF
FILE ITEM FIFTY SEVEN. MEN OF
SECTOR CAN YOU PLEASE REPEAT.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THIRTY
SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER WORKS
AN ACT RELATING TO HEALTH
FACILITIES GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
CENTER LABOR THE FLOOR'S YOURS
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS TODAY I RISE
TO PRESENT AB TWENTY THIRTY
SEVEN. CURRENTLY HOSPITAL
CALIFORNIA HOSPITALS PLANNING
ON CLOSING OR DOWNGRADING
SERVICES ARE ONLY REQUIRED TO
GIVE NINETY DAYS OR THREE
MONTHS OF NOTICE PRIOR TO
CLOSING TO THE SURROUNDING
PUBLIC. THE LOSS OF ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE AND THE CLOSURE OF
A HOSPITAL POSE SIGNIFICANT
HEALTH RISKS FOR LOW INCOME
INDIVIDUALS THE ELDERLY AND
FAMILIES IN THE COMMUNITY WITH
OR WITHOUT A GLOBAL PANDEMIC.
THE CURRENT LAW OF NINETY DAYS
ARE ONLY THREE MONTHS OF
NOTIFICATION IS NOT NEARLY
ENOUGH TIME. THE AUTHOR HAS
WORKED WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE TO ENSURE THAT THIS BILL
WITH ADDED AMENDMENTS WILL HELP
CALIFORNIANS DURING THIS
PANDEMIC AND BEYOND HAVE ACCESS
TO HEALTH CARE. AND HEALTH
FACILITIES. AB TWO ZERO THREE
SEVEN EXTENSIVE PUBLIC
NOTIFICATION PERIODS FOR
HOSPITALS AND HEALTH FACILITIES
THAT PLAN TO DOWNGRADE
SERVICES. CHANGE THEIR SERVICES.
ARE CLOSE THE FACILITY TO ONE
HUNDRED AND EIGHT DAYS OR SO
MONTHS. WITH THE ADDED
AMENDMENT HEALTH CARE
FACILITIES WITHOUT AN EMERGENCY
ROOM MUST NOTIFY THE COMMUNITY
A HUNDRED AND TWENTY DAYS PRIOR
TO THE CLOSURE. RATHER THAN A
HUNDRED AND EIGHTY DAYS.
COMMUNITIES NEED MORE NOTICE
AND TIME WHEN HOSPITALS CLOSE
SO THAT WE CAN ENSURE CONTINUED
ACCESS TO ESSENTIAL CARE. I
BELIEVE AB TWO ZERO THREE SEVEN
GIVES COMMUNITIES THIS PRECIOUS
TIME TO ACT SO THEY WILL HAVE
ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER LEYVA
LET'S EITHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE FLOOR DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE ON THE FLOOR. WE'RE
LOOKING FOR ALL THOSE PRESENT
IN THE CHAMBERS OR ANYONE
REMOTELY. DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE FLOOR. HEARING SEEING.
NINE MR SECRETARY CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. YOU.
ALLEN ARCHULETA I ATKINS I TELL.
BRADFORD HI CABRERA. DODD
DRAZEN HI GALGIANI. GLAZER
GONZALEZ. HI HERTZBERG. I TELL
FIVE HUESO I HER TADO. JACKSON
I LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE
MITCHELL. I MONNING. HI NIELSEN.
HI PAM HI PORTANTINO. HI ROTH
HI RUBIO. SKINNER STERN. AMBERG
BY CASKEY I WIENER HI. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN THE SENATE WE'RE
NOW GOING TO BE GOING TO THOSE
ARE PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
WE'RE GOING TO ASK EACH
INDIVIDUAL SENATORS
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY TO BE A
STATE YOUR NAME THE BILL NUMBER
IN YOUR VOTE AT THE CENTER
NIELSEN FOR WHAT PURPOSE YOU
RISE. HI YEAH NIELSEN I TO KNOW.
ALL RIGHT TO LAYS IN GERMAN
WE'RE NOT GONNA BE GOING TO
THOSE WHO PARTICIPATE REMOTELY
WE WANT TO SAY THANK YOU FOR
ALL OF THE WORK OF ALL SENATORS
WERE ON BILL NUMBER AB TWENTY
THIRTY SEVEN AB TWENTY THIRTY
SEVEN WE'RE GOING TO ASK FOR
THE CENTER'S NAME THE BILL
NUMBER AND THE VOTE. MADAM
SECRETARY. FACE BATES AB TWENTY
THIRTY SEVEN NO BATES NOW FOR
JUST BORDERS AB TWO ZERO THREE
SEVEN NOW BARGES NOW CHIANG.
CHANGE. CHANGE AB TWENTY THIRTY
SEVEN NO CHANGE NO DALLY. KELLY
AB TWENTY THIRTY SEVEN NO DALLY
NO GROWTH. AB TWENTY THIRTY
SEVEN NOW GROVE NO MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ AB TWENTY THIRTY SEVEN
NOW MELENDEZ NO MORE LOCK.
MISTER PRESIDENT MORE A LOT.
EIGHT TWO SEVEN. MORLOCK NO
MORAL L. A. ALL THREE SEVEN NOW
MORALE NO WILK. WILK AB TWENTY
THIRTY SEVEN NO WILK NO. CENTER
MUSICAL THANK YOU SENATORS
MEMBERS ARE NOT GONNA BE MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM EIGHTY TWO THE
NEW NINETY TWO AND THEN A ONE
OH TWO. THEIR LATEST REPAIRED
RISEN ON FILE ITEM EIGHTY TWO
MINUTE SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE
READ. ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN
FIFTY EIGHT BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
QUIRK AND ACTUALLY TO CANNABIS
WELCOME BACK SIR LEYVA I THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT GOOD AFTERNOON
MEMBERS I RISE TODAY TO PRESENT
AB FOURTEEN FIFTY EIGHT WHICH
MODIFIES THE ALLOWED VARIANCE
IN CANNABIS LABORATORY TESTING.
CURRENTLY A CERTIFICATE OF
ANALYSIS CANNOT APPROVE AN
EDIBLE FOR SALE IF IT CONTAINS
A T. H. C. OF TEN MILLIGRAMS
PER SERVING PLUS OR MINUS TEN
PERCENT. AB FOURTEEN FIFTY
EIGHT INCREASES THE VARIANCE
212% UNTIL JANUARY ONE TWENTY
TWENTY TWO THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION AND THERE HAS BEEN
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER
WE'RENOW LOOKING FOR
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR DISCUSSION OR DEBATE FROM
ALL SENATORS DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE FROM ALL SENATORS. WE
HAVE SENATOR DOLLY CENTER DOLLY
PLEASE. THANK YOU MEMBERS I
JUST WANT TO SAY I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS. MEASURE IT'S
BEEN A LONG TIME COMING ALI I
APOLOGIZE FOR IT IS GOING TO
GET YOU UP ON THE SCREEN I
REALLY APOLOGIZE FOR
INTERRUPTING YOU WE'RE JUST
GONNA GET YOU UP ON THE SCREEN
AND I'LL GIVE YOU A- THERE WE
GO IT'S GOOD TO SEE THE GOOD
SENATOR NICE TO SEE A CENTER
DOLLY THE FLOOR IS YOURS I
APOLOGIZE ABOUT THAT. NO
PROBLEM THANK YOU I. JUST
WANTED TO SAY THAT THIS IS A
REALLY COMMONSENSE BILL. BEEN
LOOKING FORWARD TO- THIS. BILL
COMING FORWARD. JUST FOR THE
FACT IS THAT PEOPLE NEED TO
KNOW. WHAT WHAT'S IN THE
ANIMALS AND WHAT- THE LEVELS
ARE. AS WE DO WITH ALL KINDS OF
OTHER BUSINESSES AND STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHEN YOU'RE SELLING
PRODUCTS. BY THE WAY. THIS THE
AMOUNT OF PROTEIN GRAMS ALL
THOSE THINGS ARE IN THOSE OTHER
PRODUCTS AND- I THINK THIS IS A
VERY COMMON SENSE BILL LONG
TIME WAITING. URGENT ABOUT.
RAPE OF YOUR COMMENTS SIR IT'S
GOOD TO SEE YOU. WE'RE GOING TO
SEE IF THERE'S ANY ADDITIONAL
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE FLOOR. LAST CALL. WHAT
ARE GOING TO GO TO CENTER LATER
FOR CLUES. RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
NAY VOTE THANK YOU SO MUCH
CERTAINLY DIMINISH SECTOR CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN
HI ARCHULETA I ATKINS I TELL
BRADFORD I HAVE A ADAM I DON.
FIVE TERRAZZA FIVE GALGIANI I
GLAZER GONZALEZ HI HERTZBERG HI
HILL AYE HUESO. HI HER TADO.
JACKSON I LEYVA. HI MCGUIRE. I
MITCHELL. I MONEY I NIELSEN.
PAN FIVE PORTANTINO FIVE ROTH
HI RUBIO. SKINNER STERN. NUMBER
FIVE MY COUNTY I WIENER. HI
WHAT IS IN GERMAN SENATE NOW
GOING TO BE TRANSITIONING TO
THOSE FOR PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY WE'RE GOING TO ASK
EACH INDIVIDUAL CENTER TO BE A
POLICE SAY THEIR NAME BILL
NUMBER IN THE VOTE WE'RE VOTING
RIGHT NOW ON BILL NUMBER.
FOURTEEN FIFTY EIGHT. BETTER
SECTOR CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. FACE BATES AB FOURTEEN
FIFTY EIGHT NO BATES NOW
GORGEOUS. BURGESS AB FOURTEEN
FIFTY EIGHT EPSTEIN. CHIANG
CHIANG AB FOURTEEN FIFTY EIGHT
BY CHIANG HI DOLLY. DALY AB
FOURTEEN FIFTY EIGHT HI DELHI
HIGH GROWTH. AB FOURTEEN FIFTY
EIGHT NOW GROVE NO MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ AB FOURTEEN FIFTY
EIGHT NOW MELENDEZ NO MORE LOCK.
AB FOURTEEN FIFTY EIGHT HI
MORLOCK HIGH MORALE. MORRELL AB
FOURTEEN FIFTY EIGHT NOW
MORRELL NO WILK. WILK AB
FOURTEEN FIFTY EIGHT HI WILK HI
THANK YOU SO MUCH SENATORS
THOROUGHLY REMOVES THE CALL
WE'RE NOW MOVING ON TO FILE
ITEM NINETY TWO MEN AND SECTOR
CAN YOU PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CERVANTES AN
ACTUAL RELATING TO ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT CENTER LEYVA. THANK
YOU MISTER MCGUIRE MANAGE MR
RESIDENT. I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT AB FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN
WHICH ESTABLISHES A PILOT
PROJECT TO SUPPORT THE
ENHANCEMENT OF A REGIONAL
TRAINING CENTER NETWORK. WHICH
CAN WORK HAND IN HAND WITH
BUSINESS OWNERS SMALL BUSINESS
SERVICE PROVIDERS AND OTHER
WORKFORCE PARTNERS TO GET
PEOPLE BACK TO WORK. OVER EIGHT
MILLION CALIFORNIANS FILED FOR
SOME FORMA UNEMPLOYMENT
ASSISTANCE BETWEEN MARCH
FOURTEENTH AND AUGUST FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY. MANY OF THE
INDUSTRY SECTORS MOST IMPACTED
DURING THE PANDEMIC ARE NOT
EXPECTED TO RETURN TO PRE
PANDEMIC LEVELS OF ECONOMIC
ACTIVITY FOR SEVERAL YEARS.
INCLUDING BUSINESSES OF
HOSPITALITY ACCOMMODATION AND
TOURISM. EVEN IN THOSE
INDUSTRIES SECTORS THAT ARE
ANTICIPATED TO RECOVER MORE
QUICKLY MANY LOWER SKILLED JOBS
WILL BE PERMANENTLY REPLACED OR
SIGNIFICANTLY MODIFIED. THROUGH
AUTOMATION AND IQAMA COMMERCE
BUSINESS MODELS. IS SIGNIFICANT
NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE
EXPERIENCED NEGATIVE IMPACT.
DUE TO COVERT AND THE PANDEMIC
ARE WOMEN AND PEOPLE OF COLOR
WITH LIMITED EDUCATION AND
TRAINING BEYOND HIGH SCHOOL. AB
FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN LEVERAGES
EXISTING PROGRAMS AND
COMPETENCIES TO RESPOND TO
THESE COVERED NINETEEN
UNEMPLOYMENT CHALLENGES
QUICKLY. AND TO HELP PEOPLE GET
BACK TO WORK I REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN THE
SENATE WE'RE LOOKING FOR
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE FROM ALL SENATORS
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. HARIAN
SCENE NINE MADAM SECRETARY CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN
AYE ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS I TELL.
BRADFORD I CABALLERO I DODD. HI
DURAZOI GALGIANI AYE GLAZER.
GONZALEZ. HI HERTZBERG. I HILL
HI WITH SO HI HER TADO HI
JACKSON. I LEYVA. I MCGUIRE I
MITCHELL. I MONEY FIVE NIELSEN.
FIVE PAN FIVE PORTANTINO AYE
ROTH HI RUBIO HI SKINNER. STERN
NUMBER I PLAY CASKEY I WIENER.
HI LADIES IN GERMAN THE SENATE
WE'RE NOT GONNA WELCOME THOSE
WHO ARE PARTICIPATING REMOTELY
WE'RE GONNA ASK EACH SENATOR
PLEASE PROVIDE THEIR NAME THE
BILL NUMBER THE BILL NUMBER IS
FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN AND A VOTE
MADAM SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. FAITH BATES AB.
FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN ABSTAINED.
FORGES GEORGE IS AB FOURTEEN
FIFTY SEVEN HI FORAGES HI
CHIANG HEY FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN
I CHANG AYE DALLI DALLI AB
FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN HI SALLY
HIGH GROWTH. EIGHTEEN FOURTEEN
FIFTY SEVEN I GROW BY MELENDEZ
MELENDEZ AB FOURTEEN FIFTY
SEVEN I WONDER AS I MORE LOCK.
SUTTER MORLOCK I DO APOLOGIZE
WE'RE GONNA HAVE YOU JUST TAKE
YOUR CELL PHONE FROM YOU YOU'RE
GOOD. THERE WE GO ALMOST. FRED
IS THE FIRST TIME I'VE DONE IT
AGAIN. WORLD AB FOURTEEN. FIFTY
SEVEN HI IT'S GOOD TO SEE
CENTER MORE LOOKING FOR A LOCK
I THANK YOU. MORRELL WELL AB
FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN MORALE OF
ALL TIME. BROWN'S AYE WILK.
WILK AB FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN HI
WILK I WE THEIR LABOR MOVES A
CALL. LAYS IN GERMAN THE SENATE
THIS IS THE LAST ITEM WITH THE
FIVE OF THE FOUR BILLS THAT THE
PRESIDING OFFICER OF THE TAKING
OF TODAY WE WELCOME HER BACK
FILE AND ONE OF TWO MEN OF
SECTOR. CAN YOU PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TO SEVENTY
SIX. BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER AS AN
ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC HEALTH
TAKE IT AWAY SENATE-ROOM. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT. MEMBERS AS A
PROUD PRINCIPLE CO AUTHOR OF AB
TWENTY TWO SEVENTY SIX. I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE WHICH ADDRESSES THE
STATE'S POOR TRACK RECORD. OF
ENSURING THAT CHILDREN MOST AT
RISK OF LEAD POISONING ARE
SCREENED AND TESTED FOR LEAD
POISONING. WE ALL KNOW THAT
THERE IS NO SAFE LEVEL OF LEAD
FOR CHILDREN ALL CHILDREN CAN
BE HARMED BY LEAD BUT CHILDREN
FROM LOWER INCOME FAMILIES. ARE
SPECIALLY AT RISK. 88% OF
CALIFORNIA'S CHILDREN WHO ARE
LEAD POISONED RECEIVE MEDICAL.
EARLIER THIS YEAR A REPORT BY
THE STATE AUDITOR FOUND THAT
MORE THAN ONE POINT FOUR
MILLION CHILDREN. COVERED BY
MEDICAID ALL DID NOT RECEIVE
PROPER LEAD TESTING CONCLUDED.
THAT ONLY 27% OF MEDICAL
CHILDREN. RECEIVE THE TEST
REQUIRED. AB TWO TWO SEVEN SIX
ADDRESSES THE STATE'S POOR
CHILD LEAD TESTING RATES Y
ONE. HOLDING MEDI CAL MANAGED
CARE PLANS ACCOUNTABLE FOR LEAD
TESTING. THE CHILDREN IN THEIR
CARE. TO REQUIRING PLANTS TO
IDENTIFY CHILDREN WHO MISLED
TEST REMIND DOCTORS THAT
CHILDREN MUST BE TESTED. A
REPORT TO THE STATE WHEN
CHILDREN ARE NOT TESTED. THREE
ENACT ADICIONAL RISK FACTORS
FOR HEALTH EXPOSURE. AND FOR
REQUIRE THE DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH. TO UPDATE ITS
CHILDHOOD LEAD POISONING
PREVENTION PROGRAM FUNDING
FORMULA. TO ACCOUNT FOR ALL
LEAD EXPOSED CHILDREN WITHIN
THE COUNTY SURE STICTION. IT IS
TIME THAT WE PRIORITIZE THE
PRIORITIZE AND ENSURE THAT ALL
CHILDREN ON MEDI CAL ARE TESTED
FOR LEAD. AB TWO TWO SEVEN SIX
HOLES MEDICARE MANAGED CARE
PLANS ACCOUNTABLE. FOR TESTING
CHILDREN IN THEIR CARE.
REQUIRES A STATE TO UPDATE ITS
LEAD POISONING PREVENTION
PROGRAM. THIS PROPOSALS
ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT NOW THE
CHILDREN ARE PRIMARILY CONFINED
TO THEIR HOMES. DURING THE
CORONA VIRUS PANDEMIC
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SIR LATER NOW TO BE
TAKING DISCUSSION AND DEBATE ON
THE FLOOR AND REMOTELY
DISCUSSION DEBATE FROM ALL
SENATORS WERE GOING. TO START
WITH AND RUBIO THAT ARE GONNA
GO TO CENTER ROSS CENTER RUBIO
GOOD AFTERNOON. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS OF THE
SAN BOB TODAY I ALSO IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS MEASURE AS A CO
AUTHOR. WHEN THIS BILL WAS
HEARD IN THE SENATE COMMITTEE
AYE I SHARED HOW IMPORTANT THIS
IS TO ME MY DISTRICT OF COURSE
ACROSS CALIFORNIA. AND TO HOW
THE NEGATIVE EFFECTS OF LEAD
POISONING IT'S REALLY IMPACTING
OUR OUR CHILDREN MANY OF MY
CONSTITUENTS IN PARTICULAR ARE
DEALING WITH THIS YEAR'S ISSUE
RIGHT NOW. IT WAS SHOCKING TO
ME WHEN THE STATE AUDITOR'S
REPORT RELEASED IN JANUARY
TWENTY TWENTY FOUND THAT MORE
THAN ONE POINT FOUR MILLION.
ONE YEAR OLD AND TWO YEAR OLD
CHILDREN HAVE NOT RECEIVED THE
STATE REQUIRED BLOOD LEAD TESTS
THAT'S- UNACCEPTABLE THAT
FIGURE PUTS THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF OUR MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATION AT RISK AND I
STRONGLY URGE AND I VOTE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND RUBIO GOOD AFTERNOON
CENTER DRUGS SO WE RECOGNIZE
pCHAIRMAN. AS VICE CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA LATINO CAUCUS. I
RISE IN SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY
TWO SEVENTY SIX. THIS BILL IS A
PRIORITY FOR US BECAUSE LEAD
POISONING. DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECTS MINORITY CHILDREN WERE
MORE LIKELY TO LIVE IN
COMMUNITIES WITH LEAD
CONTAMINATED DUST. IN OLDER
BUILDINGS AND SUB STANDARD
HOUSING. LATINOS ARE ALSO MORE
LIKELY TO HAVE ELEVATED BLOOD
LEAD LEVELS. COMPARED TO NON
HISPANIC WHITES. AND THE
EFFECTS OF LEAD POISONING ARE
YOU REIMBURSABLE. OFTEN LEADING
TO LIFELONG MEDICAL
DISABILITIES AND COMPLICATIONS.
BY ESTABLISHING ACCOUNTABILITY
MECHANISMS NEWS. HELLO
MECHANISMS FOR EARLY CHILDHOOD
MEDIC CAL LEAD TESTING. WE CAN
ENSURE ALL OF OUR CHILDREN ARE
PROTECTED. NOT THE MILLIONS OF
CHILDREN IN MEDIC CAL. MORE NOT
RECEIVING PROPER LEAD TESTS
UNDER CURRENT LAW. ARE PROPERLY
SCREENED TESTED AND TREATED
THANK YOU. THANK YU SENATOR
AZAM MEMBERS WE'RE GONNA SEE IF
THERE'S ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE FROM ALL
SENATORS. HEARING SEEN NINE
CENTER LEYVA WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. MEMBERS WE KNOW THAT
THERE IS NO CURE FOR LEAD
EXPOSURE BUT THE EARLIER WE
FIND IT WE CAN MITIGATE THE
EFFECTS ON CHILDREN THAT'S WHY
THIS BILL IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH SOONER LATER MEADOW SECTOR
CAN YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN I ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS I
TELL. BRADFORD I HAVE A ADAM I
DODD HI THERE AWESOME. I
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER GONZALEZ
FIVE HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE
HUESO. HI HER TADO HI JACKSON.
I LEYVA. AYE MCGUIRE I MITCHELL.
I MONEY FIVE NIELSEN. I PAN. I
PORTANTINO. I ROTH HI RUBIO I
SKINNER STERN NUMBER FIVE BY
CASKEY HI WIENER HI. THANK YOU
MADAM SECRETARY WE'RE NOW GOING
TO MOVE TO OUR MEMBERS WHO ARE
VOTING REMOTELY AND THIS IS AB
TWO ZERO THREE SEVEN MADAM
SECRETARY. EXCUSE ME. ARE YOU
READY. PARDON ME TWENTY TO
SEVENTY SEVEN. TWENTY TWO
SEVENTY SIX I'LL GET IT RIGHT
AT SOME POINT MADAM SECRETARY.
BATES BATES AB TWENTY TWO
SEVENTY SIX I PAID FIVE LARGEST
MATTER BRIDGE THE DOING A GREAT
JOB OR JUST AB TWENTY TWO
SEVENTY SIX AYE FORGES HI.
CHANG CHANG EIGHTY TWENTY TO
SEVENTY SIX I CHIANG HI DALLY.
GALLEY AB TWENTY TWO SEVENTY
SIX HI SALLY HIGH GROWTH. AB
TWENTY TWO SEVENTY SIX I GROW
BY MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ AB TWENTY
TWO SEVENTY SIX I MELENDEZ HI
MORE LOCK. AB TWO TWO SEVEN SIX
HI MORLOCK HIGH MORALE. L. AB
TWENTY TWO SEVENTY SIX HI
MORRELL HI WILK. WILK AB TWENTY
TWO SEVENTY SIX HI WILK I.
SENATOR MUSICAL MEMBERS WE ARE
MOVING TO FILE ITEM FORTY EIGHT
SENATOR WIENER MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY THREE SIXTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MURATSUCHI AN
ACT RELATING TO FIREARMS
SENATOR WIENER THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. I RISE TODAY TO
PRESENT A. B. TWENTY THREE
SIXTY TWO ON BEHALF OF THE
SUMMER MURATSUCHI. AB TWENTY
THREE SIXTY TWO AND FORCES
COMPLIANCE AND ACCOUNTABILITY
FOR FIREARMS TRANSACTIONS BY
AUTHORIZING THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE TO FIND. IRRESPONSIBLE
GUN DEALERS THE BILL WILL
INCENTIVIZE COMPLIANCE WITH
STATE LAW BY ALLOWING DOJ TO
FIND DEALERS FOR VIOLATIONS AS
AN ALTERNATIVE TO THE ALL OR
NOTHING. YOU EITHER DO NOTHING
OR REVOKE THE LICENSE ENTIRELY-
AND MOVING AWAY FROM IT ALL OR
NOTHING CHOICE DOJ HAS
EXPRESSED THE NEED FOR
ADDITIONAL ENFORCEMENT TOOLS-
AND A MIDDLE GROUND SHORT OR
LICENSE REVOCATION. THAT IS IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL-
THE AUTHORITY GRANTED IN THIS
BILL SIMILAR TO THE AB TO ABC'S
ABILITY TO ADMINISTER FINES- IN
LIEU OF REVOKING A LIQUOR
LICENSE. ON AS GUN SALES
INCREASE IT IS IMPORTANT NOW
MORE THAN EVER TO ENSURE THE
CALIFORNIA GUN DEALERS ARE
FOLLOWING OUR GUN LAWS THE
TWENTY THREE SIXTY TWO IS
SPONSORED BY THE BRADY
CAMPAIGN'S AND SUPPORTED BY THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL ASKED FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
WIENER DISCUSSION AND DEBATE
SEEING NO ONE ON THE FLOOR R.
O. MEMBERS PARTICIPATING.
REMOTELY SENATOR GROVE. HE MET
A PRESS I RISE IN OUR- OF BILL
IT'S NOT OUR GANG DEALERS AND
THOSE THAT ARE LICENSED BY THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT ARE
DOING ANYTHING ILLEGAL. IT'S
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE MORE LIKE
CREE. OBTAINING ILLEGALLY THAT
ARE CAUSING IN WREAKING HAVOC
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THINGS THAT
ARE GOING ON IN OUR STATE IN
OUR COMMUNITY. IT'S BEEN
RECOGNIZED SPECIFICALLY FOR THE
PANDEMIC- THE AUTHOR WAS RIGHT
THAT THE- GUN SALES HAVE-INCREASED AGAIN CELLS HAVE
INCREASED TO NEW GUN OWNERS ARE
PRIMARILY BECAUSE- OF THE CHAOS
IN THE STREETS AND THEN WANTING
TO PROTECT THEIR FAMILIES. SO
GUN DEALERS ARE DOING THEIR
VERY BEST TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY FOLLOW THAT THEY ARE DOING
THEIR VERY BEST AND THEY DO
FOLLOW ALL OF THE GUIDELINES-
BUT I THINK WE NEED TO ADDRESS
THE ISSUES INSTEAD OF
PROHIBITING LAW ABIDING
CITIZENS AND LAW ABIDING GUN
OWNERS AND LAW ABIDING RETAIL
SERVICES. TO PROVIDE UM
SERVICES THAT ARE REQUESTED BY
THE CITIZENS OF OUR STATE- WE
SHOULD ADDRESS THE ISSUES ABOUT
ILLEGALLY OBTAINING FIREARMS
WHICH IS TAKING PLACE. ON OUR
ON A REGULAR BASIS AND THAT'S
EVIDENT BECAUSE OF PEOPLE THAT
ARE ARRESTED OR PULLED OVER AND
FOR INSTANCE I COULD NAME
SEVERAL BIG ARRESTED THAT ARE
PULLED OVER. BETTER ILLEGALLY
AND DRIVING WITHOUT A DRIVER'S
LICENSE HAVE AN ILLEGAL FIREARM
IN THEIR POSSESSION NO LICENSED
AUTHORIZED AND DEALER AB SOLD
THAT FIREARMS IT A PARTICULAR
INDIVIDUAL I'M REGARDING THAT A
POLICE SHOOTING THAT HAPPENED A
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO. SO I JUST
I JUST STRESS TO THE FACT THAT-
YOU KNOW ATTACKING LAW ABIDING
BUSINESSES LAW ABIDING GUN
OWNERS LAW ABIDING CITIZENS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND NOT
ADDRESSING CRIMINAL ELEMENT. AS
WHERE IT PEOPLE ARE OBTAINING
ILLEGAL FIREARMS IS ADAMS IS-
JUST NEEDS TO GET DEFINITELY
JUST NEEDS TO BE ADDRESSED SO I
WOULD ROOF I REQUEST AN
OVERCOAT. THANK YOU CENTER
GROVE. SENATOR NIELSEN. NO
THANK YOU SIR. ANY OTHER
FURTHER TO. OR TO. SEEING AND
HEARING SENATE WE KNOW WHICH TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT JUST BE CLEAR THIS
BILL IS NOT ABOUT LAW ABIDING
GUN DEALERS THIS IS ABOUT GUN
DEALERS WHO VIOLATE THE LAW.
AND WHAT IT DOES IT'S FRANKLY
IN THE INTERESTS OF GUN DEALERS
THAT IF YOU VIOLATE THE LAW
PERHAPS IN A NOT EXTREME WAY.
AND THE ATTORNEY GENERAL HAS A
CHOICE THEIR ONLY OPTION IF
THEY WANT TO GO OUT TO YOU IS
TO REVOKE YOUR LICENSE. GIVEN
THE AGV OPPORTUNITY. TO SEEK A
FINE INSTEAD OF REVOKING OUR
LICENSE SEEMS LIKE SOMETHING
THAT GUN DEALERS WOULD BENEFIT
FROM AND AGAIN THIS IS ONLY
WITH RESPECT TO GUN DEALERS
THAT HAVE ACTUALLY VIOLATED THE
LAW. YES FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU SIR WIENER MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN.
ARCHULETA ALLEN I ARCHULETA AYE
ATKINS I TELL. BRADFORD AYE
CABRERO I DODD. I THE RYZEN HI
GALGIANI. FIVE GLAZER GONZAEZ
HI HERTZBERG HI HILL AYE HUESO.
HI HER TADO NO JACKSON I LEYVA
HI MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL AYE
MONNING FIVE NIELSEN. NO HAN I
PORTANTINO BY RUNOFF. RUBIO HI
SKINNER STERN NUMBER RIGHT HI
WHAT CASTING. HI WIENER I
MOVING NOW TO A REMOTE VOTING
MEMBERS THIS IS AB TWO THREE
SIX TWO MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. BATES BATES AB
TWENTY THREE SIXTY TWO NOW
BATES NOW BARGES. OR JUST AB
TWENTY THREE SIXTY TWO NOW FOR
JUST NO CHIANG. THANK AB TWENTY
THREE SIXTY TWO NOW. CHIANG NO
DALLY DOLLY AB TWENTY THREE
SIXTY TWO NO DALLY NO GROWTH.
GROUP AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY TWO
NO GROVE NO MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ
AB TWENTY THREE SIXTY TWO NOW
MELINDA'S NO MORLOCK. AB TWENTY
THREE SIXTY TWO NO MORE LOCK NO
MORALE. SENTARA YOU'RE A MUTE.
HOLD ON WE STILL CAN'T HEAR YOU.
OKAY HOPEFULLY I CAN YOU HEAR
ME NOW WE ARE. I THANK YOU-
MEMBERSHIPS- CENTER TOMORROW AB
TWENTY THREE SIXTY TWO VOTING
NOW. MORALE NO WILK. WILK AB
TWENTY THREE SIXTY TWO NO WILK
NOW SENATOR MUSICAL MEMBERS
MOVING THE FILE ITEM FORTY
NINE. SENATOR WIENER MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL AT TWENTY FOUR OH FIVE BY
ASSMBLYMEMBERBURKE AN ACT
RELATING TO HOUSING CENTER
WIENER I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
RENDON PRESIDENT- COLLEAGUES I
RISE TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY FOUR OH FIVE. ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER BURKE THIS
LEGISLATION ESTABLISHES THE
RIGHT TO HOUSING FOR ALL
INDIVIDUALS THE BILL AS A
FACTOR IN TWENTY TWENTY SIX AB
TWENTY FOUR OH FIVE EMPHASIZES
THAT PERMANENT HOUSING IS THE
ONLY WAY. WE CAN END
HOMELESSNESS AND PROVIDES A
FRAMEWORK OUTLINING THE BEST
PRACTICES FOR COMBAT IN
HOMELESSNESS INCLUDING ONE
PREVENTING INDIVIDUALS FROM
LOSING THEIR HOMES IN THE FIRST
PLACE TO PROVIDING EMERGENCY
ACCOMMODATIONS WITH SUPPORTIVE
SRVICES SHOULD SOMEONE LOSE
OUR HOME. AND THREE
TRANSITIONING INDIVIDUALS TO
pFOSTERING A CULTURE OF DIGNITY
AND RESPECT THROUGHOUT THE
PROCESS TO MINIMIZE TRAUMA AND
DISRUPTION TO DAILY LIFE THE
BILL ALSO SERVICES GREATER
COORDINATION ACROSS STATE
DEPARTMENTS AND AGENCIES TO
STREAMLINE. AND INTEGRATE
POLICIES AND SERVICES THAT
REDUCE HOMELESSNESS AB TWENTY
FOUR OR FIVES PROVISIONS ARE
SUBJECT TO BUDGET APPROPRIATION
AMENDMENTS TAKEN APPROPRIATIONS
AND TO LEAD THE REQUIREMENTS
IMPOSED ON LOCAL JURISDICTION.
NOW REQUIRE STATE ENTITIES TO
ESTABLISH A SET OF UNIVERSAL
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS AMONG
RELEVANT STATE PROGRAMS TO
TRACK HOMELESS OUTCOMES THE
COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC
THREATENS THE HEALTH ND
ECONOMIC WELL BEING OF EVERY
PERSON NOW MORE THAN EVER WE
ARE AWARE. OF HOW MANY PEOPLE
ARE JUST ONE PAYCHECK AWAY FROM
BEING HOMELESS HOWEVER
HOMELESSNESS WAS A PANDEMIC
BEFORE COVER NINETEEN AND IT'S
PAST TIME THAT WE PRIORITIZE
OUR MOST VULNERABLE RESIDENTS.
WE CANNOT FULLY RECOVER FROM
THE COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC AND
SO EVERY PERSON IS HOUSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR WIENER.
MEMBERS DISCUSSION OR DEBATE.
SEEING NONE THE CHAIN. OUR
LOCAL REMEMBER SENATOR GROWTH.
THANK YOU MADAM FOR I DO
APPRECIATE OUR TO ON THIS I
DON'T THINK ANYBODY ON THE
FLOOR- OR OPERATING REMOTELY
AND BELIEVES THAT WE SHOULD NOT
DO WHAT WE CAN TO PROMOTE SAFE
AND HEALTHY HOUSING FOR
EVERYBODY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA HOWEVER. I PROVIDING
FOUR MILLION ROUGHLY FOUR
MILLION HOMES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WHERE- YOU KNOW THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AS WE ARE
NOW WITH ALL OF THE- BERMAN
SAID IT TAKES TO BUILD A
HOUSING. IN IT NOT TO MENTION
TO BE ABLE TO PAY FOR THAT
HOUSING. I DON'T THINK THERE'S
ANY WAY POSSIBLE SO IF THE IF-THE AUTHOR COULD JUST. KIND OF
GO OVER WHAT THE PLAN WOULD BE
FOUR MILLION HOMES WOULD COST
APPROXIMATELY WHAT DOLLAR VALUE
IS THERE A DOLLAR VALUE
APPROPRIATED TO THIS- PIECE OF
VARY VALUE IS APPROPRIATED TO
THAT PIECE OF LEGISLATION TO
PROVIDE FOUR MILLION ALBUMS. IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA- WHERE
IS THAT MONEY GOING TO COME
FROM. CENTER GROVE REQUESTINGA
QUESTION OF THE FLOOR MANAGER.
OR JUST MAKING A STATEMENT I'M
SORRY. I WAS IS AND THEN I
SHOULD HAVE ASED PERMISSION
MADAM PRESIDENT YOU ARE CORRECT
TO ASK THE- QUESTION THE FLOOR
MANAGER SO PERMISSION TO ASK
THE QUESTION A FOR MANAGER. WE
TAKE A QUESTION. YES HE WILL
PLEASE PROCEED SURE I THANK YOU
TO YOU KNOW. THANK YOU THE
SENATOR FROM BAKER SUFFERED A
QUESTION- I WILL NOT DO THIS I
COULD SPEND CENTER FOR TWO
HOURS AND TALK ABOUT ALL THE
THINGS THAT WE NEED TO DO- TO
BUILD THE MILLIONS OF HOMES. AT
ALL INCOME LEVELS THAT WE NEED
IN CALIFORNIA AND IN FACT WE'VE
HAD DEBATES ON THIS FLOOR.
LEGISLATION THAT I'VE AUTHORED
LEGISLATION THE PROTON IS
OFFERING OTHER LEGISLATION
ABOUT THE AGGRESSIVE. MOVES SO
WE NEED TO MAKE. TO BUILD A
HOUSING- THAT WE- NEED IN SOME
OF THAT LEGISLATION HAS BEEN
SUCCESSFUL OTHERS HAVE FALLEN
SO SHORT- OF PASSING AND WE
NEED. TO CREATE THAT HOUSING AT
ALL INCOME LEVELS- MARKET RATE
HOUSING. MODERATE INCOME
HOUSING LOW INCOME HOUSING
HOUSING FOR FORMERLY HOMELESS
PEOPLE- MOST OF THAT HOUSING
DOESN'T NEED TO BE PUBLICLY
SUBSIDIZED AT ALL WE JUST NEED
TO MAKE THE CHANGES. THIS
OWNING AN APPROVAL PROCESS IS
NECESSARY TO ACTUALLY GET. THE
HOUSING- BILL AND YES WE DO
NEED TO RAMP UP WHAT WE SPEND
ON IT THIS BILL DOES NOT
APPROPRIATE FUNDS. BUT THIS
BILL SETS A POLICY FOR THE
STATE. THAT WE ACTUALLY WANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT EVERYONE.
SHOULD HAVE ACCESS TO HOUSING
AND THEN WE HAVE TO THE- IN THE
PEACE. THERE ARE BY THE- AND
THROUGH OUR- AND- THANK YOU
CENTER WIENER CENTER DID THAT
AND YOUR- IT DID MADAM
PRESIDENT AGAIN I WOULD HAVE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO VOTE
I KNOW THAT AGAIN ALL OF US
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT HOUSING
IS FIXED AND TAKING CARE OF
THAT TO APPROVE TO. JUST
RANDOMLY PASS A BILL THAT
BASICALLY SAYS THAT WE'RE GOING
TO PROVIDE ROUGHLY FOUR MILLION
HOMES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WITH NO MECHANISM OF
PAIN FOR THAT AND NO MECHANISM
AS- YOU KNOW AS A PATH FORWARD
JUST IT AS THE AS THE FLOOR
MANAGER JUST SAID THAT YOU KNOW
WILL FILL IN THE BLANKS AS WE
MOVE ON. AND I JUST THINK THAT
THAT'S JUST NOT IT'S NOT
APPROPRIATE AND IT'S NOT
RESPONSIBLE LEGISLATION SO I
WOULD JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
A NO VOTE AND LET'S ADDRESS
THIS HOUSING CRISIS. LIKE WE
SHOULD AND MAKE SURE THAT- ALL
THE DETAILS ARE IN THE
LEGISLATION WE PASS IT SO THAT
WE KNOW WHAT WE'RE GETTING
OURSELVES INTO AND WHAT WE KNOW
THAT WE'RE COMMITTING
CALIFORNIANS AND TAXPAYERS TO
AND THAT WE KNOW WHAT WE'RE
COMMITTEE LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
TO SO AGAIN I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR IN A NOTE. THANK YOU CENTER
GROVE SEEING NO OTHER HANDS
RAISED AND SEEING NO OTHER
MICROPHONES UP IN THE CHAMBER.
SENATOR WIENER WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I WILL SIR. BE SAN. A
LIST OF POLICY IDEAS- TO THE
REPUBLICAN LEADER I LOOK
FORWARD TO- TO HER SUPPORT ON
THOSE IDEAS AND I RESPECTFULLY
ESPERANDO. THANK YOU SENATOR
WIENER MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN FIVE
ARCHULETA I ATKINS I FELL. I
BRADFORD I CABALLERO I DODD. HI
DURAZO I GALGIANI FIVE GLAZER
GONZALEZ FIVE HERTZBERG. HILL I
HUESO. HI HER TADO FIVE JACKSON
I LEYVA FIVE MCGUIRE HI
MITCHELL. I MONEY FIVE NIELSEN.
PAN FIVE PORTANTINO I. ROSS
FIVE RUBIO HI SKINNER STERN
NUMBER FIVE I Y. CASKEY AYE
WIENER. I NIELSEN NOW THANK YOU
MADAM SECRETARY MOVING TO A
REMOTE VOTING MEMBERS THIS IS
AB TWO FOUR ZERO FIVE MADAM
SECRETARY. BATES EIGHT AB TWO
FOUR ZERO FIVE NO. UPDATES NOW
GORGEOUS ORDERS AB TWENTY FOUR
OH FIVE NOW FOR JUST NO CHIANG.
THANK AB TWENTY FOUR OH FIVE I
CHIANG I DALLY. THE ONLY AB
TWENTY FOUR ZERO FIVE NO DALLY
NO. GROWTH AB TWENTY FOUR ZERO
FIVE NO GROWTH NO MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ AB TWO BORDER ZERO
FIVE NOW MELENDEZ KNOWS MORE
LOCK. AB TWO FOUR OH FIVE NO
MORE LOCK NO MORALE. MORRELL AB
ALL ZERO FIVE NO TO SEND A ROLE
THAT WAS TWO FOUR ZERO FIVE CAN
YOU RESTATEMENTS YES AB TWENTY
FOUR ZERO FIVE- WOULD BE ENOUGH
THANK YOU SIR MORALE NO. WILK
WILK AB TWENTY FOUR OH FIVE HI.
WILK HI SENATOR MUSICAL MEMBERS
WE ARE MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM
FIFTY SENATOR WIENER. BEN
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLY. AMANDA PRESIDENT WE
CAN'T DETERMINE WHAT JUST
HAPPENED. HOLD ON HOLD ON ONE
SEC A MADAM LEADER. ALL RIGHT
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO PROCEED
FOR MEMBERS WHO ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY WE JUST
HAD AN OUTBURST FROM THE
GALLERY THE WOMAN HAS BEEN
REMOVED WE'RE GOING TO PROCEED
ON FILE ITEM FIFTY SENATOR
WIENER. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
READ ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY FIVE BY ASSEMBLY MARK
STONE AND ACTUALLY DID YOU
ANNOUNCED SENATOR WIENER THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT
OUR COLLEAGUES I. KALRA RISE TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY
MEMBER STONE- THIS LEGISLATION
WILL PROTECT USED TO
PARTICIPATE IN DIVERSION
PROGRAMS FROM THE NEGATIVE COST
CONSEQUENCES OF AN UNSEALED
RECORDS WHEN A USER COMPLETES A
DIVERSION PROGRAM UNDER
EXISTING LAW. ASIAN THE
DIVERSION SERVICE PROVIDER ARE
BOTH REQUIRED TO SEAL THE
RECORDS BUT THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT IS NOT. THIS MEANS
THAT EVEN FOR YOU DOES
EVERYTHING NECESSARY TO
COMPLETE THEIR DIVERSION
PROGRAM AND IF THEY
SUCCESSFULLY STATE OUT OF THE
JUVENILE COURT SYSTEM WE WILL
NEVER THE LESS SADDLE THEM WITH
AN UNSEALED POLICE RECORD.
WHAT'S MORE FOR YOU TOWARD
DIVERTED BY THE POLICE WHERE
THEY DON'T GO TO COURT AT ALL.
WHO WHO ARE SIMPLY COUNSELED
AND RELEASED BY THE POLICE NO
AUTOMATIC SEALING PROTECTIONS
EXIST EVEN IF THEY HAVE NEVER
TOUCHED. THE PROBATION OR
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM.
THEREFORE WE SEE THE PERVERSE
RESULT THEY USED TO ACTUALLY
AND AVOID SYSTEM INVOLVEMENTS
FOR POLICE TO VERSION ACTUALLY
HAVE FEWER CONFIDENTIALITY
PROTECTIONS. THEN YOU TO
ACTUALLY ENTER THE SYSTEM AND
OF COURSE WHY WOULD WE CREATE
AN INCENTIVE FOR PEOPLE TO
ENTER THE SYSTEM. AS WE
CONTINUE TO DIVERT YOUTH AWAY
FROM THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM. WE NEED TO HOLD UP OUR
END OF THE BARGAIN AND PROTECT
THEM FROM THE NEGATIVE EFFECTS
OF OUR FLAWED SYSTEM IN TERMS
OF THE PUBLIC RELEASE OF THESE
RECORDS. IT IS UNFAIR TO THE
BURKE USED TO KEEP THEM OUT OF
THESYSTEM PROMISE THEM A CLEAN
RECORD AND SURPRISE HIM DOWN
THE ROAD WITH THE POLICE RECORD
THAT COULD PREVENT THEM FROM
ACCESSING EDUCATIONAL
EMPLOYMENT. OR HOUSING
OPPORTUNITIES A RECENT
AMENDMENTS ALLOW A PROSECUTING
ATTORNEY TO ACCESS YOUR RECORDS
IN CERTAIN CASES IN ORDER TO
MEET THEIR BRADY OBLIGATIONS.
TO THE CRIMINAL DEFENSE
ATTORNEY. IT IS A MEMBERS ALSO
PROTECT RECORDS- FROM
DISCLOSURE ONE PROSECUTORS
ACCESS FOR BRADY PURPOSES- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THE YOU
CENTER WIENER MEMBERS DISCUSS
AND THE SEEN AMERICA. ON THE- I
DO SEE HIM REYES GROWTH PLEASE
PROCEED. IF YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR. CENTER
WHERE WE TAKE A QUESTION.
PLEASE PROCEED I'M ON THE
DIVERSION PROGRAMS IF THESE
YOUTH PARTICIPATE IN THIS
DIVERSION PROGRAMS AND WE DO SO
THE RECORDS IS THERE A LIMITED
NUMBER OF TIMES- WITH THIS BILL
I'M DAVID BE ABLE TO EXERCISE
THIS RIGHT IF THIS BILL WAS TO
PASS. WHAT THIS BILL DOES IS IT
MAKES HIS ARREST RECORDS FOR
THE VERSION. ARE CONSISTENT
WITH THE WAY WE TREAT OTHER OUR
RECORDS FOR YOU YOU'RE IN THE
JUVENILE JUSTICE SYSTEM-
THERE'S NOT A LIMIT. WE HAVE
MADE A POLICY DECISION THAT
WHEN USE COMPLETE THEIR
INVOLVEMENT WITH THE SYSTEM
WE'RE GOING TO SEE OLDER
RECORDS SO IT DOESN'T HAUNT
THEM FOR THE REST OF THEIR
LIVES AND WE- WE WANT TO GIVE
YOU THAT OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE A
CLEAN SLATE. AND MOVE ON AND BE
SUCCESSFUL IN LIFE THIS IS A
LOOPHOLE THAT ALLOWS FOR THAT
FEELS A WHOLE BUNCH OF THEIR
RECORDS. BUT FOR WHATEVER
REASON DIDN'T GET AROUND THE
CEILING THEIR ARREST RECORDS.
IF THEY WENT THROUGH A
DIVERSION PROGRAM WHERE THEY
DIDN'T ACTUALLY ANSWER- THE
CRIMINAL SYSTEM- AND SO WE WANT
TO CLOSE THAT LOOPHOLE- AND
WHETHER THEY'RE ARRESTED ONCE
OR MORE THAN ONCE- WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THESE. KIDS CAN
HAVE A CLEAN SLATE. THANK YOU
SENATOR GROW DID YOU WANT TO
ADD ANYTHING. NO MAN THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT UP I SEE SENATOR
BORCHERT'S IS HANSON GORGEOUS.
HMM RESIDENT DIED THREE YOU MAY
POSE A QUESTION TO THE FLOOR
MANAGER. SAID WE DO WE TAKE A
QUESTION YES PLEASE PROCEED. I
GOOD AFTERNOON I. WHAT I'M
HOPING FOR A LITTLE BIT OF
CLARIFICATION SO WE TALK ABOUT
THE AVAILABILITY OF THESE
ARREST RECORDS- IS IT NOT IS IT
LIMITED. ONLY FOR PURPOSES OF
POLICE INVESTIGATIONS OR THESE
PUBLICLY DISCLOSEABLE ARREST
RECORDS. IS ALL OF THEIR ARREST
RECORDS. WHAT I'M WHAT I'M WHAT
I'M WHAT I'M GETTING AT IS THAT
IF THE POLICE DEPARTMENT IS
CONDUCTING AN INVESTIGATION DO
THEY HAVE ACCESS TO THESE
RECORDS THAT WOULD AID THEM IN.
INVESTIGATION WAR IS ARE THESE
ARREST RECORDS- OBTAINABLE BY
THE PUBLIC. SO IS IT LIMITED TO
LAW ENFORCEMENT- OR IS IT
AVAILABLE TO THE PUBLIC. IT
SEALED AREA. SOME ACCESS IT FOR
INVESTIGATIONS LAW NO ONE WOULD
BE ABLE TO ACCESS AND EXCEPT
FOR A DISTRICT ATTORNEY- TO
FULFILL THEIR BRADY OBLIGATIONS
NO NO. CURRENTLY THE WAY THINGS
WORK RIGHT NOW- CURRENTLY- YEAH
IT COULD BECOME PUBLIC- LAW
ENFORCEMENT CAN ACCESS IT AND
IT CAN BECOME PUBLIC. OKAY AND
THEN WE WANT TO SEAL IT JUST
OTHER. JUVENILE RECORDS ARE
SEALED IN ORDER TO GIVE THESE
KIDS A SECOND CHANCE AND A
CLEAN SLATE TO MOVE ON WITH
LIFE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CENTER BORDERS- I SEE SENATOR
NOPE THAT CENTER BORDERS ANYONE
ON THE FLOOR FOR THIS
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE. SEEING
AND HEARING NONE SENATOR WIENER
YOU MAY CLOSE. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
SIR MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS I FELL I BRADFORD HI
CABRERO I DODD. DODD HI THERE
AWESOME. HI GALGIANI. GLAZER
GONZALEZ HI HERTZBERG I HILL
FIVE HUESO. HI HER TADO.
JACKSON I LEYVA I MCGUIRE. I
MITCHELL. FIVE MONNING AYE
NIELSEN NO PAN FIVE PORTANTINO
HI ROTH. I RUBIO. SKINNER STERN
NUMBER I WOULD CASTING I WIENER
HI WE'LL BE ON OUR MEMBERS
VOTING REMOTELY THIS IS FILE. I
ITEM TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE
MEN SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. BATES BATES AB TWENTY
FOUR TWENTY FIVE NO BATES NOW
FOR JUST. ORDERS AB TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY FIVE NO FORGES NO CHIANG.
CHIANG AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE NO TEN NO DALLY. DALY AB
TWENTY FOUR. TWENTY FIVE NO
DALLY NO GROWTH. AB TWENTY FOUR
FOUR HOURS TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE NOW GROVE NO MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ AB TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE NO. MELENDEZ NO MORE LOCK.
THE NEW MORE LUCK YOU'RE ON
MUTE. THANK YOU MR BY ITSELF I
APOLOGIZE A. B. AB TWO FOUR TWO
FIVE NO MORE LOCK NO MORALE.
WELL AB TWO FOUR TWO FIVE NO
MORALE NO WILK. AB TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY FIVE NO WILK NOW I'M
SORRY SENATOR WILL COULD YOU
REPEAT THAT YOU DID NOT SEE
YOUR NAME. WELL I'M SORRY ABOUT
THAT WILK AB. TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY FIVE NO PERFECT. WILK
NOW THANK YOU SENATOR MOVES A
CALL MEMBERS REMOVING THE FILE
ITEM FIFTY ONE US SENATOR BILL
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
SEVEN SIXTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER O'DONNELL AN ACT
RELATING TO PUBLIC WORKS
SENATOR BILL. GOOD AFTERNOON-
MEMBERS AND NON PRESIDENT- I
PRESENT TO AB TWENTY SEVEN
SIXTY FIVE. BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
O'DONNELL THE BILL DEFINES
PUBLIC WORKS TO INCLUDE CHARTER
SCHOOL FACILITIES PROJECTS THAT
RECEIVE FUNDING PUBLIC FUNDS
THROUGH CONDUIT REVENUE BONDS
AND THIS WOULD ENSURE THAT
INDIVIDUALS WHO WORK ON THESE
PROJECTS RECEIVED PREVAILING
WAGE AND ALLOW THEM TO BENEFIT
FROM APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS. A
CONDUIT REVENUE BONDS AS
FINANCING COURTED BY A PUBLIC
AID ENTITY UNDER EXISTING LAW
CHARTER SCHOOLS THAT ARE FUNDED
BY STATE EDUCATION BOARDS ARE
REQUIRED TO COMPLY WITH
PREVAILING WAGE. AND HIGHER
CONSTRUCTION STANDARDS UNDER
THE FIELD OUT. WE MUST ENSURE
THAT THESE THOSE WORKING IN OUR
SCHOOL FACILITIES ARE SKILLED
AND QUALIFIED. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
CENTER BELL MEMBERS DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE. SENIOR MICROPHONES
UP IN THE CHAIN- CHAMBER ENCINO
HANDS UP ON A REMOTE VOTERS
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALLEN. WELL I ARCHULETA I
ATKINS I FELT I BRADFORD AYE
CABALLERO I DON. DURAZO I
GALGIANI I GLAZER GONZALEZ FIVE
HERTZBERG. HI HILL AYE HUESO. I
HER TADO HI JACKSON. I LEYVA
FIVE MCGUIRE I MITCHELL. I
MONEY I NIELSEN NO HAN. I
PORTANTINO HI ROTH I RUBIO HI
SKINNER STERN NUMBER I Y.
CASKEY I WIENER I THINK YOU
MOVING TO A REMOTE VOTING
MEMBERS MEMBERS THIS IS AB
TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY FIVE MEN
SECRETARY. SIX BATES AB. TWENTY
SEVEN SIXTY FIVE NO BATES NOW
FORGES WE'RE JUST AB TWENTY
SEVEN SIXTY FIVE NO. BARGES NO
CHIANG CHIANG AB TWENTY SEVEN
SIXTY FIVE I'D- CHIANG I DALLY.
DALY AB TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY FIVE
NO DALLY NO. GROWTH AB TWENTY
SEVEN SIXTY FIVE NOW GROVE NO
MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ AB TWENTY
SEVEN SIXTY FIVE NOW MELENDEZ
NO MORE LOCK. AB TWENTY SEVEN
SIXTY FIVE NO MORE LOCK NO
MORALE. AB TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY
FIVE NO MORALE NO WELLS. WILK
AB TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY FIVE HI
WILK HI. SENATOR MOVES A CALL
MEMBERS MOVING ON THE FILE ITEM
FIFTY TWO SENATOR BRADFORD. BEN
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY NINE NINETY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER WEBER AND I
ACTUALLY NEED TO IMPLEMENT
CENTER BRADFORD. ALL RIGHT WE
NEED A CENTER BRADFORD
MICROPHONE PLEASE. TRY AGAIN
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AB
TWENTY NINE NINETY TWO BY.
SERVICE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WHATEVER'S. THIS BILL TO SIMPLY
EXPAND PROTECTED LEAVE THE
VICTIMS OF ANY VIOLENT CRIME
AND ALSO TO THE IMMEDIATE
FAMILY MEMBERS OF A HOMICIDE
VICTIM AB NINETY TWO TWENTY
NINE NINETY TWO DOES NOT MAKE
ANY CHANGES TO THE AMOUNT OF
LEAVE CURRENTLY THAT IS
ALLOWABLE. IT ONLY EXPAND SEIZE
PROTECTIONS TO ADDITIONAL
VICTIMS OF VIOLENT CRIME THIS
BILL WILL CREATE A SAFE HAVEN
FOR SURVIVORS WHO NEED TIME TO
RECOVER AND TO GET TO SAFETY
FOLLOWING A DRAMATIC CRIME WITH
OUT THE REST OF LIEU OF LOSING
THEIR JOB AND I SIMPLY ASK FOR
A VOTE. THANK YOU CENTER
BRADFORD MEMBERS ON THE FLOOR I
SEE NO MICROPHONES REYES
MEMBERS VOTING REMOTELY I SEE
NO HANDS RAISED. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN. FIVE ARCHULETA HI ATKINS
I TELL. FIVE BRADFORD I CAN BY
ADAM I DODD I THE RAZA. I
GALGIANI AYE GLAZER GONZALEZ I
HERTZBERG I HILL I WITH SOME.
HI HER TADO I JACKSON. I LEYVA
I MCGUIRE. I MITCHELL. I MONEY.
I NIELSEN I CAN I PORTANTINO. I
ROTH. HI RUBIO I SKINNER STERN
NUMBER I Y. CASKEY I WIENER I.
MOVING ON TO OUR MEMBERS OF
VOTING REMOTELY THIS IS AB TWO
NINE NINE TWO M. SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. BATES.
YEAH CENTER BATES YOU'RE ON
MUTE. BATES AB TWO NINE NINE
TWO NO. BATES NOW GORGEOUS
WE'RE JUST AB TWO NINE NINE TWO
ABSTAINED. CHIANG THANK AB TWO
NINE NINE TWO BY CHIANG I.
ALLEY DALY AB TWO NINE NINE TWO
BY. DALLY I GROWTH. AB TWO NINE
NINE TWO I. ROVE I. MORE
MELENDEZ AB TWO NINE NINE TWO
NOW MELENDEZ NO MORE LOCK. AB
TWO NINE NINE TWO NINE MORLOCK
HIGH MORALE. AB TWO NINE NINE
TWO NOW MORALE NO WILK. WILK A
TWENTY NINE NINETY TWO HI WILK
AYE SENATOR MUSICAL MEMBERS
MOVING TO FILE ITEM FIFTY FIVE
SENATOR MITCHELL MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO THIRTY ONE TWENTY ONE
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER WEBER AND
ACTUALLY THE STATE GOVERNMENT
SENATOR MITCHELL THANK YOU SO
MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES
AB THIRTY ONE TWENTY ONE WITH
ESTABLISH A TASK FORCE TO THE
STATE TO STUDY. AND DEVELOP
REPARATION PROPOSALS FOR
AFRICAN AMERICANS THIS BILL
WOULD REQUIRE THE TASK FORCE TO
RECOMMEND THE APPROPRIATE
MECHANISMS FOR REDRESS AS IT
PERTAINS SPECIFICALLY TO
CALIFORNIA'S ROLE IN THE
ENSLAVEMENT OF BLACK PEOPLE AND
THE LEGACY OF THE SINCE LATE
MEANT. BETWEEN CALIFORNIA'S
STATEHOOD IN EIGHTEEN FIFTY IN
THE END OF SLAVERY NINETEEN
SIXTY FIVE CALIFORNIA WAS
CONSIDERED A FREE STATE IN NAME
ONLY. WITH MUNICIPAL AND STATE
AUTHORITIES ACTIVELY SUPPORTING
BLACK AND SLATE MEANT IN A
VARIETY OF WAYS. FOR EXAMPLE
THIS CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE
AUTHORIZED SEVEN SLAVEHOLDERS
TO HOLD PERSONS IN BONDAGE SO
LONG AS THEY GET INTO THE STATE
WITH THEIR IN FLIGHT PROPERTY
PRIOR TO STATEHOOD IN EIGHTEEN
FIFTY. CALIFORNIA'S JUDICIAL
BRANCH ALSO HELPED PROP UP THE
SYSTEM OF SLAVERY IN EIGHTEEN
FIFTY TWO CALIFORNIA ADOPTED A
HARSH FUGITIVE SLAVE ACT.
EMPOWERING STATE AND LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT. TO FORCE ITSELF
EMANCIPATED PERSONS LIVING
WITHIN THE STATE BACK INTO
CHAINS OF ENSLAVEMENT. THE
CALIFORNIA SUPREME COURT
ORDERED FUGITIVE SLAVES AS IN
THE HISTORIC CASE OF ARCHIE LEE
RETURNED TO THEIR IN FLAVORS IN
DIRECT VIOLATION OF
CALIFORNIA'S CONSTITUTION. MY
OWN HOME MY OWN HOMETOWN OF LOS
ANGELES IN THE ACTUAL DISTRICT
I CURRENTLY REPRESENT DOWNTOWN
LA HAS A SIMILAR ISSUE WITH THE
WOMAN BY THE NAME OF BETTY
MASON WHO ACTUALLY HAD TO ARGUE
HER OWN CASE IN COURT. TO
PREVENT HER IN FLAVOR FROM
RETURNING HER TO THE STATE OF
MISSISSIPPI. WELL THIS HISTORY
IS NOT PART OF STATE. LOWER OR
SCHOOL CURRICULA IT DOES OFFER
CONCRETE EXAMPLES OF
CALIFORNIA'S COMPLICITY IN
RACIAL DISCRIMINATION IN FACT
THE DISCRIMINATORY PRACTICES OF
THE PAST ECHO IN THE EVERYDAY
LIVES OF BLACK CALIFORNIANS
TODAY. ACCORDING TO GOVERNOR
NEWSOME'S TWENTY TWENTY STATE
OF THE STATE ADDRESS BLACK
PEOPLE MAKE UP 80% OF
CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION.
HOWEVER 43% OF THE HOMELESS
POPULATION IN CALIFORNIA ARE
BLACK. AND THE PERCENTAGE IS
MUCH HIGHER IN OTHER IN SOME OF
OUR LARGER COUNTIES INCLUDING
LOS ANGELES. ACCORDING TO A
TWENTY EIGHTEEN REPORT BY THE
PUBLIC POLICY INSTITUTE OF
CALIFORNIA. AFRICAN AMERICAN
MALES ACCOUNT FOR TWENTY EIGHT
POINT 5% OF THE STATE'S FEMALE
PRISON POPULATION DESPITE THE
FACT THAT BLACK MEN MAKE UP
JUST FIVE POINT 6% OF THE STATE
ADULT MALES. A RECENT STUDY
CONDUCTED BY THE L. A. L.
STATES THAT BY NEARLY EVERY
STATE MEASURE BLACK K. THROUGH
TWELVE STUDENTS HAVE THE LOWEST
PERFORMANCE OF ANY RACIAL
ETHNIC GROUPS. EVEN AS WE
DEBATE THE NEED FOR THIS STUDY
COVERT NINETEEN ISSUED A
SOBERING LIGHT ON THE
CULMINATION OF THESE PERSISTENT
DISPARITIES. EMERGING DATA
CONFIRMS THAT A
DISPROPORTIONATE BURDEN OF
ILLNESS AND DEATH GET A CALL
THAT NINETEEN FALL ON THE BLACK
COMMUNITY. SO LET'S BE CLEAR.
CHATTEL SLAVERY BOTH IN
CALIFORNIA AND ACROSS OUR
NATION BIRTH A LEGACY OF RACIAL
HARMONY AND INEQUITY THAT
CONTINUES TO IMPACT THE
CONDITIONS OF BLACK LIFE IN
CALIFORNIA. PEOPLE WHO SUFFER
INJURIES THE LOSSES TO THE
MALICIOUS OR CALL PROBABLY
NEGLECT CONDUCT THE BROTHERS
HAVE A RIGHT TO REDRESS. AB
THIRTY ONE TWENTY ONE COULD
WOULD REQUIRE AN IN DEPTH
EXAMINATION OF THE IMPACT OF
SLAVERY IN CALIFORNIA AND
PROVIDE THE FRAMEWORK TO
DEVELOP GUIDELINES ON HOW TO
BEGIN TO ADDRESS THE
DISPARITIES BORN OF A SHAMEFUL
HISTORY. I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR
MITCHELL MEMBERS HERE ON THE
FLOOR DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
SENATOR MINING. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I STAND IN SUPPORT I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT AS A BODY
THAT WE UNDERSTAND THIS
CALIFORNIANS THIS INITIATIVE IN
PROPOSAL FOR NO MORE THAN A
STEADY AND THE CONVERSATION IS
LONG OVERDUE. AND STANDS TO
BENEFIT ALL CALIFORNIANS NOT
JUST THOSE THE VICTIMS OF A
HISTORY OF SLAVERY WE'RE ALL
VICTIMS OF THAT HISTORY I HEARD
TONIGHT VOTE. THANK YOU
CEREMONY MOVING TO OUR MEMBERS
WHO ARE VOTING REMOTELY I SEE
SENATOR BORCHERS HIS HAND UP
SENATOR BORDERS. THANK YOU.
EVERY ONCE IN A WHILE WE COME
ACROSS PIECE LEGISLATION THAT
CAPTURES THE IMAGINATION AND
THIS HAS CERTAINLY CAPTURED MY
ATTENTION AND MY IMAGINATION.
MOSTLY ON A PERSONAL LEVEL-
MAYBE YOU KNOW THAT I'VE BEEN
INVOLVED IN GREEK AND ARMENIAN
RELATED ISSUES. AND FOR YEARS I
HAVE ADVOCATED THAT GREEKS AND
ARMENIANS WERE VICTIMIZED BY
THE OTTOMANS THE AUTUMN IN
TURKS BE GIVEN PROPER VENUE FOR
REPARATIONS. BEING AN ISSUE
ORIGINALLY FROM ARIZONA- WE HAD
LENGTHY CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
WHAT THE NATIVE AMERICANS WENT
THROUGH AND THEIR TRIBAL
SOVEREIGNTY RELATED ISSUES. AND
I'VE ALWAYS WANTED TO CHAMPION
THOSE CAUSES IN THIS RESPECT
AND SO NATURALLY WHEN THIS.
ISSUE CAME UP IT CAPTURED MY
IMAGINATION BECAUSE I WANT.
SUCH A TASK FORCE IF IT'S
CREATED AND IT WILL BE I
SUSPECT. THAT IT BE ON THE
MERITS AND IT BEING ELEVATED TO
A LEVEL WHERE EXPERTS IN THOSE
INDIVIDUALS PROPERLY BACKGROUND.
CAN LEAD THE CHARGE ON THIS AND
SO I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
HAVE A REALLY LONG CONVERSATION
WITH THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN WHO IS
ALTERING THIS BILL AND THEN
WHEN IT CAME TO JUDICIARY I PUT
FORWARD SOME WHAT I BELIEVE ARE
POSITIVE RECOMMENDATIONS- ONE
THAT THE INDIVIDUALS APPOINTED.
BEING PROPERLY CREDENTIALED AND
REPARATIONS RELATED TOPICS
WHETHER THEY HAD EXPERIENCE
WITH THIS YOU KNOW SOUTH
AFRICAN APARTHEID OR HOLOCAUST
FOR JAPANESE INTERNMENT
SOMETHING WITHIN THAT BODY OF
SCHOLARSHIP- WAR CHU MIN RIGHTS
AMERICAN HISTORY ONE GETTING
OUT WITH ALL OF THIS IS THAT I
WAS CONCERNED THAT HAVING SO
MANY LEGISLATIVE APPOINTEES IN
THE ORIGINAL DRAFT. WOULD DRAG.
DOWN HIS TASK FORCE AND I WAS
HOPING THAT WOULD BE ELEVATED.
TO AN EXPERT LEVEL OF REVIEW BY
THOSE WHO HAVE A STRONG
BACKGROUND IN TEAM RELATED
TOPICS- I HAD WANTED ALSO TO
PROPERLY REPRESENT THE
BREAKDOWN OF CALIFORNIA. AND
EVEN THOUGH THE VAST MAJORITY
OF FOLKS IN THE LEGISLATURE AND
ACROSS STATE AFFILIATE WITH THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY I THOUGHT IT
COULD BE HELPFUL IF IT LEADS
ONE APPOINTING COULD BE FROM
THE MINORITY LEADERSHIP IN THE
ASSEMBLY AND THE SENATE. SO I
PROPOSE THESE RECOMMENDATIONS
AND ASSEMBLY WOMAN WEBER- WAS
GRACIOUS ENOUGH TO WALK THROUGH
THEM. MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT
THE GOVERNOR STEPPED IN AND HAS
SUBSTANTIALLY MODIFIED IT AND
TAKEN A FEW RECOMMENDATIONS
THAT I THINK ARE ARE HELPFUL-
HE HAS TAKEN MORE OF THE
APPOINTEES THAT WERE INITIALLY
A LOT OF. REDUCE THE APPOINTEES
FROM THE SENATE AND ASSEMBLY
AGAIN LEADERSHIP. AND IT'S PUT
A SPECIAL EMPHASIS ON OF THOSE
HAVING THE ACADEMIC AND
PROFESSIONAL BACKGROUND TO
ELEVATE. THIS DISCUSSION. I'M A
LITTLE CONCERNED STILL THAT
THERE IS NOW OPPORTUNITY FOR-
REPUBLICANS TO PARTICIPATE EVEN
IN AN EMERGENCY REPUBLICANS ARE
JUST FOLKS THAT ARE APPOINTED
FROM THE REPUBLICAN- LEADERSHIP
IN THE ASSEMBLY AND THE SENATE.
SO I'M I HAVE SOME HEARTBURN
HERE I WANT TO SUPPORT THIS BUT
I THINK THAT THERE ARE SOME
SHORTCOMINGS IN THE COMPOSITION
OF THIS OF THIS- TASK FORCE.
AND GIVEN MY PAST EXPERIENCE
WITH YOU KNOW WHAT. BEING
ADVOCATE FOR OTHER FOLKS I WAS
HOPING THAT THIS WOULD TO BE
SLIGHTLY DIFFERENT BUT I DIDN'T
KNOW IF ANY OF MY OTHER
COLLEAGUES HAD. FELL THAT THESE
CHANGES MADE BY THE GOVERNOR
AND AGREED TO BY THE AUTHOR-
GOOD EVERYONE IS HAPPY WITH THE
NEW COMPOSITION- BECAUSE I
THINK IT STILL HAS SOME
FUNDAMENTAL SHORTCOMINGS EVEN
THOUGH I WANT SOMETHING LIKE
THIS TO SUCCEED. AND NONE OF
THIS OF COURSE IS. OUR BINDING
US TO WHATEVER THE OUTCOME OF
THE TASK FORCE RECOMMENDATIONS
ARE THAT WOULD HAVE TO GO
THROUGH THE LEGISLATURE L. AS
WE KNOW IT SO WE'RE NOT VOTING
FOR REPARATIONS WERE VOTING FOR
THE STUDY OF REPARATIONS BUT- I
DO KNOW THAT IN MY COLLEAGUES
HAD CONCERNS ABOUT THE
COMPOSITION BECAUSE I THINK. IF
YOU WANT TO DO IT RIGHT AND YOU
WANTED MAKE THIS. A TRUE PEACE
A TRUE A TRUE LEGACY WITH
CALIFORNIA LEADING THE WAY
ACROSS THE UNITED STATES I
BELIEVE THAT THERE NEEDS TO BE
CERTAIN BOXES CHECKED. AND DID
THE CURRENT COMPOSITION FALLS
JUST SLIGHTLY BELOW THAT IN MY
IN MY HUMBLE OPINION. THANK YOU
CENTER BORDERS. SEEING NO
FURTHER HANDS UP I DO SEE
ANOTHER HAND UP THE SENATOR
JONES. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT IT'S A PLEASURE TO
JOIN YOU TODAY 'M ALTHOUGH I'M
NOT VOTING TODAY ON THE-
MEASURES I DID WANT TO MAKE
JUST A QUICK COMMENT ON THIS
ONE. AND SHARES SOME I THINK
YOU NEED SENATE HISTORY. WITH
ALL OF US AFTER I GOT ELECTED
TO THE SENATE I KEPT WONDERING.
WHAT IS THAT BUST OVER ON THE
RIGHT SIDE OF THE CHAMBERS. AND
SO BEING PRESERVED I AM I DID
SOME RESEARCH AND THAT'S DAVID
BRODERICK ONE OF CALIFORNIA'S
FIRST US SENATORS. AND THE
REASON WE HAVE HIS BUSTS HERE-
AND IN KNOWLEDGE IN HIS HISTORY
IS HE WAS A AN ANTI SLAVERY
DEMOCRATS WHEN HE WAS IN A
POLITICAL OFFICE I HERE IN
CALIFORNIA AND THEN WHEN HE
SERVED AS THE U. S. SENATOR IN
WASHINGTON DC HE WAS VERY
PASSIONATE. THATCALIFORNIA
WOULD NOT BE A SLAVE STATE AND
IT COST HIM HIS LIFE HE GOT
INTO A DAHLE WEATHER AND
ANOTHER. DEMOCRAT COLLEAGUE
FRIEND OF HIS AT FROM A
CONVENTION THEY GOT INTO A
DISAGREEMENT- ONE CHALLENGED
OTHER TWO ADULT THEY HAD TO
ACTUALLY LEAVE THE CITY LIMITS
BECAUSE AT THE TIME BILLS ARE
ILLEGAL IN THE- CITY OF
SACRAMENTO BUT LEGAL IN THE
COUNTY OF SACRAMENTO.
UNFORTUNATELY ON THE DAY OF THE
DUAL- DAVID- WAS THE LOSER OF
THAT COMPETITION BUT I
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN THE WINNER
OF HIS PASSION AND- THE HISTORY
THAT HE HELPED. CALIFORNIA
START WITH AND THE HISTORY THAT
I THINK ALL CALIFORNIANS ARE
TRYING TO LIVE UP TO. AND SO-
WELL I CAN'T TAKE A POSITION ON
THE BILL TODAY I JUST WANT TO
SHOW THAT LITTLE BIT OF HISTORY
WITH US AND SO THAT WE WOULD
HAVE A POSITIVE. A RECOLLECTION
OF SOME OF THE CALIFORNIA
HISTORY WHEN IT CAME TO DEALING
WITH SLAVERY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MA'AM PRESIDENT THANK. YOU
SENATOR JONES SENATOR BRADFORD.
THANK MA'AM PRESS ARRIVE IN
STRONG. OF THIS AND I WISH SHE
WAS STRONGER I WISH WAS IN THE
STUDY I WISH IT WAS TIME FOR.
NOT ONLY CALIFORNIA BUT AMERICA
TO PAY ITS DEBT TO THE AFRICAN
AMERICAN. PEOPLE OF THIS
NATION. ARE JUST FIFTY SEVEN
YEARS AGO YESTERDAY. DR KING SO
ELOQUENTLY STATED. BAKER WROTE
A PROMISSORY NOTE. TO THE
AFRICAN AMERICANS AT THE END OF
SLAVERY. A NOTE THAT HIS
COMEBACK INSUFFICIENT FUNDS WE
WERE TALKING ABOUT FARMING
EARLIER IF. AFTER AMERICANS
STILL HIT THE LAND THAT THEY
HEAR AFTER SLAVERY WE WILL ALL
BE BILLIONAIRES IF THE FORTY
ACRES AND A MULE THAT WAS
PROMISED TO FREE SLAVES WERE
DELIVERED TO THE DESCENDANTS OF
THOSE FLAVORS TODAY WE WILL ALL
BE BILLIONAIRES BUT IT HASN'T
HAPPENED. THE OLD DAD AND I
HERE FOR TOO MANY PEOPLE SAY
WELL I DIDN'T OWN SLAVES THAT
WAS SO LONG AGO WELL YOU CAN
INHERIT WEALTH YOU CAN IN HERE
TODAY BUT YOU'LL HAVE BEEN
AMERICAN SO I HOPE THIS GOALS
FOR THIS STUDY SHOULD BE ABOUT
PARTISANSHIP IT SHOULD BE A
BALL WRITES. RESPECT IN
OBLIGATION DIRECTORY OF THE SKY.
AND UNDERSTAND THAT THIS
COUNTRY STANDS TODAY. BECAUSE
OF THE SPREE SLAVE LABOR ATKINS
WHO WERE BROUGHT HERE AGAINST
THEIR WILL AND WE'RE THE GREAT
COUNTRY WE ARE TODAY BECAUSE OF
THAT SLAVE LABOR AND I THINK
IT'S FAR PAST TIME FOR AMERICA
TO PAY THAT DEBT GOOD AFTERNOON
MARK PEOPLE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL. THANK YOU SENATOR
BRADFORD SENIOR FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SENATE
MITCHELL PLEASE CLOSE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MADAM PRESIDENT I
THANK YOU ALL FOR. YOUR DEBATE
AND INTEREST IN THIS TOPIC I
WOULD JUST SAY. A COUPLE
THINGS- HAVING SERVED FROM. THE
A GOOD AMOUNT OF TIME AS A
SITTING MEMBER OF THE SENATE
RULES COMMITTEE. I WE HAVE NOT
BEEN ABLE TO IDENTIFY ANY
OTHER- COMMISSION OR BOARD
THAT- REQUIRES THE MINORITY
PARTY TO HAVE A ROLE IN AS AN
APPOINTED AUTHORITY- SO THIS
WOULD BE UNIQUE THAT DOESN'T
EXIST FOR IN ANY OTHER
COMMISSIONER BOARD. SECONDLY I
THINK IF YOU REVIEW THE
APPOINTMENTS MADE BY THIS
ADMINISTRATION THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION- ITS IT'S VERY.
YOU KNOW WE SHOULD NOT ASSUME
THAT ARE SITTING GOVERNOR OR
SITTING PROTEIN OR SPEAKER- ARE
NOT BROAD AND OPEN IN THEIR
APPOINTMENTS AND SOME
REPUBLICANS HAVE TO BEEN
APPOINTED. BUT AGAIN THERE IS
NO EXAMPLE I COULD FIND WHERE
THE MINORITY PARTY HAS
APPOINTING AUTHORITY AND SO ON
WE DID NOT BELIEVE IT WAS
NECESSARY OR APPROPRIATE FOR
THIS BILL- FOR ALL THE REASONS
REFERENCED PREVIOUSLY I ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. A. B. THIRTY ONE
TWENTY ONE. THANK YOU SENATOR
JACKSON MEMBERS BEFORE WE START
TAKING CALLS JUST REMINDER FOR
EVERYONE TO COME TO THE FLOOR
WE ARE GOING TO LIFT CALLS ON
PREVIOUS BILLS AFTER WE VOTE ON
THIS BILL. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ON AB.
THIRTY ONE TWENTY ONE. ALLEN
ARCHULETA I ATKINS I FELL. FIVE
BRADFORD I HAVE ITEM I DODD.
FIVE TO RAZA. HI GALGIANI AYE
GLAZER AYE GONZALEZ HI
HERTZBERG HI HILL AYE HUESO. HI
HER TADO HI JACKSON I LEYVA AYE
MCGUIRE. I MITCHELL I MONNING
I NIELSEN. NO HAN FIVE
PORTANTINO. FIVE ROTH FIVE
RUBIO I SKINNER. STERN NUMBER
HI WHITE HOUSE SKI HI WIENER.
FIVE WE TO THE MEMBERS WERE
VOTING REMOTELY MEMBERS THIS IS
AB THIRTY ONE TWENTY ONE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
BATES BATES AB THIRTY ONE
TWENTY ONE I'D BE FINE.
GORGEOUS FORGES AB THIRTY ONE
TWENTY ONE HI. HOLD ON ONE
SECOND CENTER BORDERS I
APOLOGIZE WE DID NOT HAVE YOU
ON THE SCREEN THAT WAS NOT YOUR
FAULT YOU'RE HERE NOW GO AHEAD
AND REPEAT THAT PLEASE. FORTUS
AB THIRTY ONE TWENTY ONE. HI
THANK YOU SIR. CARRIAGES HI
CHIANG. CHIANG AB THIRTY ONE
TWENTY ONE I CHIANG MAI DALLY.
DOLLY AB THIRTY ONE TWENTY ONE
HI DALY HI GROWS. AB TWENTY ONE
THIRTY ONE EXANE MADAM- THERE
WE GO CAN YOU REPEAT THAT
CENTER GROVE YOU'RE NOW ON
SCREEN. YES MA'AM A GRILLED AB
TWENTY ONE THIRTY ONE STATE
THANK YOU. MELINDA. MELENDEZ AB
THIRTY ONE TWENTY ONE NOW.
MELENDEZ NO. MORLOCK AB THIRTY
ONE TWENTY ONE SPEAKING.
TOMORROW. SANTA MARIA YOU'RE A
MUTE. THERE YOU GO YOU'RE THERE
HE DID HIT IT I APOLOGIZE. A.
B. THIRTY ONE TWENTY ONE.
GENERAL I'M SORRY WASN'T YOU IT
WAS US CAN YOU JUST REPEAT
THAT. YES I CAN- MORALE AB
THIRTY ONE TWENTY ONE NOW THANK
YOU SIR WE'RE L. NO. WILK WILK
AB THIRTY ONE TWENTY ONE HI.
WILK HI THE- SERVICE WE ARE
COMING BACK TO YOU. YES. SENATE
DEBATE DID NOT YOU DID BUT WE
THINK YOU HAVE THE WRONG BILL
NUMBER IT WAS AB THIRTY ONE
TWENTY ONE IF YOU COULD JUST
SAY THAT AGAIN AND YOUR VOTE
THAT WOULD BE GREAT WELL AB
THIRTY ONE TWENTY ONE. BY IT
DIDN'T SAY SENATOR BATES PLEASE
SENATE RATES THANK YOU MA'AM
BATES HI.
SENATOR MOVES THE
CALL MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO
START RAISING AIR LIFTING THE-
CALLS LIAM BILLS THAT ARE ON
CALL SO BEAR WITH US FOR A
MOMENT WHILE WE PUT THAT LIST
TOGETHER. WELL WE'RE REPAIRING
THE LIST I WANT TO JUST GIVE A
LITTLE REMINDER TO OUR MEMBERS
WHO ARE VOTING REMOTELY. IF YOU
WANT TO CHANGE YOUR VOTE. JUST
DO THE RAISE YOUR HAND FUNCTION
AT ALL CALL ON YOU AGAIN THANK
YOU
. FOR YOU'RE PREPARED TO
LIFT THE CALL ON BILLS WE'RE
GOING TO START WITH FILE ITEM
TEN. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN
I CABALLERO. I GLAZER FIVE
HUESO. HI NIELSEN. NIELSEN NO
INNER I STERN. SEEING NO HANDS
FROM OUR REMOTE VOTING MEMBERS
HIS TWENTY EIGHT KNOWS EIGHT
THE APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED
MOVING TO FILE ITEM. ELEVEN
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
THIS IS ONE WE NEED MORRELL. I
GLAZER I HER TADO. I NIELSEN.
NIELSEN I ISN'T. RUBIO I
SKINNER. HI STERN. NIELSEN I
DON'T KNOW. SOON MORE LIKE I'M
JUST GONNA CHECK IN WITH YOU I
HAD YOUR HAND UP AND IS NO
LONGER OF I JUST WANNA MAKE
SURE THAT YOU DIDN'T WANT TO.
SPEAK I APOLOGIZE MATTER
PRESIDENT I THOUGHT WE WERE
GOING TO ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN NOT
TO ITEM NUMBER EIGHTY TWO. WE
WERE ON ELEVEN SIR. ALL ON MY
SCREEN I HAD THE RIGHT I MEAN
TO. ME TO. OKAY ONE MOMENT OF.
HOLD ON ONE SENATOR SENATOR
MARK.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE MEMBERS WE ARE GETTING
TO THE BOTTOM OF THIS WILL BE
RIGHT WITH YOU.
YEAH ALL. RIGHT
MEMBERS WE'RE READY TO GET
STARTED AGAIN IF I CAN HAVE ALL
MEMBERS IN THEIR SEATS PLEASE
WE STILL WANT TO PRACTICE A
PHYSICAL DISTANCING EVEN THOUGH
WE'RE WEARING OUR MASKS. BUT
MEMBERS WE HAD A LITTLE
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTY THERE SO
WE'RE GOING TO START. OVER ON
FILE ITEM ELEVEN MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ON FILE ITEM
ELEVEN. PUBLISHED BY ADAM. I
GLAZER. FIVE NIELSEN I SKINNER.
I STERN. SENATOR MORE LONGTIME
GONNA COME TO YOU. FOR YOUR
VOTE. PRESIDENT THANK YOU FOR
THAT EXTENDING THE COURTESY
JUST TO ASK ME WHY I TOOK MY
HANDS DOWN- THAT WAS REALLY
REALLY A SMART MOVE BUT I
APPRECIATE IT NO PROBLEM HI.
THIS IS SENATOR MORAL OUT FOR
MEREDITH WILLIAMS DIRECTOR
DEPARTMENT OF TOXIC SUBSTANCES
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN HI. THANK
YOU SIR. THANK YOU. MORLOCK.
FIVE FIVE THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO
THE APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM TWELVE
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. GLAZER I.
SKINNER FIVE KERN. FIVE THIRTY
KNOWS TO THE APPOINTMENT IS
CONFIRMED MOVING ON TO THE NEXT
YEAR YES CENTER MORLOCK. YOUR
YOUR I VOTED THAT'S WHY I
THOUGHT I WOULD NEVER MIND HI
I'M I'M I'M GOOD I APOLOGIZE.
NO PROBLEM HI PAUL. SENATOR
MORE LIKE JUST SO YOU KNOW ON
FILE ITEM TWELVE YOU DID NOT
CAST A VOTE IS THAT HOW YOU
WANTED THIS TO END UP YES IT IS
MATTER PRESIDENT CHEN FORGIVE
ME FOR JUST THE CONFUSION MY ON
MY AND I APOLOGIZE NO PROBLEM
WHATSOEVER ALL EYES ABOUT THE
ARTICLE THAT WE'RE GOOD OKAY
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM THIRTY
TWO. AB. TWENTY SEVENTY SEVEN
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
WELL. I GLAZER. I SKINNER. I
STERN. NIELSEN I DIDN'T KNOW
SEEING NO HANDS REYES FOR
REMOTE VOTING MEMBERS FIVE
TWENTY SEVEN KNOWS TEN THE
MAJOR KERRY'S MOVING TO FILE
ITEM THIRTY FOUR AB TWENTY FOUR
TWENTY ONE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL EXCUSE ME
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN. I
BELL I REISER. GLAZER. I
MCGUIRE. SKINNER I STERN. I WAS
THIRTY FOUR KNOWS ONE THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING TO FILE
ITEM THIRTY FIVE AB TWENTY
NINETY TWO PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. BELL I GLAZER I
MCGUIRE I SKINNER. I STERN.
NIELSEN I TO KNOW SENATOR
PORGES. THANK YOU FOR JUST
EIGHTY TWO ZERO NINE TWO NO.
THANK OR FOR JUST NOW. HIGHS
THIRTY KNOWS EIGHT THE MEASURE
PASSES MOVING TO FILE ITEM
THIRTY SEVEN AB SEVEN TWO FIVE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN NO BELL I GLAZER NO
HERTZBERG. NO JACKSON. MCGUIRE
I PORTANTINO. NO STERN. SEEING
NO HANDS RAISED BUYS TWENTY
THREE KNOWS FOURTEENTH THE
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM THIRTY
EIGHT AB SEVEN THIRTY TO PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BELL I.
GLAZER I HERTZBERG I NIELSEN.
STERN THE NEW HANDS RAISED FIVE
THIRTY THREE KNOWS WHEN THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING TO FILE
ITEM. THIRTY NINE NINE SEVEN
NINE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALLEN I BELL I. DON.
GLAZER. STERN UMBERG. I LIKE
CASCADE. I SEE SENATOR BATES
AND SENATOR MORLOCK WILL GO TO
SENATOR BATES FIRST. IT IS YOUR
BASE AB NINE SEVENTY NINE NO.
BATES NO CENTER MORLOCK.
MOORLACH AB NINE SEVEN NINE NO.
MORLOCK NO. I TWENTY SIX KNOWS
EIGHT THE MEASURE PASSES MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM FORTY THREE AB
TWO ZERO FOUR THREE PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BELL I
GLAZER. I NIELSEN. SKINNER. I
STERN. SEEING THEIR HANDS
RAISED BY THIRTY THREE NO ZERO
ON THE URGENCY I THIRTY THREE
NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
MOVING TO FILE ITEM FORTY ONE
AB THIRTEEN OH FOUR PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. WELL. FIVE
GLAZER. FIVE HERTZBERG. I
NIELSEN. OKAY NIELSEN NO.
SKINNER I STERN. SEEING NO
HANDS RAISED FIVE THIRTY SIX
KNOWS ONE THE MEASURE PASSES
FILE ITEM FORTY FOUR TWENTY ONE
FOURTEEN PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ALLEN. BELL I GLAZER
NO HERTZBERG. JACKSON. RUBIO.
SKINNER. I STERN SINGLE HANDS
RAISED EYES TWENTY TWO KNOWS
TWELVE THE MEASURE PASSES FILE
ITEM FORTY SIX AB TWO TWO ONE
EIGHT PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. WELL I GLAZER. I
SKINNER. I STERN SEEING NO
HANDS RAISED BY TWENTY EIGHT
NINE KNOWS NINE MAJOR KERRY'S
FILE ITEM FORTY SEVEN AB TWO
TWO EIGHT SEVEN PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. HI. BELL I
GLAZER. I INNER. I STERN. C. NO
HANDS REYES EYES THIRTY EIGHT
NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
MOVING TO FILE ITEM. FIFTY
SEVEN TWO ZERO THREE SEVEN
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALLEN. I FELL HI CABALLERO. I
DODD. GALGIANI I GLAZER NO HER
TADO. WELL TADO. HURTADO KNOWN.
RUBIO I SKINNER. I STERN NUMBER
I C. NO HANDS RAISED EYES
TWENTY FIVE KNOWS TWELVE THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING ON TO
FILE ITEM. EIGHTY TWO FOURTEEN
FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. FILE ITEM
EIGHTY TWO BY EIGHTY TWO. HEY.
WELL I GLAZER I HER TADO. I
NIELSEN. RUBIO I SKINNER. I
STERN. NIELSEN NO C. NO HANDS
RAISED BY THIRTY TWO KNOWS FIVE
THE MEASURE PASSES MOVING TO
FILE ITEM NINETY TWO AB
FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. WELL I
GLAZER. I SKINNER. I STERN. WE
HAVE ONE HAND UP SENATOR BATES.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BATES AB
FOURTEEN FIFTY SEVEN HI BATES
OUR- FIVE THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM
ONE ZERO TWO AB TWENTY TWO
SEVENTY SIX PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. TELL HI LASER I
SKINNER. I STERN FIVE THIRTY
EIGHT NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM FORTY EIGHT AB.
TWENTY THREE SIXTY TWO PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. BELL
HI GLAZER I ROTH. SKINNER. I
STERN. SEEING NO HANDS RAISED
FIVE TWENTY SIX KNOWS ELEVENTH
THE MEASURE PASSES MOVING TO
FILE ITEM FORTY NINE AB. TWO
FOUR ZERO FIVE TWO FOUR ZERO
FIVE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. GLAZER. I HERTZBERG.
HI SKINNER. I STERN SINGLES HIT
NO HANDS RAISED EYES THIRTY
KNOWS EIGHT THE MEASURE PASSES
MOVING TO FILE ITEM FIFTY ONE
AB. TWO SEVEN SIX FIVE PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. WE
DIDN'T. I APOLOGIZE WE'RE GONNA
MOVE TO FILE ITEM FIFTY AB. TWO
FOUR FIVE TWO FOUR TWO FIVE
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
I CROSSED OUT TOO QUICK. THE
GALGIANI. GLAZER I FURTADO.
RUBIO I SKINNER. AND REYES EYES
TWENTY SIX KNOWS TEN THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING THAT FILE
ITEM FIFTY ONE AB TWO SEVEN SIX
FIVE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. DODD GLAZER. GLAZER NO
NO. SKINNER FIVE STERN. THE NEW
HANDS RAISED. TWENTY EIGHT FIVE
NINE NO THE MEASURE KEPT HOUSES
FILE ITEM FIFTY TWO AB TWENTY
NINE NINETY TWO PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. GLAZER. GLAZER
I SKINNER. I STERN SEEING NO
HANDS RAISED US THIRTY FOUR
KNOWS THREE THE MEASURE PASSES
MOVING TO FILE ITEM FIFTY FIVE
AB THIRTY ONE TWENTY ONE PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN
I. SKINNER I KERN. I SENIOR
HANDS RAISED FIVE THIRTY THREE
KNOWS THREE THE MEASURE PASSES
THOSE WERE ALL OF OUR BILLS ON
CALL MEMBERS GIVE US ONE MOMENT
AND WE WILL CONTINUE. MEMBERS
WE ARE MOVING BACK TO MOTIONS
AND RESOLUTIONS WITHOUT
OBJECTION THE FOLLOWING BILLS
WILL BE PLACED ON TODAY'S
SPECIAL CONSENT CALENDAR SB
FIVE NINETY SIX ITEM FOURTEEN.
SB NINE TWELVE FILE ITEM
SIXTEEN SB TEN SIXTY FIVE FILE
ITEM TWENTY AND SB THIRTEEN
FORTY ONE FILE ITEM TWENTY FOUR.
AT THIS TIME WILL TAKE UP THE
SPECIAL CONSENT CALENDAR. MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL 596-912-1060 FIVE AND THE
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN FORTY ONE.
THE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL ON SPECIAL CONSENT
CALENDAR. ALLEN. I ARCHULETA. I
ATKINS FIVE WELL I BRADFORD I
HAVE A OTHER. I DODD. I DURAZO
HI GALGIANI. I GLAZER I
GONZALEZ. HI HERTZBERG AYE HILL
AYE HUESO. HI HER TADO HI
JACKSON I LEYVA AYE MCGUIRE AYE
MITCHELL. I MONEY I NIELSEN. I
CAN FIVE PORTANTINO FIVE ROTH
FIVE RUBIO. I SKINNER. HI STERN.
NUMBER I WHITE HOUSE SKI. I
WIENER HI WE ARE NOW MOVING TO
OUR MEMBERS VOTING REMOTELY
MEMBERS THIS IS THE SPECIAL
CONSENT CALENDAR. MADAM
SECRETARY FACE. BATES SPECIAL
CONSENT CALENDAR HIGH BATES I
GORGEOUS. FORGE'S SPECIAL
CONSENT CALENDAR ARE GORGEOUS I
CHIANG. THANKS SPECIAL CONSENT
HI CHIANG HI DOLLY. DALY
SPECIAL CONSENT HI DALLY FIVE
GROWTH. AS SPECIAL CONSENT AYE
GROVE AYE. MELENDEZ. MELENDEZ
SPECIAL CONSENT I MELENDEZ HI
MORLOCK. SPECIAL CONSENT ONLINE
MORLOCK HI NIELSEN MORALE A
NUMBER OF SPECIAL CONCERN MIGHT.
MORALE AYE WILK BOOKS SPECIAL
CONSENT HI. WILK I FIVE THIRTY
EIGHT NO ZERO THE CONSENT
CALENDAR HAS BEEN ADOPTED. WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO ANNOUNCEMENTS
OF COMMITTEES. MATT SENATOR
JACKSON THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES THE SENATE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE WILL I HEAR
ONE BILL AT TWO THIRTY IN ROOM
FORTY TWO- OH THREE- DON'T KNOW
HOW LONG IT'S GOING TO BE BUT-
IT'S A SIGNIFICANT ONE SO WE
WILL BE STARTING PROMPTLY AT
TWO THIRTY IN ROOM FORTY TWO OH
THREE. THANK YOU CENTER JACKSON.
THAT THEIR WEDDING THINK.
SENATOR MITCHELL. MADAM
PRESIDENT BUDGET FISCAL REVIEW
WILL CONVENE UPON ADJOURNMENT
OF JUDICIARY. THANK YOU SENATOR
MITCHELL. ON THE FLOOR IF THERE
IS NO OTHER THAT IS LEGAL. WHAT
A GERMAN YOU WANT ME TO. ONE
THERE IS NO FOR IF THERE IS NO
FOR THE BUSINESSMEN AND PRO
TEMP THE DESK IS CLEAR SENATE
PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO MUCH
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR THE WORK TODAY LET ME
EXPRESS MY GREAT APPRECIATION
TO THE DESK STAFF THE I. T.
STAFF- AND CERTAINLY TO OUR
SERGEANTS ODD. YOU KNOW YOU'VE
DONE INCREDIBLE JOB YESTERDAY
TODAY ROLLING WITH THE
CHALLENGES AND THE ISSUES THAT
COME UP AND I JUST WANT TO MAKE
SURE AND THANK YOU AND
ACKNOWLEDGE YOU WHILE WE'RE IN
THE MIDST OF THIS WE WERE ABLE
TO GET THROUGH FOR SENATE BILLS
TODAY TWENTY ONE ASSEMBLY BILLS.
WITH ABOUT A HUNDRED. SO BILLS
LEFT LET'S HOPE THAT MANY OF
OUR BILLS WILL COME BACK ON
CONCURRENCE AND MOVE QUICKLY-
ABOUT A HUNDRED AB'S LEFT AND-
WE'RE CONTINUING TO TRY TO FIND
WAYS TO. BE EFFICIENT AND WORK
FAST I KNOW THAT WE HAVE
COMMITTEE MEETINGS LET ME THANK
ALL OF YOU COLLEAGUES. FOR THE
WORK YOU'RE GOING TO CONTINUE
TO DO TODAY. THE NEXT FLOOR
SESSION WILL BE TOMORROW SUNDAY
AUGUST THIRTIETH TWENTY TWENTY
AT TEN AM. THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU MADAM FOR
TEMP MEMBERS JUST TO LET YOU
KNOW THAT PLEASE PLAN TO WORK
LATE TOMORROW SUNDAY AND LATE
ON MONDAY HAVE A GREAT EVENING.
THE SENATE WILL BE ADJOURNED
AND WE WILL RECONVENE ON SUNDAY
TOMORROW AT TEN AM.